young immigrants arriving on these
shores who feel her warmth and
generosity and of course some of them
who end up as her ministers
i also want to
thank prince charles and prince william
the duke of cambridge for opening
parliament on her behalf during her
majesty's 70-year reign this country has
been
the best place in the world to grow up
and grow old yet
yet during these seven decades mandatory
speaker the british people have overcome
major challenges time and time again
man deputy uh speaker we have now just
lived through
what i'm sure you will agree has been an
incredibly difficult period
after years of sacrifice by people up
and down the country
this queen's speech focuses our
attention exactly where it should be
the future
the future full of promise
will again
not be without its challenges both at
home
and of course overseas our country
needed a queen speech that rises to the
scale of the challenge we face
and we have delivered it
our communities
our communities needed a queen speech
that keeps them safe secure
and prosperous and we will deliver it
and of course our constituents needed a
queen speech
that shows them the door of opportunity
is always open to them
and we will deliver it our relentless
focus madam deputy is delivery delivery
delivery
before i outline how our legislative
program is making sure that this country
remains the best place to grow up and
grow old i would just like to reaffirm
this government solidarity with the
people of ukraine
i'm pleased to say that all ukrainian
children and young people arriving in
the united kingdom have the right to
access state education whilst in the uk
with memories of my own childhood
mandate speaker leaving saddam hussein's
iraq and building a new life here
i know how important education is to
helping young people integrate into
their new communities
but not only do we uh i'll give way to
them
thank the secretary for that and he's
absolutely right to say that there's no
better place in the world to live other
than this great united kingdom of great
britain and northern ireland always
better together but just to say this to
the minister uh our suggestion can he
confirm when it comes to education
through the government policies and the
queen speaks at every step will be taken
to ensure that every child in this
united kingdom of great britain and
northern will achieve their academic
success that every person who is on the
willingness for health will have a
better health system and every elderly
person who's dependent on a better
income for for energy food and and heat
at those things would also be part of
the queen speech thank you
i'm grateful to the member for
strengthening i think he speaks uh for
the whole of northern ireland when he
says the focus has to be on education
and health care and those public
services that the people of northern
ireland so
badly need to be delivered upon
but
not only do we need to make sure
mandatory speaker that uh ukrainian
refugees are well integrated well we
need to give them the same skills that
we are giving our children so that they
can take it
but take on the challenges of the future
and i just want to take this opportunity
to commend
schools and local authorities across
england for rising to that challenge of
welcoming and supporting children
arriving from ukraine and offering
thousands of them a school place
in these same schools managed speaker
that are at the heart
of our plans to level up
one of the first bills produced this
session
in the other place is the school's bill
delivering a stronger school system that
works for every child no matter where
they were born or live
in our country it will work alongside
close to 5 billion pounds of investment
for our ambitious multi-year education
recovery plan investing in what we know
works teacher training tutoring and
extra educational opportunities
including of course extra hours for
those who've got less least time left in
education the 16 to 19 year old students
manager speaker the evidence is clear
that our plan is working and the
recovery is happening primary pupils
recovering around 0.1 months in reading
and 0.9 months in maths since the summer
combined with our 7 billion pound cash
increase in the total cost schools
budget by 2024-25 not 10 years ago but
compared to 21 22 we are giving schools
the resources they need to focus on
student outcomes
it is money that will help schools
increase teachers pay including
delivering on our manifesto pledge of 30
000 pounds starting salary money that
will help schools deliver resources for
students and money that will help
schools meet inflationary pressures in
these uncertain times
but there is more to do with the speaker
because as it stands today
too many children leave primary school
unable to meet the expected standards in
reading writing and mathematics despite
the remarkable progress in the last
decade
through our bill
by 2030
90
of primary school children will achieve
the expected standard reading writing
and maths and the percentage
and the percentage of children meeting
the expected standard in the worst
performing areas which need the most
help will have increased by over a third
to meet
our ambitious targets the school's bill
will go further taking steps to make
children safe
addressing standards and attendance
all underpinned by a fairer and stronger
school system
and because our best multi-academy trust
that family of schools delivering
improvement in schools and in areas
where poor performance had become
entrenched by 2030 we want all schools
either in a strong multi-academy trust
or with plans to join or form one
madam deputy speaker
our ambitions are
i will be afraid and i thank the
secretary of state for his uh uh
allowing me to intervene he's making a
very powerful point is he aware that in
my area the strong odyssey trust which
runs a successful townley girls grammar
school is already ahead of the game on
this one and has taken over the failing
era school and made it king henry school
and are determined to make it a great
success
i'm grateful for my friend i certainly
am aware of the odyssey trust and indeed
it is exactly that that uh
passion
for
uh transforming young people's lives uh
that
we need them on this journey and i know
they and many other grammar schools uh i
think 90 of of 165 grammar schools have
already uh joined those families of
schools will do
the same uh madame deputy speaker our
ambitions are for all children including
those with special educational needs and
disabilities who may need additional
support to reach their potential
the send and alternative provision green
paper published in march sets out our
ambitions for children and young people
with scnd our proposals will build a
more inclusive and financially
sustainable system that delivers the
right support in the right place at the
right time for every child and young
person and we want to establish a new
single national send and authentic
provision system and are investing now
to secure the future sustainability for
that system we have also set out clear
roles and responsibilities and of course
accountability measures for everybody
working in the send and alternative
provision sector this includes the new
national and local inclusion dashboards
to give a timely and i think transparent
picture of how the system is performing
across education health and care which
is what parents have asked us to do
mr speaker children and young people are
the future of our country but they
cannot succeed
if they are not safe and secure at home
that is why under my stewardship the
department for education has been laser
focused on families
with strong families we can make a
fairer society one in which children can
escape
the quicksand of disadvantage
with strong families we help make sure
that every child can grow up happy
and of course
with that vital opportunity
and we are taking steps to strengthen
families
we're funding 75 local authorities half
of england's local authorities with the
highest levels of child deprivation to
create family hubs and transform that
support for
families
our investment includes a focus on
babies
children and families in the early years
with funding for breastfeeding parenting
and parent infant mental health services
where families need more help
we've expanded the supporting families
program so that up to three hundred
thousand families with more complex
needs can work with a key worker to help
resolve problems i'll give way to honor
blake i'm grateful to my right
honourable friend for giving way safety
is at the heart of so many uh
parents when they send their child into
settings and i welcome the the family
hub and last week a child died in a
nursery in my constituency and i send my
my heartfelt condolences to the family
it was a heartbreaking time and
10 years ago another constituent lost
her childhood in a nursery she's
done and she was done and john thompson
they set up in in mummy's name for their
child melis trust and now have mother's
mark which accredits people in nurseries
staff in nurseries and who have got
pediatric first aid training would my
write a honourable friend agree with me
that safety in nurseries and child care
settings is vitally important that
pediatric first aid is vitally important
for members of staff to know how to deal
with these emergencies and would you and
would you join me in importing it
there are a lot of speakers trying to
get into this debate really a lot so
interventions do need to be
really very brief
thank you secretary of state i'm
grateful for my honourable friend i
absolutely agree with her on millie's
mark
and of course child safety nurseries is
vital and non-negotiable
uh and i'm very grateful for her for uh
bringing uh the accreditation to the
house's attention uh and of course as i
was saying madame speaker where families
do need that additional help uh we've
expanded supporting families program so
that those 300 000 families with more
complex needs can work with a key worker
to help resolve uh problems and of
course to improve uh the lives and
outcomes i'll just make a little bit
more headway i will take her into
version with pleasure
to improve the lives and outcomes of
children with their social worker we
need to make some fundamental changes uh
to the current system i look forward to
seeing the recommendations from the
independent review of children's social
care which will be published in the
coming weeks the mcallister review it is
a once in a generation opportunity madam
deaf speaker to improve outcomes for
children and families this government is
also acutely aware of how important
child care is to both children and their
moms and dads
in each of the past three years we have
spent in excess of 3.5
billion pounds a year
on our early education entitlements and
we will continue to support families
with their child care costs and at the
spending review last october we
announced additional funding for the
early years entitlements worth 160
million uh in 2223 180 million in 23 24
170 million 24 25 compared to 21 22
financial year
providing quality child care
is vital for children to develop from
the earliest opportunity
but
there is another point to all of this
madame de speaker we know that women
are most likely to shoulder high child
care costs
the aim of the government's universal
credit child care offer
is to support parents for whom paid
child care is a barrier to work to
overcome
that barrier
this works alongside the tax free child
care helping parents
return to work and making sure it pays
to work
for every eight pounds parents pay into
their child care account we add 2 pounds
up to a maximum of 2 000 pounds in top
up per year for each child up to the age
of 11 and up to 4 000 pounds per
disabled child until they are 17.
overall mandatory speaker the government
has spent
over four billion pounds each year for
the past five years on child care in the
united kingdom through child care offers
led by
my department department of education of
course tax-free child care and the
employer support
child care
addressing
this issue means women
can if they wish go back to their
careers it is fair to them and it is
good for business and the economy
mandatory speaker for
our long-term economic success
uh
will really turn on our ability to
nurture and utilize talent including new
mothers human potential
human capital is the most important
resource
on earth
to steal a phrase from my right
honourable friend the chair of the
education select committee we are
determined to build a skills rich
economy
we are committed to delivering those
skills through
massive investment and reforms to skills
and further education provision
we've already embarked
on revolutionizing the post 16 education
sector transforming apprenticeships
driving up quality
better meeting the skills needs of
employers through more flexible training
models we've launched t levels boosting
access to high quality technical
education
for thousands of young people and of
course creating our skilled workforce of
the future
and madame dr speaker i will pledge to
the house to make t-levels as famous as
a-levels
watch this space
in the last parliamentary session we
successfully passed the skills and
post-16 education act to do just this
this act alongside our wider reforms
including an additional 3.8 billion
pound investment in skills over this
parliament
rightly rightly my view places
employers at the heart of the skills
system
supporting our ambition for everyone to
be able to access the training they need
to move into highly skilled jobs
there is of course
a crucial role for our universities in
making sure that our country remains the
best place to grow up and
given the link to future earnings and
opportunities to grow old too
we will bring forward further
legislation through a higher education
reform bill to ensure that our post 18
education system promotes real social
mobility is financially sustainable and
will support people to get the skills
they need to meet their career
aspirations and help grow the economy
alongside this i'll give away
thank the secretary of state for what
he's saying but will in the the bill
he's bringing forward will he address
the injustice that muslim students face
because that at the moment they cannot
access student loans
and
islamic
uh
suitable loans were promised
by david cameron in 2014 and they are
still waiting will you address this
i'm grateful to the honorable lady and
uh i made that pledge to the education
select committee um when i went before
them a few weeks ago we are looking at
how we deliver uh against that
um uh and as i was saying madame dr
speaker uh we will bring forward further
legislation um through the higher
education reform bill to ensure that our
post 18 education system does promote
real social mobility including the point
the honourable lady quite rightly raises
and is financially sustainable now
alongside this uh we are meeting our
manifesto commitment uh to challenge any
restriction of lawful speech and
academic freedom
the higher education freedom of speech
bill will strengthen existing freedoms
of speech duties and will directly
address gaps within the existing law
including the lack of a clear
enforcement mechanism commander speaker
for both universities and technical
education one of the most important
policies we're implementing as part
of the skills and post 16 education act
is the paradigm shifting lifelong
loan entitlement a new and flexible
skill system it will provide people with
an entitlement equivalent to four years
of post-18 education to use over their
lifetime in
modules or as a whole
worth 37 000 pounds in today's money
we are writing a new chapter
no matter speaker i think we're writing
a new book
in skills education
this will give people the ability to
train retrain and upskill in response to
changing skills needs and employment
patterns in a dynamic economy
colleagues where sectors can be crushed
and reborn in double time this has to be
our priority the world is different now
to when i entered the world of work and
business madam dick speaker it is
different now than when
i became
an mp 12 years ago we must not just keep
up with a changing world we must lead
the change this squeeze speech lays out
how we will do this
as i said at the start of my statement
i'm focused on delivering against the
ambitious targets we have set ourselves
across skills
schools and families and holding
ourselves to account against those i
believe sharing our plans and
performance data
is a key lever to drive rapid
improvement through the complex systems
we oversee i'll give way to honor them
very grateful to the minister for giving
way he talks about skills so important
would he recognize the real crisis we
face when it comes to uh skills in the
health service in particular the number
of people we lack in prevention and
treatment of cancer would he look at and
would the secretary of state for health
his friend sat next to him look at the
amendment in my name on the order paper
which calls for a strategy to tackle the
cancer backlog in particular the fact
that over a third of my constituents
with cancer are waiting more than two
months for their first treatment
i'm i'm grateful uh for uh uh members uh
intervention and i think a couple things
to say on that one obviously uh i know
that the
health will address this but his
priority his laser-like focus is on the
backlog and dealing with that uh backlog
but also the investment
in uh cumbria and versa cumbria in terms
of those clinical
uh training and needs that
is happening for his constituents uh as
well
as i said mental speaker the start of my
statement
i am focused on
that delivery and i absolutely am
passionate in believing that
the
performance data is key as a lever to
drive rapid improvement through a
complex system
in education or in health and that
transparency as we did with vaccine
we will do again in education and health
and i've committed to publishing a
delivery plan setting out what we will
achieve and a performance dashboard
showing
progress of the house and the country
can hold us to account i've already
written to all schools stating that we
will publish data on uptake of the
national tutoring program this summer
many schools have helpfully given us
access to their attendance data and i'm
conducting a trial over the coming weeks
to share that data back in a way i think
that prompts helpful actions in schools
and of course in local authorities
madame dr speaker the spirit
with which our education sector
responded to the pandemic demonstrated
why this is the best country to grow up
in
it is a spirit i will give way to honor
it
i'm grateful to the secretary of state
for giving way and when he's talking
about the best place for young people to
grow up in could you explain to me why
there isn't a single placement of
special provision for children at risk
across the country as my constituent is
experiencing right now
i'm grateful for the honor she raises a
very important point partly why um the
mcallister review is so important into
children's social care and i'll be
saying more on that uh in the coming uh
weeks
manager speaker uh as i was
just
praising the incredible spirit uh
of our education front line those
brilliant teachers uh school leaders and
of course support staff never forget the
support staff
demonstrates why this is the best
country to grow up and it is a spirit we
see across our public and private sector
including of course the national health
service working with our great vaccine
companies which has led the way in
protecting lives and livelihoods in the
battle against covet thanks to the
astonishing
rollout of the vaccine and booster
programs we were the first european
nation to protect half of our population
with at least one dose and the first
major european nation to boost thanks to
my right honourable friend half of our
population too uh following the
unprecedented challenges placed on the
nhs by covert we will spend more than 8
billion pounds
from 22 23 to 2425 supported by uh the
revenue
uh from the health and social care levy
to clear the covered elective backlogs
but we must be honest we must be honest
man the speaker our nhs faces long-term
challenges too
including an aging population and people
increasingly living with multiple
long-term conditions
at this critical moment we must now
seize the opportunity to put our health
care system on a more sustainable path
for the future whilst meeting the
immediate
urgent recovery challenges we face the
health and care bill has created the
structures for this sustainable future
at the same time as my right honourable
friend the health secretary will outline
later we will publish draft legislation
to reform the mental health act so
patients suffering from mental health
conditions have greater control over
their treatment and receive the dignity
and respect that they deserve
i know
i know the nhs is an institution that
makes people proud to be british
i share this
i would say this entire government
shares this sentiment and that is why we
are safeguarding its sustainable future
madam speaker in closing
this was a queen speech filled with
substantial policies not least those
that give young people the education
they need to succeed in life
policies that will provide more rungs on
the ladder of opportunity
and opportunity
for older people who want a chance to
learn and retrain
policies that put skills at the heart of
our economy to unleash its potential
policies that back our public services
so they can deliver what our country
needs policies that sustain the truth
that this is the best place in the world
to grow up and grow old in thank you
very much
order before i call the um shadow uh
secretary of state it will be obvious
that there are a large number of
speakers um wishing to participate in
this debate
and
um i won't put a time limit on to start
with but i will be expecting
that speakers will be
maximum
five minutes
shadow secretary of state bridget
phillips
thank you madam deputy speaker it's a
pleasure to speak in today's debate on
behalf of the opposition and to set out
the contrast between a conservative
government which has spent 12 long years
failing britain and a labour party
determined to make our country the best
place to grow up and the best place to
grow old
as the leader of the opposition set out
last week at the heart of the
government's programme there is a
poverty of ambition for our public
services entirely inadequate for the
challenges we face
we see that in the ongoing refusal by
the government to commit to a children's
recovery plan to support children after
the disruption of the pandemic on
anything like the scale which either
their advisor sir kevin collins or the
labour party has set out now i remain
disappointed but sadly not surprised
this is after all the government that
reopened the pubs before it reopened
schools
12 years in and the conservatives are
out of ideas out of touch and out of
steam the challenges we face as a
country demand division leadership
energy drive determination
of course there are challenges which
every country faces and now there are
the challenges bequeathed by the
pandemic and its legacy but there are
also the challenges brought to us by 12
years of conservative failure and what
they all have in common is that every
single one of them is a challenge from
which this government flinches
a generation of children has been
through the education system in this
country under conservative governments
since 2010
their experience is the core narrative
of this government's failure not simply
a failure to deliver but a failure to
think a failure to plan a failure to
resource and a failure to learn
i think of what a child starting school
in 2010 would have seen in that time
real terms cuts to funding per pupil
secondary school classes at their
largest for a generation
hundreds of thousands more children
eligible for free school meals
school buildings repaired cancelled
postponed
hundreds of days lost to the pandemic
botched examinations not for one year
but two and now this historic failure to
invest in the children's recovery plan
that the government's own expert
recommended and which our children
desperately need
madam deputy speaker the only thing on
the up under this government is child
poverty
and now as that child that young person
looks ahead to university and the years
that follow
they can see higher costs than ever
before stretching almost to retirement
comparisons of what it was like going to
school under a conservative government i
went to school under a labour government
i left my secondary school in 2005
which had an 11 pass rate one in three
teachers were supply teachers wasn't
that real legacy of a labour government
of a failed generation
[Applause]
madam deputy speaker the last labour
government transformed the life chances
of children right across our country
child poverty down investment in our
schools schools rebuilt teachers
properly supported that is a record of
which we are very proud
[Music]
this is a generation of children madam
deputy speaker let down from primary
school right the way through to
university a generation of children
failed by the conservatives and i can
tell you why they've been failed because
madam deputy speaker the government has
stopped thinking in terms of children
people parents and families
too long in power they are mistaking
changing institutions and changing
regulations for improving the lives of
our people
just look at the schools bill published
last week i genuinely hope for better
but what do we find
narrow in scope hollow in ambition thin
on policy 32 clauses on the governance
of academies 15 on funding arrangements
and on funding what a sorry site it is
to see a conservative chancellor and a
conservative secretary of state seeking
plaudits
merely for aiming to restore by 2024 a
level of real terms school funding
achieved by the last labour government
when his own government has spent a
decade slicing it away
and the newspapers this weekend sadly
made too clear that whichever children
the secretary of state cares about it
doesn't appear that it's always the
children in england state schools
we learned that he is concerned that the
success of our young people in accessing
their first choice universities from
england state schools the schools which
the vast majority of children attend the
schools for which he is primarily
responsible
is evidence in his words of tilting the
system away from private schools at
which he tells us he is so proud
tilting the system
what an extraordinary remark by the
secretary of state for education about
the success of students in state schools
in our country
but if that were not enough the next day
brought further clarification not only
does he appear concerned by the growing
success of state-educated children and
entering their universities of first
choice
apparently he doesn't even appear
bothered that their schools are
crumbling around them
let me quote his own officials within
the last two months and i quote
some sites a risk to life too many
costly and energy and efficient repairs
rather than rebuilds and rebuild demand
three times supply
some sites are risk to life
children are being educated in schools
which are a risk to life and his
government hasn't lifted a finger madam
deputy speaker the children of this
country are being failed by an education
secretary more interested in appealing
to conservative party members than in
ensuring the success of our young people
i'll happily give away to um the ladies
made two points in in the last two
minutes one about school funding for for
buildings and the second about children
for private schools perhaps i could have
with the deputy speakers permission i
test both one will she welcome the over
a million pounds given to carl's grammar
school in sleeford to improve um the
school building and facilities and
secondly i went to i went i went to a i
went to a comprehensive school
in middlesbrough
until i was 16.
just before i was 16 i met somebody out
when i was out on a walk in the hills
who went to gordon a brilliant public
school they gave me
an ordinary working-class girl from
middlesbrough a scholarship for which
i'm internally grateful were i to have
applied for oxford university which i
didn't should i be penalized as a
working-class girl for that scholarship
could i just emphasize that
interventions should be briefed bridget
phillipson thank you madame speaker i'm
afraid i did i didn't catch most of that
but all i would all i would say once
again it was a bit hard to hear the
honourable lady all i'll say again is
that the last labour government rebuilt
schools right across our country that
has sadly not been the record of the
last 12 years
mr madam deputy speaker the next labour
government will build a britain where
children come first where we put
children and growing up at the heart of
how we think about the future of our
country where we build britain which is
the best place to grow up and the best
place to grow old where young people
leave education ready for work and ready
for life
i thank her for giving way since we're
all talking about when we're at school i
think i'm probably the only member of
this house who who went to who grew up
under a tory government and was at
school in in 2010
recently
and will will she agree with me that the
reality of it was that our class sizes
were the biggest that they'd ever been
on record our school buildings were
falling apart and all we had to look
forward to was the prospect of our ema
having been cut
and having us go to university and pay
nine grand a year on tuition fees
[Music]
absolutely my honorable friend is
absolutely right the last labour
government transformed the life chances
of a generation and it will fall to the
next labour government to do the same
[Music]
because in a country where we think
about children as both the society and
economy of the future we build a better
britain for everyone a britain of
children and families where government
works to enable and empower that success
and in particular a britain where the
government sees the soaring cost of
child care not as a statistic to be
observed but as a problem to be solved
because that cost is crippling families
suffer financially children suffer
socially and our country suffers
economically
when the cost of child care not just for
our two and two to four year olds but
for the whole time from the end of
maternity leave to the start of
secondary school from ensuring that
parents can afford whether to go back
can choose to afford whether to go back
to work to affordable breakfast clubs to
after-school activities so parents don't
always need to be at the school of the
gate schoolgate when all of that is
quite literally pricing people out of
parenting then children and families are
being failed
and that failure isn't just about the
individual children and individual
families this government fails though
there are millions of them and that's
bad enough our whole country is failed
when we let our children down
and it isn't just child care we see it
too in the government's failure to face
up to the damage their mishandling of
the pandemic did to the education of a
generation
the secretary of state's failure to
convince the chancellor to invest
properly in children's recovery from the
pandemic his failure at the last
spending round in the autumn his failure
in the spring statement his failure now
that series of failures above all else
he does or says now or in the future
those failures are what he will be
remembered for
the prime minister's own advisor had the
dignity to resign rather than accept
such failure and labour would have been
very different madam deputy speaker we
have a plan where they have failure
on the very day schools and nurseries
close to most children in march 2020 a
labour government would have started
work on three plans
an immediate plan to support children's
learning and development remotely and as
fully as possible while lockdown went on
an urgent plan to reopen schools safely
and quickly and once open again to keep
them open so children can learn together
and play together and critically a plan
to ensure that when lockdown ended
children's education and well-being did
not suffer in the long run
our children's recovery plan put
children and their futures at the heart
of how we think about moving on from the
pandemic because after all every child
in britain did more to follow the
culvert rules than our prime minister
the impact that had on the their health
and educational attainment needs
addressing and not ignoring
we would introduce breakfast clubs so
every child starts their day with a
proper meal
after-school activity so every child
gets to learn and experience art music
drama and sport
mental health support because every
report we see tells us children's
development has fallen behind in the
pandemic
continued professional development for
our teachers because every child
deserves teachers second to none in
support of their learning
targeted extra investment right from the
early years through to further education
to support the children at risk of
falling behind because attainment gaps
open up early and they need tackling
early and we would go further to lock in
the gains of a recovery program for the
long term
a national excellence program to drive
up standards in schools because every
child deserves to go to a school with
high expectations and high achievements
thousands upon thousands of new teachers
in subjects with shortages right now
because every child deserves to be
taught maths and physics by people who
love their subjects and every child
deserves to be introduced to a love of
sport music art and drama
a skills commission because every young
person needs to leave education ready
for work and ready for life
careers guidance in every school work
experience for every child because each
of us deserves to succeed at work and
labor believes government has a role to
play in making it happen
a curriculum where we teach our children
not just the past that they will inherit
but the future they will build where
they learn about the challenge of net
zero and the climate emergency we face
it is precisely because we have a plan
that we would enable our education
system to deliver it
it's why we want an approach to how our
schools are run that focuses on how on
how children achieve how children
achieve and thrive not the name on the
uniform or the hours that they are there
it's why we have a determination to see
child care not as a passing costly phase
in the lives of others but as the
foundation of opportunity in the lives
of every child and every parent
and madam deputy speaker it's sadly not
the case that as our children grow and
as they interact more and more with my
pra with my party's proudest achievement
to date the national health service
that their experience of this
government's record on public services
improves as with education so with
health a decade of failure even before
the pandemic began the national health
service did not go into this pandemic
strong well-resourced resilient no the
nhs went into the pandemic with record
waiting lists 100 000 vacancies 17 000
fewer beds than in 2010 and as my
honorable friend has rightly said it's
not that the conservatives didn't fix
the roof while the sun was shining it's
rather that they dismantled the
roof and took out the floorboards
last autumn the government announced
that they would raise tax to fund
clearing the backlog and improve social
care the tax rise happens during a cost
of living crisis sure enough but it's
not clear how they're going to manage
the rest which is why today in our in
our health service as in child care
we're paying more and getting less
the government are raising taxes on
working people in the middle of a cost
of living crisis yet patients are
expected to wait longer for care
and members opposite would do well to
remember that nhs waiting lists are at a
record six million
and ministers cannot blame the pandemic
because the figure was already at over 4
million before corvid struck
now let us think of those millions of
people waiting waiting longer than ever
before often waiting in pain and
discomfort
waiting while working or trying to find
work
waiting while walking their children to
school
waiting while trying trying to find
somewhere affordable to live
waiting while looking after their
grandchildren
waiting at a cost of themselves of
course but waiting at an astronomical
cost to our country that isn't just
financial but economic and social too
waiting for their government to give our
public services the priority they
deserve
in mental health services are on the
brink of collapse
12 years of conservative governments
have seen a quarter of mental health
beds cut and right now 1.6 million
people are waiting for mental health
treatment how on earth can any minister
defend that record
and their approach on social care is up
there with their failure on child care
too their approach isn't fair and it
won't work the less you have the more
they will take those with homes worth
150 000 will lose almost everything
while the wealthiest are protected again
it doesn't need to be this way
labor will build an nhs fit for the
future and get patients seen on time
we will provide the nhs with the staff
equipment and modern technology required
so the nhs is there for you when you
need it we will fix social care so that
those in need don't go without
our new deal for care workers will
provide fair pay and secure contracts to
plug the over 100 000 vacancies in
social care and we will transform
training to improve standards of care
across our public services labor will
build a better britain we have done it
before we will do it again
because i remember a previous
conservative government that cared
little for the challenges my family
faced a government keener on judging my
family than on supporting it and then i
saw growing up and as a young woman the
difference an incoming labour government
made
i saw a government that acted decisively
to tackle disadvantage cut child poverty
and support families and children
a generation grew up with surestart with
children's centers a generation like me
were supported after 16 with education
maintenance allowance a level of
investment in our nhs unmatched in
history waiting lists driven down from
months and years to days and weeks i saw
then in my own community the difference
those changes made and i still see it
now in the better lives of young people
who grew up with that advantage with the
support it unlocked for 12 long years
minister of ministers opposites have
failed a generation of our children
labor in power will be different because
we see britain as its people our
children our families our future
and we will never swerve for making this
country the best place to grow up and
the best place to grow old
[Applause]
order order
nominations closed at five o'clock this
afternoon
for candidates for the post of chair of
the back bench business committee
one nomination has been received
a ballot will therefore not be held
i congratulate ian means on his
re-election
as chair of the back bench business
committee
um
i remind honorable and right honourable
members of my stricture about sticking
to five minutes at least for the
opening contributions from the
backbenchers john whittingdale
thank you madam deputy speaker it's a
pleasure to speak in support of this
queen's speech
um it's tempting to respond to a number
of the points made by the right
honourable lady whose speech did sound
remarkably like a bid for the leadership
of the lay party however
however given the lack of time i want to
concentrate on just um four bills all of
which emanate from the department of
digital culture media and sport and all
of which i had a small hand in a part of
the preparation of
the first bill is a continuation the
online safety bill and i was going to
say to you madam deputy speaker but i
would welcome this opportunity because i
only had five minutes to speak on the
second reading of the online safety bill
um i will have rather less this time but
i do want to reiterate that this bill is
tremendously important and will protect
our young people as they grow up
but equally it is a pioneering piece of
legislation to introduce some regulation
of online activity and we also have an
ambition in this country to be the
technological leaders of the world and
therefore i do remain concerned that the
bill is very vague in a lot of aspects
and since the second reading i've
actually had meetings with mid-sized
platforms like pinterest and reddit and
eventbrite and tripadvisor all of whom
are committed to this country but are
concerned that whilst they want to
comply with the provisions of the bill
it is not actually clear to them what
those provisions are going to undertake
and i would once again say to the
government
that what is important here is to con
control and protect people who are at
risk not necessarily just regulate every
large platform because of their reach
that i if the honourable gentleman
forgive me i i'm under a lot of pressure
to keep this short um
my second the second bill i wanted to
touch on is the media bill which is
vital for the future of public service
broadcasting in this country a lot of
attention will be given to the
provisions for channel 4 which i welcome
although i do think that it's important
we debate those and discuss the model
that channel 4 should operate in the
future but equally contains other very
important provisions the prominence of
public service broadcasters is something
that has been argued for by itv and
channel 4 and the bbc for many years and
it is essential if we are to protect
public service broadcasters and ensure
that they are visible in a world where
there are competing channels uh
increasing in number almost every week
and equally in support of commercial
public service broadcasters can i also
add that i welcome the absence from the
queen's speech of a bill to introduce
advertising bans for hfs foods after
nine o'clock i am one who supports the
government's wish to reduce obesity but
i firmly believe that an advertising ban
would have no effect on that and at the
same time would massively affect
commercial broadcasters in this country
i also regret the absence from the bill
or provisions for radio prominence this
was an important part of the outcome of
the digital radio and audio review the
government has accepted the
recommendations from that but it seems
to have dropped out of the bill that's
something which i hope we might try and
correct during its passage and finally i
look forward in the media bill to the
inclusion of the repeal of section 40 of
the courts and crimes act
which is a sword of damocles hanging
over a free press
allowing a government in future to
impose punitive costs unless they sign
up to the government's version of
regulation
it is something which was in the
conservative manifesto to remove and i
hope very much that we will uh fulfill
that manifesto commitment in this bill
the third bill i want very briefly to
mention is the digital markets and
competition bill which of anything is
even more important to the freedmen for
press the press are at the moment in at
a disadvantage in their negotiations
with the big platforms like facebook and
google who take their content and decide
how much if anything they are going to
pay for it the digital markets unit is
being established to address that but it
needs to be put on a statutory basis it
needs to be underpinned by law i
therefore welcome the provision in the
queen's speech for a draft bill but i
hope that the government will move
forward to implement that uh legislation
as soon as possible and finally
a bill which again i i played some role
in the data bill one of the great
opportunities from britain taking back
control of its own laws is our ability
to write our own data protection laws of
course we want to ensure that people's
privacy is protected but at the same
time the existing rules are acted as a
disincentive they are overburdened some
they are not properly understood by
large numbers of small firms
particularly this is a real opportunity
to have a
modern data protection regime which
others across the world will admire and
follow and on that basis i am delighted
to support the queen's speech
s p spokesperson carol monaghan thank
you madam deputy speaker in this queen's
speech i would have expected to see some
radical interventions that are urgently
needed to tackle the cost of living
crisis to tackle climate change and to
properly support our elderly community
including elderly veterans
but
there's been a real lack of ambition in
this speech
and this government has done the
absolute opposite of making britain the
best place to grow up and grow
while they've lined their pockets of
their cronies they've limited the
opportunities of young people
they've caused then ignored the cost of
living crisis which has left many
children and elderly without enough to
get by
and they've delayed action on climate
change which arguably will have the
biggest impact on our younger
generations
for us here in scotland this really is a
tale of two governments
the scottish government is determined to
make scotland the best place in the
world to grow up and grow
regardless of household income
regardless of your social demographic
but only as an independent nation will
scotland have the levers the
decision-making powers and the full
fiscal autonomy to see this ambition
fully realised
and regardless of the heckling that's
going on in the government benches
i would have thought the um results in
the elections two weeks ago would have
shown them something maybe they would
have learned some lessons that people in
scotland more and more are waking up to
this
so comparing these two governments a
woman in in scotland who's expecting a
child is given a baby box
filled with essentials for her baby
clothes books teething toys blankets
the message is clear your baby is
important your baby is valued and your
baby is welcomed
and at the same time as a baby box has
been introduced in scotland the uk
government introduced a two-child limit
on child tax credit and universal credit
it's apparently okay
to have up to two children
beyond this if you're a low-income
household your baby is neither welcomed
nor valued by this tory government
the british pregnancy advisory service
said that over half the women it
surveyed who had an abortion in the
coronavirus pandemic
new and new of the two child limit said
that this policy was
important in their decision making
around whether or not to continue the
pregnancy
that's a pretty damning
piece of um evidence so it's no support
it's no surprise that since 2016
when mothers who were expecting babies
um who would be born after this policy
came into force
it's no surprise that there's been a
sharp increase in the number of
abortions taking place
women choosing abortions because they
cannot afford to have a baby
the best place to grow up
in scotland the scottish government has
introduced the scottish child payment 20
pounds a week for every eligible child
and this will be rising to 25 pounds a
week and this is mitigating some of the
worst impacts for families but frankly
the progressive policies of the scottish
government
must be matched with similar
interventions from westminster
last week we were treated to the
honourable member for rashfield denise
eastwood's comments who said that people
were only using food banks because they
can't budget and can't cook a meal from
scratch
today gareth mason the head chef at
absolute bistros in in west totten has
said that the honourable members
comments were tone-deaf and insulting
and he set about to prove this by
cooking seven every everyday meals such
as spaghetti napoli
beans on toast
baked potato order can i just
check that the honourable lady has
informed the honourable gentleman that
she was going to refer to him perhaps
just a reminder that that's that's what
she should do
if he speaker i haven't but i wasn't
making a point of order i was referring
to something that was said in a debate
and has been said in the press
i don't like it
gareth mason said
i've come to the conclusion it's a load
of rubbish these meals i've done
as soon as you put any protein or dairy
into them it's not feasible to do for
30p
if you eat beans and toast for every
meal it might work but even if you had
cheese and toast the cheese would be
more than 30 p
on its own and that's
before you consider the cooking cost of
the food absolutely the member for
ashfield was very clear that he offered
anyone from the opposition benches to go
and join him down in ashfield given the
problems she's outlined is she planning
on going down to see what happens in
nashville to see how that food functions
i would love to do that but more than
that i look forward to the honourable
member from ashfields cooking book
because i'm sure that be a really
popular volume and you know i'll even
buy some copies for my own food bank if
we think that we can be making uh meals
for 30 pence a day
incredible
the fact is that people on low income
or on benefits are far superior with
managing their finances because they
have to be
according to jack monroe the bootstrap
cook who gave evidence to working
pensions committee the impact of the
cost of living crisis on millions of
children living in poverty in britain
today is going to be in some cases fatal
this is first and foremost due to the
rise in the cost of everyday essentials
not because families on low incomes
can't budget or can't cook a meal from
scratch
but it gets worse
the minister for safeguarding said in
sky news today that people struggling
with the cost of living should just take
on more errors or get better paid job
this shows how detached this government
is from the lived reality of so many
people in our communities that we
represent
because hunger impacts the ability of
children to learn
they can't as one of the members have
said they can't concentrate they can't
think it's and i know of teachers that
are keeping cereal bars and snacks in
their desk drawers to give to children
to make sure they have something in
their tummies
as secretary of state said in his
opening remarks he talked about
extracurricular activities and i think
every member here understands the
importance of these
but for families that are just about
managing they're just about managing to
pay bills and to feed their children the
things that will go are the little
extras are the sports clubs are the
activities are the birthday parties the
days out the holidays in fact all the
little things that together make
childhood so special
that enrich their experience and their
ambitions
it's good to hear the secretary of state
also talk today about the importance of
teachers
as a former teacher myself i know the
difference that good teachers can make
to young people
and it is good to hear him talking about
his ambition to make the starting salary
for teachers thirty thousand a year
is they'll only be three thousand below
what scottish teachers currently start
out on in 33 000 a year
in scotland we want to create a more
equal society
and one way we aim to do this is for
through widening rather restricting the
opportunities for our young people once
they leave school
the scottish government's young person
guarantee
ensures every young person from 16 to 24
has a chance to go to university or
college with no tuition fees
secure an apprenticeship or a high
quality job
and it's significant that in scotland we
have the highest proportion of young
people with positive destinations post
school anywhere in the uk
but time and time again we see this tory
government undermining progress towards
a better society for our young people
they talk of
uncapping aspiration yet just a couple
of weeks ago their own social mobility
commission chair stated that less girls
are studying physics than boys as they
dislike hard
maths perpetuating outdated and harmful
gender stereotypes about girls
particularly girls in stem something
that's close to my heart is no way to
uncap aspiration or ambition
and we have students in
england
students who are considering their
careers and also considering whether
they're willing to take on a lifetime of
debt
and this government's
equality analysis on its reforms to
student finance have found that its
changes would likely
negatively impact graduates from
disadvantaged backgrounds
whilst benefiting those already more
privileged
not in fact increasing social mobility
this government's making policy
decisions which will hinder
opportunity
and
to the obvious detriment of so many
young people i could talk about brexit
about lack of mobility across europe now
about international collaborations that
have been lost
but i want to speak a little about our
elderly community
according to the centre for aging one in
five pensioners over two million people
living in our communities are living in
relative
poverty and many also worse than that in
abject
poverty
this represents an increase of over 200
000
just in the last 12 months and the
problem is only going to get worse
the report also
presented a stark picture showing there
are up to 10 year differences in
lifespan
of wealthy and poor pensioners
pensioners have been abandoned by this
government which scrapped the pension
triple walk
with the rising cost of living
pensioners are going to be amongst the
hardest hit with some already having to
resort to measures such as we heard last
week spending days on buses just to keep
warm or eating one meal a day
the best place to grow old
many uk citizens including a significant
number of veterans are also living in
poverty abroad as a result of the freeze
of overseas pensions
so their pension is frozen
at the point at which they moved
now other countries have asked for a
reciprocal arrangement countries such as
canada have formally requested a
reciprocal arrangement consider m
covering pension operating but this uk
government has declined
and of course we've also got amongst our
pensioners we have a veterans as well
those who have given their very best of
themselves in order to serve
we have a duty of care to those
pensioners and i want to say um i want
to talk briefly about one particular
group of pensioners i know has a support
on both sides of the house and this is a
nuclear test veterans the nuclear test
veterans who are dwindling in numbers
who have been who have had a lifetime of
health issues and have received neither
a medal recognition or compensation the
only country not to have compensated
their nuclear test veterans surely we
can do better for this small group of
individuals
the snp scottish government are doing
what they can to support households
during these difficult times
fully mitigating bedroom tax
mitigating council tax
doubling the scottish child payment free
tuition free prescriptions free
school meals for all primary school
children
but just as scotland
tries to mitigate the worst excesses of
this tory government the scottish
government are
cut with a are suffering budget cuts by
this touring government
a lack of powers for the scottish
government means that we can only really
really deal with things around the edge
we can deal with the symptoms of poverty
not the deep rooted causes of inequality
in our society that delivers child
poverty and pension poverty
only
with full independence can we realise
our ambition for our children
for our young people and our pensioners
said david evernote thank you mr speaker
and it's great pleasure to have the
opportunity to participate in this
debate today
in support of the queen's speech and i
want to focus my attention in my speech
to education as part of the session on
making britain the best place to grow up
and to grow old in
however i appreciate inflation and the
cost of living at top priorities for my
constituents at this time and the
government needs to do more to help
alleviate the consequences of rising
prices and i believe that they will
i believe the uk is and always has been
one of the best places to grow up in and
i'm convinced it remains a great place
for all ages to live in
people from my own background have been
fortunate through education and
resulting opportunities especially with
great state schools and teachers to be
able to reach our potential
however despite the financial fantastic
opportunities and the increase in
finance the government has put in uh to
our education system there are a number
of issues that still need to be
addressed and i know my right honourable
friend the secretary of state for
education is determined to tackle these
we congratulate him on the white paper
march 22 and i know he aims to improve
standards and achievement and i look
forward to the school's bill coming to
this house where we can participate in
it
i work both as a teacher and a lecturer
so i know how important vitally
important it is that every child every
child receives the best possible
education
education and social mobility have
always been key political issues for
myself and i passionately believe that
every child deserves the best possible
start in life
i'm a strong supporter of lifetime
learning as education is not just for
the young but all age groups
particularly for all age groups
particularly in this time of a rapidly
changing world as we all know parents
are the primary educator in children's
lives
parents education level has also a
significant impact on their children's
success and this can significantly
affect opportunities later in life
however talent
and hard work alone
should determine how far people can go
whoever you are wherever you come from
whatever your background
opportunity is the key and this
government believes passionately in
opportunity
and i believe talent has spread
widespread widespread across our nation
unfortunately there's certain groups in
areas where opportunity is not open to
all for many and varied reasons so fair
funding accountability a safe
environment and attendance are vital and
i look forward to further debates on the
bill
in my constituency bexar heath and
crayford we're very fortunate to have a
diverse and fantastic
collection of schools
both primary and secondary level the
borough is a social mobility hotspot we
have a wide variety of education
offerings available including church
grammar comprehensive and single sex
schools all of which achieve good
results and give excellent opportunities
young people to develop their talents
children across specsy from both
advantage and disadvantage
backgrounds achieve great results at
school and benefit from the wide range
of opportunities we have an excellent
further local education uh provider in
bexley campus of london southeast
colleges giving a wide range of choices
and courses
visiting recently i particularly enjoyed
the media and special needs facility
last week i also visited woodside
academy which is special school
supporting children from the age of four
to 19 with a wide range of learning
difficulties and is part of the london
southeast colleges trust another example
of working together
they are doing innovative work to
support the children under their care
both within their education and wider
health concern especially as i watched
and listened and learned about their
specialist eye testing on the side and
the trust chief executive dr sam
paratovii and our team are doing a
superb job
however even in areas like bexy where
we're making great progress there's
always more that can be done in
particular i think i've recently beaten
well school recently with my honourable
friend the member for old bexie in
sidcup and the honourable lady the
member for iris and thames mead which
provides outstanding scn provision but
highlighted some of the concerns they
have on sen funding i've written to my
right under friends secretary of state
on the concerns they raised during our
visit
i'd like to say that this the school's
bill will make it easier for schools in
england
to join multi-academy trusts and
strengthen their regulatory framework
reform the school's funding formula to
make it fairer and strengthen the school
attendance regime so that children can
benefit from being in school these are
vital issues and that is why i support
strongly what the government is doing
i'm keeping to the
as far as the five minutes that madame
deputy figures insisted i can't talk
about the higher education bill which is
also great news but
well i i think we all agree with that on
this side so we don't have too much
details but to conclude madam deputy
speaker in leveling up skills and
education we not only help to unleash
the potential of every area in our
united kingdom but also to grow the
economy and boost our gdp there's a
clear theme from the queen's speech
which needs to be promoted loud and
clear the conservative government
believes in social mobility opportunity
and an education system that offers the
best to all so that every individual can
maximize their life's chances
dame diana johnson
deputy speaker and i am delighted to
speak in this queen's speech debate on
making britain the best place to grow up
and grow old in and i want to focus on
what my part of the country actually
needs to meet our full potential for
contributing to the future national
prosperity and ensuring that the people
of whole and in the rest of the united
kingdom don't just survive but thrive
through strong public services and
opportunities for all it's now 12 years
since the coalition government talked of
rebalancing the economy boosting uk
economic growth by taking pressure off
the congested southeast it's 10 years
since since lord hesseltine's 2012 no
stone unturned report eight years since
the northern powerhouse was launched and
three years since the current prime
minister took office rebadging it as
leveling up now levelling up was only
recently defined in the white paper and
after 12 years we now have 12 missions
so we all know that a growing uk economy
is the key to improving standards of
living ending poverty and having
well-funded public services but we are
currently stuck with low productivity
low growth alongside high inflation and
high tax so escaping this requires a
major contribution from the humber hull
is a free port city with an existing
multi-sector industrial base including
the uk's fastest growing digital economy
a strong local arts sector and a great
university new maritime industries are
expanding around the green energy
estuary with opportunities for future
growth for ending fuel poverty and for
energy security
however alongside these success stories
hull has setbacks local unemployment
remains above the national average hull
is unusual is usually in the top five
areas in the uk for deprivation in work
poverty weakened our local economy even
before the austerity decade and now the
cost of living crisis hull needs more
skilled higher paid jobs and the
minister doing the media round this
morning seems to think that those jobs
were equally shared around the country
when suddenly they are not
hull has several of the 225 left behind
neighborhoods with physical and mental
health outcomes considerably lagging
behind wealthier areas raising
educational standards in hull has also
been challenging too many local
youngsters are not in education
employment or training and many of our
brightest feel the need to leave to get
on and like many left behind areas over
the past decade hull has not just lost
shops but also banks pubs youth clubs
churches children's centres police
stations and post offices and access to
gps and nhs dentist is now worsening
hull has however gained food banks
gambling outlets junk food sellers and
loan sharks and hopefully opportunities
to bid for the community wealth fund
will help to repair some of our depleted
social infrastructure
but so far the talk about levelling up
has been unmatched by deeds independent
research from bloomberg and others shows
that leveling up barely started for most
of the north indeed the gap with the
southeast has grown over the past decade
including most shamefully on life
expectancy
and the excuses for failure do not
convince my constituents of course covid
and the ukraine have been economic
shocks
ministers presented brexit as an
opportunity to boost levelling up not
another excuse for failing and we know
that crisis can also create
opportunities as happened in 1945.
now hull has received some levelling up
funding for our city center sites but
it's a small proportion of the funding
package required to turbo charge our
regional economy
and nowhere near the sustained public
and private private investment
transforming for example london
docklands over the past 40 years it
doesn't even replace funding lost since
2010 now i always fight in this place
for the people of hull but a fair share
of not very much will not be
transformative in boosting uk economic
growth and increasing the opportunities
that we all want to see for the people
of this wonderful country
hull's digital connectivity is good but
our poor roads and rail connectivity
holds back economic regeneration and the
government's integrated rail plan
delivers no genuine transport leveling
up another obstacle to hull's progress
has been ministers insistence behind the
guise of devolution of permanent made in
whitehall changes in political
structures without proper local
consultation as a precondition for
funding but i just draw attention to the
fact that london never had to make such
changes before getting schemes like
crossrail so the ambition must be to
transform not tinker going beyond the
rhetoric of a medici style renaissance
or the victor meldru charter to level
down next doors conservatory
so to conclude the whole country needs a
leveling up bill that is bold lifting
the dead hand of whitehall bureaucracy
cutting waste and boosting investment
and only failure is unaffordable for our
country
jackie doyle price
mr speaker it's a pleasure to follow the
honourable lady who who represents what
is an exciting area of the country in
terms of being on on the humber and as i
say representing thorough which may be
in the south east but i share her
exasperation about london century
policymaking which has actually gone
back decades and in that sense i think
we should welcome the commitment to
leveling up even though she's set quite
a high bar in terms of proving what it
actually means in practice but i do
share some of the concerns she's
expressed and i do think that when it
comes to certainly looking at my local
road infrastructure in thorac
having a national approach hasn't
actually served us especially well all
together so we must make sure that we
make sure that leveling up readers mean
something in practice
but we're talking today about you know
whether this making this country the
best place to to grow up and grow old
and it is the greatest country in the
world and you know i have to say
you know when we look at what's
happening around the world aren't we
lucky to be here in here in the united
kingdom
and i often think when i read our
newspapers or watch our tv or indeed
listen to members opposite sometimes you
know this country is much better than
they say it is and that should be
celebrated but that's not to say we
can't do better that's not to say there
aren't challenges which need to be
addressed but i always think that with
too much in this place we talk about how
much we are spending to solve a problem
and not on the outcomes that we try and
deliver because actually success isn't
doesn't measure by how much you spend in
fact if we look at it and measure it by
how much we spend we end with a very
short-term approach that doesn't
actually fix the problem which is why we
end up having the same debates over and
over again
and i think one of the one of the areas
i'd like to highlight in that regard is
social care for the last 10 years we've
been obsessing about how we pay for
social care without actually properly
looking at how we actually design a
system of social care which is fit for
purpose because the challenge is that we
are all living longer and we haven't
revisited our systems and our policies
to actually address that you know we
need a life course approach to our
housing we know that falls are the
biggest source of elderly health so why
are we not doing more to incentivize
people to have an approach to how they
live which suits their new length of
life
you know we also need to make sure we're
giving hope to younger people that they
can actually buy it out there buy their
own home and this is where the two
policies come together we look at
policies in too much of a silo you know
why aren't we encouraging people to make
better use of their housing asset for
the whole of their family we can
incentivize granny annexes we can make
sure that young people have got some
hope by having greater access to ins to
the wealth in their parents home and i
tell you if we can do that we will
actually save money in the health
service because unnecessary hospital
stays are much more expensive than
dealing with a little inheritance tax
problem which might unlock some
investment
housing is a big challenge and i really
do feel that we need some very radical
approaches to this council housing is a
is a big part
uh we must actually have a millenesque
expansion of our housing supply we can
deal with that by having fixed term
tenancies to make sure that we're only
helping or giving the most help to those
who most need it and not having having
those homes being stuck
but i'd also like to say something also
about more widely about health because
i've always said that government perhaps
works too well for the pointy elbow
middle classes who are good at fighting
for their interest and not those who
most need it and in that respect i'm
very disappointed that we have not made
more progress with reform of the mental
health act it is now four years since
the simon wesley brought forward uh his
review
and
to be frank you know we we we spent a
great deal of time consulting users who
we often had to relive their own trauma
in order to give us their advice so we
have really let those people down in
terms of actually living the material
change
we know that deprivation of liberty can
be an important part of looking after
people with severe mental ill health but
we also know that actually it's misused
and so simon west's report actually
shows that as i have no not very little
time left i just want to just have a
couple more things that we need to
properly address in that regard and that
is that we still are using the bail act
to remand people in custody for their
own protection now the criminal justice
system should not be the place where we
deal with people with severe mental ill
health in 21st century britain that is
completely unacceptable and we've had
we've made much about dealing with
prison cells and police cells
to to
remove them as places of safety
and i assumed that we were making
considerable progress with that i
thought it was a used very limited way
so i was absolutely horrified to hear
from her majesty's inspector of prisons
that in the three women's prisons that
they they visited last year there were
68 women in those prisons remanded for
their own protection that's not
acceptable and i'll more speed dealing
with it
i now call to make her maiden speech
paulette hamilton
[Applause]
today i stand madame deputy speaker and
it's also an honor to follow the member
of thorac
to to thank you for giving me the
opportunity to make my maiden speech
i can only say how proud i am to be
abroad me today
i am overwhelmed but privileged to be
standing here today in this great
institution
being elected to parliament is not just
a right
it's it is an honor
and for any greater honor
sorry and and an even greater honor
knowing your community voted for you to
be here
when i was elected on the fourth of
march people found it difficult to
understand
that i was the first female to be
elected for the erdington constituency
they were even more shocked to learn
that i was the first person of african
and caribbean descent to be elected as a
member of parliament in birmingham
i hope the constituency shares my pride
in knowing that they have made history
saying that i cannot go any further
without talking about the late great
jack joe miami
jack was elected in may 2010 and worked
relentlessly to serve our community
he said in parliament and often within
the constituency in his speeches
erdington may be rich in talent but it
is one of the poorest constituencies in
the country
until his death he worked to support his
constituency in so many ways
any job lost
in the area was a personal blow to jack
to many um to many to many tributes that
there have been many tributes that have
been made to him
in in this place and in the community
it shows how much he was deeply he's
deeply missed
madame deputy speaker i grew up in
answers in a neighboring constituency of
peribar
but erdington is a place i have called
home for 35 years
over 103 000 people live in the
constituency and we have a diverse
community 26
bme people with over 69
of our community under the age of 45
years old with some families who have
sadly not worked for three generate
generations it is important
to get these people back to work
we need to invest
instill confidence give opportunity and
build aspirations into our young people
i am looking forward to being involved
with debates relating to people living
with mental health issues
serving as the mental health champion
for birmingham city council the first
ever to be elected
i have seen at firsthand the increase in
people living with mental health issues
and a massive increase since the
pandemic of young people living with
severe and enduring mental illnesses the
funding in this area has been cut and it
does not need and it does need to be
increased
as mental health services are struggling
to access adequate inpatient inpatient
beds when needed
in erdington the community has also seen
an alarming increase
in the houses of multi-occupancy
where we have the second highest number
in the city my constituency needs to see
an urgent change in legislation
sorry to in legislation to ensure poor
unscrupulous landlords are punished
fined and removed from the market
if they fail to comply with the rules
that are designed to protect residents
here
these are just some of the many issues
that i will be raising on behalf of my
constituency as i as i heard time and
time again
whilst out campaigning
my children were born in erdington
and some of them are up there
they went
and and they went to erdington schools
of which we have over 40 in my
constituency
i have 40 schools to visit
and i promise
i will be visiting all of them
but listen to the the point i know i
will feel at home when i do because
arriving in parliament after a
by-election has truly made me feel like
the new girl at school
my husband opened his first shop on the
slade road in the late 80s in an area
where the high street was dying so as a
family we were acutely aware of the
difficulty other small businesses were
experiencing back then
at the same time i trained as a nurse
and worked at the local health center in
on in warren farm road king standing for
several years
my career in the health service lasted
over 25 years
and it has truly shaped my political
career
as i have already noted erdington is a
very diverse part of birmingham with a
wonderful strong community and
neighborhood spirit with people who work
very hard and look out for each other
one day you could be celebrating eid on
in stockholm green or vasaki in the
local gurdwara or you could be working
with our strong irish or african
caribbean community to celebrate the
good friday walk along the i street
our manufacturing history is well known
sadly too many of our workplaces have
closed it is vital that new business
comes into the constituency
so it is important that through the
leveling up fund we are given the
funding to develop our i street
particularly the erdington high street
the erdington constituency can look
quite dark and lack in green space when
you drive through
this is because of the roads like the dr
the gravelly ill interchange which i am
sure you all know as
spaghetti junction
[Music]
but if you can look more closely under
the spaghetti junction and gary will
tell you this
you can walk along some of the most
beautiful canal walkways in the country
we are all so fortunate to have many
lovely parks such as pipes such as the
rookery park such a short heath playing
fields such as the the beautiful 13-acre
site owned by the erdington rugby club
i would also like to mention the
stunning
bowling facility we have in the
constituency run by the erdington port
bowles club
the brookville lakes the whitten lodge
lakes where residents do duckling watch
to ensure we preserve the mu the natural
beauty of this area is truly incredible
alongside the amazing eco-hub run by an
organization called the whitten lodge
association
when i won this election my husband
looked on and said
well done now the work starts
how right he was
after receiving over 2 000 emails plus
sacks of mail in my first month i am
under no illusions that the role of an
mp is many things to many people
we are here to help
guide advise support and represent our
constituents
i want to thank the people of birmingham
erdington for putting their faith and
trust in me it is an amazing privilege
to be here and my promise to you
is that i will work tirelessly on your
behalf both in this place and in the
community i'd like to thank you madam
deputy speaker
[Applause]
so paul beresford
okay
i must congratulate the honourable lady
that was a really feeling speech i was
sitting here waiting for clapping above
but you must warn them not to but it
would have deserved it it was absolutely
brilliant
i want to just with the time stretchers
touch on one little bill
and it wouldn't be very hard for people
to work out it was a trade bill that
will help make britain the best place
and that is the trade australia and new
zealand bill
there's a great support between this
country and the antiquities the kith and
ken's support
in fact most of my parents generation
used to talk about this country as home
even if they've never been here
and many a new zealand coffee table of
that generation displayed a copy of one
of those amazing books of beautiful
photographs of the united kingdom
the amazing factor was that they were
all taken on a sunny day
this is the uk's first new free trade
agreement with new zealand australia
since us leaving the european union
it's long overdue new zealand australia
was sore when we went into the common
market
i'm a member of the uk nfu and locally
there's been some concern
as both australia and new zealand are
agricultural juggernauts
my mole valley biggest dairy farmer has
about 350 cows and i think my largest
sheep farmer probably has about a
thousand sheep
a couple of colleagues of mine in the
north of the south island dairy farmers
are milking 1 500 and 2 500 and the farm
i left to come here
after lambing we had 30 000 sheep
but fortunately the balance of timing
means that we can work together plus the
fact that the new zealand nfu equivalent
is looking to working with our farmers
fulfilling the bids that are going into
europe now the economic opportunities
under this agreement will be
considerable across a whole range of
sectors
whole range of businesses
any visitor to new zealand or australia
will be struck by the dominance of cars
trucks agricultural machinery and i'm
not just mentioned tractors
they are dominated by southeast asia
particularly by japan
there is a desire to buy british trucks
cars etc
but they're too expensive now with this
tariff change
that should give us the opportunity and
we need to get in there and i've already
been urging the appropriate minister to
get down and do something about it with
the manufacturers and promote southeast
asia
promote in australia new zealand i've
suggested a campaign i've offered to
help i've offered to translate
and i hope
that the combination with the government
for stimulating our industries we will
get in there
open the doors
and work towards going into the tpp
because of the time limit i will stop at
that point but i still reiterate and i
hope the minister does hear from us
that i'm willing to help
and need to help and it is an
opportunity for huge sales to make
britain the best place
the honourable gentleman has been
exemplary in his
in his uh
uh watching of the time limit but um
whereas he has been such an excellent
example i'm just going to make sure that
everyone else adheres to the five
minutes by now putting on a formal time
limit but it's still five minutes which
is a long time if you speak quickly
sharon hodgson
okay and i will speak very quickly um
when i became chair of the eppg for
dyslexia and other specific learning
difficulties
in 2016 the implementation of the
children and families act was underway
now here was a piece of legislation i
had actually taken through parliament as
a shadow minister so i was very hopeful
that it might lead to an advance in snd
provision in schools
but things have obviously got not gone
to plan madam deputy speaker because the
new send green paper by its very
existence implies that something has
gone wrong
so let's look at some numbers pupils
with sen are less likely to meet the
expected standards in reading writing
and maths at the end of key stage two
with only 22 percent of children with
scn achieving this compared to 74
of those with no recorded sen
this continues at gcse with only 27
percent of sen children achieving a
grade 4 or above in english and maths
compared with 71 percent of those with
no recorded sem
in 12 years of conservative government
those with scnd have ensured endured a
broken system leaving lasting impact on
their futures
special educational needs and
disabilities are sometimes invisible as
we know making them hard to identify and
support
many working-class children are
categorized as poor readers not because
they may have dyslexia but because they
come from disadvantaged backgrounds
others who may have dyslexia but don't
have the money to access private
assessment and diagnosis so may never
then get the support that they need
and far from levelling up this
government imprisons these children in
lower expectations
and as we make necessary spread strides
in special educational needs assessment
so the system supporting these needs
these needs faces greater levels of
strain
on capacity so it's all about cost
i hope madam deputy speaker that that is
not the reason for conspicuous absence
in the government's recent green paper
of the three days dyslexia dyspraxia and
dyscalculia
the government finally recognizes the
need for new high-level alternative
provision but i implore the government
to expand their priorities to specific
learning difficulties
these can have a profound
effect on a child's educational
development and without wider assessment
we can only guess at the incidence rate
of these conditions
in the meantime children will struggle
through their school years and lose the
chance to fulfill their potential
and that is not to say those with
specific learning difficulties are less
able than their peers on the contrary
neurodiverse individuals exhibit problem
solving lateral thinking and innovation
skills often in excess of the
neurotypical
this year i was very proud to be
involved in the launch of neurodiversity
and business an initiative which says at
last count over a hundred companies
across the country including the likes
of deloitte and the bank of england
championing neurodiverse workers
they recognize unique skills and
benefits neurodivergent employees bring
to an organization and this is to be
greatly welcomed and encouraged as it's
so true
i welcome the government's consultation
on scn day provision and i will
certainly be engaging with the
consultation in due course and will
encourage all colleagues and
organizations in the sector to do the
same
now very quickly on another topic i'd
also like to take a moment to draw
attention to food insecurity we know
families are struggling with the cost of
living crisis a crisis that is only
going to get worse more adults are
reporting skipping meals 57 more in
april than just in january and more
children are unable to access nutritious
food at the same time public sector
caterers who make up an important part
of the protection against food and
security are facing supply chain
disruptions stock price explosions it's
been described to me and it's getting
more expensive to run the industrial
kitchens in our schools hospitals and
prisons and it's getting so much harder
to ensure services therefore offer the
same nutritious food
so the government is allowing food and
security to become worse in allowing
standards to decline and doing nothing
to prevent a public health crisis along
the way
this is happening on their watch madam
deputy speaker and there was nothing in
this queen's speech to address it that
means it's only going to get worse until
we have a change of government to one
with the will and the plan to grow the
economy and be on the side of working
people thank you
bob blackman thank you speaker and a
pleasure to follow the honourable member
for washington uh and sunderland and
indeed i had my congratulations to the
honourable member for birmingham
erdington for her maiden speech i can
assure her that actually the case load
continues year after year
can i uh uh say from the outset that i
also want to
appreciate another formidable lady her
majesty the queen and i was delighted to
see her uh being able to to join in the
celebrations of her jubilee unaided
yesterday
on the greater speech i i wish to uh
talk about several of the bills that are
coming up first the leveling up and
regeneration bill which i think gives us
the opportunity of leveling up each part
of the united kingdom
i was absolutely over the moon with the
local election results in harrow last
week
where we took eight seats from labour
and control of the council for the first
time since 2006 and i look forward to
the hard-working councillors leveling up
paro and for putting right what has been
going wrong for far too long
but on the transport bill
my constituents depend on good public
transport and across the uk we need good
public transport
and getting people uh out of their cars
and on to public transport so i'm
delighted that this morning catalyst the
developers withdrew their planning
application to build high-density
multi-story flats on the stanmore
station car park and i trust that tfl
will now abandon that plan completely
on the social housing regulation bill i
hope that we're going to go further not
just regulating social housing but
expanding the amount of social housing
across the uk and providing more
affordable housing for the people that
need it we've got to stop selling public
land and start building homes on it
instead of allowing developers to
end up with unsustainable capability
on the renters reform bill
these are central and i
refer the house to my declaration in the
register of interest
i have a concern
that in just abolishing section 21 no
fault evictions which the government
consulted on in 2019
we will improve the security of tenure
for tenants and also make sure that we
are strengthening the position
around which landlords can
give cause for gaining possession of
their properties back but
what we must not do is lead to the more
section 8
evictions and tenants being landed with
county court judgments
across the piece so i hope that we're
going to have a new lifetime tenancy
deposit model that eases the burden on
tenants when they move from one tenancy
to the next
which will improve the overall private
rented sector
i also remind the government that my
landmark housing homelessness reduction
act
triggers and the trigger for that is a
section 21 notice uh that then leads to
the local authority having
responsibility to help and advise people
who are threatened with homelessness so
if you abolish section 21 i want to make
sure that local authorities are not let
off the hook from their responsibility
of ensuring that they help and assist
single homeless people
it's also important that the government
stands by its pledge to develop a new
ombudsman for private landlords
so that disputes are resolved without
going to court on expensive processes on
both sides
on the financial services and markets
bills
i'm delighted to hear that the
government is going to preserve access
to cash
far too many bank branches and atms have
closed and access to cash is a priority
for many people in our society so i'm
pleased that that's going to happen and
particularly the elderly population of
this country still rely heavily on cash
and are dependent on that so we must
protect that part of society i also
welcome the boycott's divestment and
sanctions bill
uh it's quite clear we do not want local
authorities or other public bodies
across this country having their own
foreign policy that is something to be
determined
by the uk government it means that the
ongoing commitment to support the uk's
jewish community and support for israel
is fundamental and i'm delighted to see
that yeah in terms of the the other
bills the schools bill is clearly
vitally important as we return to
normality under the pandemic and i
welcome that and indeed the higher
education freedom speech bill i am one
of those people that believe that people
should be free to say what they wish as
long as they can be challenged on it
but not that we should get to a point
whereby people are shouted down and
prevented from putting forward their
views
and finally uh deputy speaker this is
dementia action week and clearly people
that are
getting older and frailer we must have
more action
for that from the national health
service so i welcome and support
the queen's speech
steve mckay
thank you madam deputy speaker this
government's great on slogans get it
done oven ready leveling up but the
reality is that they consistently fail
to get the right things done their ideas
are mostly half baked and the key
statistics show they're leveling down
not up
after 12 years this country is going
backwards
there's no plan to fix social care
improve the health figures address
education shortfalls or tackle
neighborhood crime the queen's speech
was a chance to put that right to
address those issues affecting the lives
of ordinary people a chance to move on
from the pandemic and be in touch with
the needs of business families and the
elderly
instead what we have is a program of 38
bills which will occupy parliamentary
time over the next 12 months or so and
hardly any address the things people
really care about on education the
emphasis
is on academization
playing with the structures when the
need is catch up improvement and tending
to crumbling buildings and giving
children the best start in life
i support the work of the right
honourable lady for south
northamptonshire but i have to say how a
government that's closed two and a half
thousand surestart centers and plans to
replace them with 75 family hubs thinks
it can lay claim to an ambitious early
year strategy is beyond me
according to the government every family
should receive a minimum of five health
visiting reviews
even with remote and phone consultations
included their own figures show this
isn't happening and nearly 30 percent of
toddlers have missed out on the crucial
24 30 months
it
check
in language an area where existing
waiting lists have been exacerbated by
the pandemic nearly 70 000 children are
waiting for support children under seven
often wait over two years where's the
catch-up or improvement plan to help
them
they can find time for a bill to sell
channel four which wasn't in their
manifesto but not time to legislate for
a measly one week's unpaid leave for
carers a manifesto commitment in which
every one of them stood
there's no plan to reduce nhs waiting
lists or ambulance delays the reality of
healthcare in birmingham is that every
day the west midlands ambulance service
starts hundreds of calls that require an
ambulance response but they can't
provide midland hospitals have the
highest waiting list in the country
university hospital birmingham a
first-class institution for those it's
able to treat has 185 000 people now
waiting for treatment no wonder the
country's health outcomes are
deteriorating
for care homes there's still no plan to
fix social care one of the earliest
promises made and abandoned by the prime
minister and no assistance to deal with
staff retention rising energy and
insurance costs but care homes will
still be set by many difficulties have
lost their covered 19 support grants
rather earlier than the support for
newspaper grandees negotiated personally
by the prime minister of mr cummings is
to be believed
i have no time for the behavior of some
of the extinction rebellion activists
but do we really need a new law
to deal with the antics of this minority
group when we already have the 1986
public order act the latest bloomberg
analysis of the government's leveling up
strategy shows a 33
increase in crime in south birmingham
wouldn't allow to establish viable
neighborhood policing units be of much
greater value to my
constituents so in early years speech
and language carers care homes waiting
lists ambulance services and the
security of neighborhoods this queen's
speech is a missed opportunity from a
government that stopped paying attention
to the interests of the people it
purports to represent the slogans now
are morphing into can't you budget and
cook on 30 pence a day and why don't you
just get another job
out of touch and out of ideas
sir robert neil thank you madam deputy
speaker
i welcome the queen's speech they're
concentrating upon the importance of
leveling up and expanding opportunity
across the whole of the country that is
fundamental to our mission that couldn't
be more important than in the health
service i'm glad to see the minister of
state on the treasury bench because he
will know how passionately i feel from
personal experience of the importance
that we level up all health service
provision in particular provision for
often under appreciated conditions such
as those which touch upon stroke
survivors and he knows and the house
will know my interest as chair of the
appg about four stroke at the moment
stroke provision provision of after care
and therapy for stroke survivors remains
unfortunately patchy across the country
despite it being the largest single
cause of adult disability if we're
serious about leveling up i hope we'll
invest more in that and in particular
take up the app suggestion of
transforming our already good national
stroke plan into a fully fledged
national stroke strategy joined up and
fully resourced with specialist
workforce behind it
leveling up is also important to
education and both getting education and
health services right in terms of the
criminal justice system
because failures there as the honourable
member for thorough pointed out often
had impacts on the justice system
downstream poor educational outcomes
mental health and allied issues
failures in relation to social services
child care and poor housing all
contribute to people falling into
offending behavior getting into the
justice system and then getting upon the
never ending circle of reoffending that
ruins lives and it harms the economy
investment in those topics upstream is
actually investment to the whole of the
public good both societally and
economically i hope the government will
redouble its efforts there both in in
terms of cash but also in much more
joined up policy working across the
various agencies
can i then turn madame deputy speaker
specifically to some legal issues and
start with the proposed bill of rights
i stored and supported our manifesto in
2019 to update the human rights act and
administrative law and i stand by that
and in pursuance of that uh the
government
commissioned a panel and expert panel of
independence under the chairmanship of
the right honourable peter gross qc
of highly distinguished former lord
justice of appeal
sir peter and his team produced a
thoroughly detailed comprehensive
meticulously argued
report on how best to take this forward
he followed that up with most compelling
evidence to the justice committee i'd
support and are persuaded by sir peter's
proposals
the government as it is entitled to of
course
appears to propose to go further than
sir peter's proposals well up to a point
there's never harm in that i'm all in
favor of updates i don't see any harm in
putting in already well established
rights such as the right to trial by
jury in england and wales or the right
to freedom of speech into statute even
though they're perfectly well present
protected are under our existing common
law
but where i'll caution however it is
going any further than that beyond sir
peter's well-researched and argued
proposals it will be perhaps dangerous
to go down a route of limiting the at
the ability of individuals in the united
kingdom to assert their european
convention rights in the domestic courts
in a way which ultimately means that
there will simply be more petitions
brought to the strasbourg court on the
face of it that is potentially
counterproductive to the government's
own availed intention of reducing
litigation in this area i'm delighted
that we remain committed to our
membership of the european convention on
europe upon human rights it is a
fundamental it was written essentially
by a future conservative lord chancellor
the future lord kilmur
it was churchill's government which took
us in to the european convention on
human rights so it's in the conservative
dna
but we must make sure that we approach
this important issue with care and with
caution and do not run beyond the
evidence briefly madam speaker i also
welcome the draft victims bill i look
forward to the government delivering on
its commitment to pre-legislative
scrutiny by the justice committee of
that that is critical for a real impact
upon people who suffer from crime at the
moment and i also welcome the economic
crimes and corporate transparency bill
now that's important because our
committee recently took evidence upon
the prevalence and harm done by fraud to
the economy and to individuals lives but
i hope too will use that as an
opportunity to bring forward a long
awaited and long argued for updating of
the law of criminal corporate criminal
corporate responsibility
an area in which we lag behind some
other common law jurisdictions
particularly on the other side of the
atlantic so great opportunities here a
word of caution on one fundamental
constitutional issue but also i hope
constructive suggestions as how we can
take another important parts of the
government's agenda forward
nasha thank you
i would really like every one of my
constituents in battle west to be able
to say britain is the best place to grow
up and grow old but unfortunately due to
the failures of this government i can't
say that for every single one of my
constituents because
actions speak louder than words and this
prime minister committed to levelling up
every part of the uk it but it just
remains an idea and it's slogans like
the member before me early on said
last week madame deputy speaker it was
seven years since the people of bradford
west put their trust and faith in me to
be their voice in this chamber and i
said it then that the north was being
neglected and i say it again at the time
i shared it was my privilege to be
representing the great northern city
which is the youngest city in europe the
birthplace of a bronte sisters had has a
world world-renowned literature festival
and so much more
seven years later after enduring
austerity an unforgiving pandemic and
now a cost of living crisis the great
city is applying to be the city of
culture and continues to move forward
but madam deputy speaker this is in
spite of the government's failures to
level up bradford and its broken
promises i'm very grateful for the 20
million pounds that's coming to my
constituency for a health and wellbeing
center which has long been overdue but
unfortunately this is a drop in the
ocean in compared to the 30 billion
pounds worth of growth that potential
growth and 27 000 jobs which have been
robbed from bradford due to this
government's failure to deliver on the
northern powerhouse rail the government
has also made bradford a priority area
for education but in reality this is
also too little too late during the
pandemic i repeatedly warned the
government that disadvantaged pupils in
bradford were 18 months behind their
wealthy appears and the gap was widening
it is shocking that the government has
made bradford a priority area of
education while it plans to defund
b-tech qualifications despite the
department of education's own equality
impact assessment concluding that this
move will embed inequality into our
education system the reality is that
over the last 12 years the city of
bradford and my constituents have been
robbed of investment and opportunities
to grow the government has only
supplemented this loss by providing
bradford with hand-out investments which
are not enough to truly level up madam
deputy speaker children across the uk
and in my constituency deserve the best
start in life and deserve access to
education training and job opportunities
throughout their lives however only
today the government safeguarding
minister has suggested that people who
are struggling with the cost of living
crisis should take on more hours of work
or move to better paid jobs this is
shocking and is another reminder that
leveling up is just a slogan and just a
bunch of words
this reality that the government was is
truly committed to leveling up it would
give each and every person in my
constituency the right support and
investment to thrive not just to survive
and at the moment people aren't even
surviving because it's literally having
to make the difference between who's
getting fed and what heating goes on
another example of opportunity
investment bypassing bradford is a king
cross-style regeneration project in
which the government had promised to
transform 20 cities and towns across the
country as part of its level of agenda
and it comes as no surprise to me that
bradford has not been named as one of
the 20 cities as of yet so i asked the
minister will bradford be overlooked
again
the prime minister has mentioned
leveling up 97 times since 2019 in this
chamber alone and that's not the rest of
minister unsurprisingly he's not yet
delivered on levelling up even once
i've said this before and i will say it
again the litmus test for levelling up
is bradford and the reason is if a
government fails bradford it has failed
to deliver on its leveling up strategy
full stop the whole lot of it and
without equality and equity and fairness
britain will only be the best place to
grow up and grow old
it it's not going to work for people in
bradford west if there isn't equality in
fairness and if this government doesn't
put it's only where its mouth is and
speak and the actions speak louder than
words and my constituents will be
judging everything this government does
thank you
dr caroline johnson
the honourable lady from bradford west i
must disagree with her because i believe
this country is the best place to grow
up
although that does not mean there is not
work to do to make it even better and i
look forward to supporting the queen's
speech in this regard
to grow up and grow old well you need a
healthy pregnancy and a healthy birth i
look forward to the women's health
strategy in this regard childhood needs
to be filled with opportunity and the
school's bill and higher education bill
provide this opportunities to us we need
to have better sport and better mental
health services again covered in the
queen's speech
we also need to look at the impact of
loneliness in particular on social life
which we know has a huge impact on
elderly people and i was pleased to
organize with my team at senior citizens
fair in north highcom last week where
many people came along to hear about the
available clubs activities and other
support available for older people in
that region
two things i want to touch on the first
is the impact of covid on the national
health service and i should refer to my
registered members interest as a doctor
at this point we know that the impact of
coburg means that a lot of people are
waiting for treatment and i was somewhat
perturbed to read we want to eliminate
weights of the year by 2025 because the
weight of a year is a long time and 2025
is not particularly soon if you're
waiting and in pain
but i am pleased to see that we have
community diagnostics
services opening around the country to
help improve this i'm particularly
pleased to see that one is opening in
grantham will serve many of my
constituents and also to hear that there
are two new operating theaters being
built in grantham hospital which will
again will improve elective activity in
this area
we're going to do 17 more million tests
in the next three years we're going to
have an increased capacity of 9 million
extra treatments and procedures and to
increase elective activity by 30 percent
all this is very good and it's
especially good to see the government
focusing on output and actions that
benefit patients treatments tests and
procedures things that make them better
not just inputs like the opposition do
of x or y billion i've noted in my
career in hospital medicine that the
amount of senior staff has increased but
demands expectation and the number of
administrative and managerial staff has
also increased too
if we're to deliver for patients and not
simply spend more money
we need to ensure that the extra money
is only spent in those areas of clinical
care which improve patient outcomes
in that regard i support calls for more
medical students more nursing students
and i would also support relative a
relative increase in renumeration for
nurses providing direct clinical care so
that those roles are not disincentivized
i appreciate that the nhs is
operationally independent but i look for
ministerial reassurance that we are
linking all this extra money that we are
taking from our constituents to improve
clinical care and clinical delivery
the second thing i wanted to touch upon
was education and opportunity because
they are inextricably
linked
we share the view on these benches that
talent is uniformly distributed but that
but that opportunity is sadly not
and i welcome the government commitment
to leveling up in this regard
i'm lucky that we have excellent schools
in my constituency and that some as i
mentioned earlier including cars grammar
school have seen huge investment this
week with cars receiving over a million
pounds in sleeper to improve its um
structure of its buildings this is
fantastic news for all the successful
schools in that bid
the school bids bill also offers us an
opportunity to look at not only how we
educate children in maths english and
science but also how we contribute to a
positive childhood mcallister report due
out very shortly we'll look at it will
help us to guide us on the safeguarding
improvements and in doing so i hope the
secretary of state will protect
children's lives and well-being by
focusing on evidence he often talks in
select committee about his focus on the
evidence and i hope we'll be looking at
the evidence on how we can preach or not
just adding to the bureaucracy that
teachers face
i would also like to see curriculum
measures to improve sport in particular
girls sport as we know many teenage
girls do less sport as they get older
and throughout their secondary school
experience
children's sport is crucial to physical
development it's crucial to bone health
and preventing osteoporosis in the
elderly even it's important to fitness
to mental well-being and indeed
important to improving academic outcomes
as well
and i look forward to the government
bringing forward school paper where i
hope to see an increase in the minimum
participation and encouraging of more
sport as a priority
i look forward to welcoming the queen to
voting for the queen speech when that
opportunity rises
judith cummings
thank you
mr deputy speaker my constituents are
facing a growing growing number of
crises that continue to pile up day
after day
now i accept some of these difficulties
on you but most are not most of these
difficulties have been brewing and
festering for years and government's
failure to solve these problems or come
up with solutions has pushed many
services to breaking point and now
families are being left to bear the
brunt
despite the fact that day after day
cash-strapped families are trying to
make ends meet
by working extra hours often in multiple
jobs what do this government's benches
tell them learn to cook learn to budget
work more hours get a better paid job
you're responsible you're to blame and
it's you that are doing it wrong
but mr deputy speaker what people need
from the government is help to navigate
through the things that are out of their
control yeah they need them to solve the
long-term issues which continue to push
down on people's quality of living and
eventually leave them out of options
and it's one of these issues that i want
to address today
an issue that's not in the queen's
speech but really should be because nhs
dentistry and oral health inequality has
been repeatedly unaddressed by this
government and access to basic dentistry
care in this country is often forgotten
but it's a vital part of this nation's
health
in 2016 an nhs digital report found that
just under half of dentists were
thinking of leaving dentistry and so i
warned the government not to kick the
can down the road and risk a crisis in
dental care
i told the government then that the most
important measure the government could
implement as highlighted by the british
dental association would be changes to
the dental contract that incentivized
prevention but nothing was done in 2017
the bda told us that 58 of the uk's nhs
dentists were planning on turning away
from nhs dentistry in the next five
years so again i warned the government
that we faced a national crisis
in 2019 the times reported that 60
of dentists plan to lead the profession
or cut back nhs care in the next five
years with more than a million new
patients turned away and some patients
resorting to pulling out their own teeth
yet again shocking nothing
in 2020 i told the government that a
majority of nhs dental practices across
england believe they could only survive
for 12 months or less
the government said they would look at
the workforce issue more broadly and in
the round but no action was forthcoming
and a thousand nhs dentists left the
service
and earlier this year mr deputy speaker
hearing almost a thousand children under
10 in bradford had to be admitted to
hospital to have declared teeth removed
i pleaded with the government to finally
deal with the issue that had been
staring them in the face for years
shocking and then of course to nobody's
surprise except this government last
week it was it was revealed that two
thousand dentists have quit the service
in the last year
reforming the dental contract is urgent
and it is not good enough to be told
time and time again
year after year that reform is imminent
because i've been asking for seven years
now and still the government has yet to
deliver
if the government need help with
budgeting mr deputy speaker i can point
the chancellor in the direction of when
is it one of his own mps who might have
a cost that he can take up
but mr deputy speaker i desperately do
not want to be back here in 2023 still
trying to open the government's eyes to
the massive freight train coming towards
them
i have sounded the alarm other
honourable members of this house have
sounded the alarm dentists and patients
have sounded the alarm we are all
waiting for the government to act and
reform the dental contract
patients and our constituents cannot
wait any longer
thank you mr deputy speaker
making britain the best place to grow up
and grow old is a big challenge
ensuring that where you are born and
raised does not limit your quality of
life and life expectancy is an even
bigger challenge and one which lies at
the heart of the government's leveling
up agenda
we all know the expression you are what
you eat
in britain we are trapped in a junk food
cycle that means we now consume more
highly processed foods than any other
european country except malta and have
higher levels of obesity
yet we have had decades even centuries
of political barriers to good food
policy
we often hear cries of nanny statism or
don't tell us what to eat
the latest government announcements of
delaying the ban on junk food
advertising on television before 9 pm
and delaying restricting buy one get one
free promotions follows this regrettable
trend
as a self-confessed chocoholic i
struggle to resist the temptation to
boost my energy levels with a bar of
chocolate rather than a piece of fruit
so i know first hand the irresistible
pull of promotions and multiple multiple
purchase deals
and i appreciate that some honourable
members believe that attempts to tackle
the bombardment of unhealthy food should
be postponed so as not to increase the
cost of living
they are wrong
research shows that promotions on
unhealthy food and drink
actually encourage people to buy 22 more
unhealthy food and drink than intended
and to consume more of it too marketing
tactics have a real financial cost as
well as a negative health impact
let's not forget retailers have other
choices
instead of encouraging customers on
tight budgets to spend more on
non-essential foods through these offers
they could simply offer 50 discounts or
some supermarkets have started to do
ensure that they have a value range of
products at affordable prices which
covers the basic foods for a balanced
diet
the political context has changed in
recent months and the government's focus
is rightly on helping with the cost of
living
though this is a priority it should not
prevent introducing the important
measures i've listed
any delay will mean more children will
live with obesity and too many will have
reduced life chances through ill health
our constituents will not thank us or
forgive us for doing a u-turn on their
health
obesity is a national emergency
in england about 60 percent of men
68 of men 60 percent of women and more
than one in four children aged 2 to 15
are obese or overweight
while this is a nationwide issue rates
of obesity are disproportionately higher
among people living in the more deprived
communities the statistics in my own
city of stoke on trent are shocking
76.1 percent of adults in stoke-on-trent
are overweight or obese and that is the
third highest figure of all local
authorities in england
as the cost of living continues to
squeeze household budgets low-income
families are forced to choose the
cheapest calories which are typically
the least healthy
the government must ensure that when it
comes to tackling food security and the
cost of living it introduces policies
that make nutritious diets affordable
easy and accessible to families on the
lowest incomes
there is a pressing need for a good food
bill which would set out long-term
approach and clear targets for the food
system
and make it laid out in law with better
systems for independently monitoring
policy
we talk about the need for resilient
food system in terms of supply chains
and production
i think we need to widen out the
resilience narrative to resilient
population that is both financially
resilient to price shocks and resilient
in public health terms to pandemics for
instance
we must not lurch from price crisis to
crisis
action on the nation's obesity emergency
needs to start now
to be clear i support the right to good
food as a fundamental pillar of the
government's leveling up agenda
i support a school standards food
standards to ensure our young people
have the fuel to learn
i support bringing cookery skills and an
understanding of nutrition into the
school curriculum at every key stage and
through community organizations such as
family hubs i support measures to enable
british farmers to produce the food we
need and the food industry to innovate
and adapt so that they are incentivized
to create healthier and more sustainable
products
and i support better help within the nhs
for people living with obesity including
social prescribing and fair affect at
bariatric services
good food good health is a vital
ingredient to maximizing our quality of
life and longevity proper nutrition is
the foundation of good health an
investment in access to good food will
pay dividends both in terms of savings
to the nhs and increased productivity
which will boost the economy and deliver
on the promise of levelling up health
outcomes
chris matheson thank you mr deputy
speaker speaking in this debate last
year i welcome the government's
commitment to bring forward a ban on
conversion therapy one year on we're no
further forward in fact we seem to have
gone backwards but i'm hoping to see
that progressed this year i'm also i was
also hoping to see a better business act
um included in the the queen's speech to
give us a cleaner greener and fairer
future i'm being pushed on this actually
by businesses in my constituency who
understand how important it is to give
different priorities in law to
businesses so i hope to see something
about that and was disappointed by its
absence this time and while we're
talking about better business i was
extremely disappointed to see no pro no
progress in legislation to outlaw fire
and rehire we saw recently the latest
example piano ferries where ministers
and members opposites said it was
absolutely terrible but when push came
to shove there was no action to
get rid to outlaw it in law and that was
a huge omission
from the queen's speech instead we get
um a promise to bringing forward
legislation to um abolish the northern
ireland protocol whose northern ireland
protocol was it it was the prime
ministers he wrote it he sold it to the
to the british people and now once again
he's trying to he's trying to renege on
something that he himself wrote and
demonstrates that yet again he is a
prime minister who will say whatever it
needs to say to get out of whatever
position he's in at the time and then
have no sense of responsibility to those
to those um to the to to those promises
he's made but i say to the house it does
affect us internationally who's going to
do big deals with us if he's going to
bring forward legislation to break deals
that he only signed himself and wrote
himself two years ago and of course the
biggest omission at the moment
was any kind of proposals on
tackling this dreadful
energy crisis that we have millions of
families up and down the country are
facing soaring energy bills and ever
increasing cost of living the government
have demonstrated they've no plan to fix
this families are paying triple their
energy bill they'll need a solution now
and i was disappointed that the
government has not adopted a one-off
windfall tax on the oil and gas giants
and let's just understand exactly why
that is that's because it won't just
affect a windfall tax wouldn't simply
affect
the oil and gas companies who
incidentally have we all know have said
that with the level of profits that
they're getting we're get several
billion pounds a quarter they'd be quite
happy to pay it it would affect the city
investment funds and the city hedge
funds which the concurrent conservative
party along with russian oligarchs of
course exists to serve and they're not
in their places now but of course the um
the education secretary and the
secretary of state for health and the
chancellor all have big city investment
fund backgrounds that's where they know
and that's who they're really defending
when they refuse to have
um a windfall tax um locally um in in my
area in cheshire western chester that we
are leading the way on our alternative
and clean energy provision um
my honorable friend mails me a portion
nestor news in his place next to me and
i have been very supportive of highness
and actually i pay tribute to the
government on that particular scheme
they have um
they have assisted us i know in his
constituency the vauxhall elsewhere pork
plant and is looking forward to an
all-electric future leading the way on
green jobs thanks to him and again
thanks to the secretary of state uh
patrick pay credit where it's due um but
i have to say to the governments that um
any attempts to bring back fracking will
be given short shift in my constituency
and i'm very concerned about that um on
leveling up
and on transport i was looking forward
to
some detail in the new transport bill
and i will be keeping an eye on what the
government is proposing but at the
moment we need proper rail services my
honourable friend from elizabeth
reporter nestor and i um were
meeting the the rail companies this week
to try and restore direct services
between chester and london at the moment
they've gone from 12 before a day before
the pandemic down to one and now they've
been doubled to two
we're asked to be grateful for that
we're hopeful that we might get more
services but of course direct services
are essential to economic growth but
instead we've seen the cancellation of
northern
house rail the scrapping of the hs2
eastern leg which is a betrayal of the
north and it's the same for buses
the government has turned down bids for
more bus money from cheshire western
chester council even though ministers
describe the bid as excellent and i hope
the transport bill will tackle the the
difficulties we are seeing with bus
provision and give more opportunity for
places like chester to improve
connectivity finally it is absurd that
the um the the great heritage asset
which is the city walls of chester
have to be paid for out of highways
budget
so that money that should be paid on
roads potholes and pavements um is being
diverted understandably to pay for that
great heritage asset we need a separate
fund for those walls
jack brereton
deputy speaker i was delighted to
welcome the prime minister and the
cabinet to stoke-on-trent last week to
meet with local workers businesses
educators and community groups
stoke-on-trent is on the up and we are
determined to deliver an even better
place to grow up and grow old we must
now level up cities like stoke-on-trent
and seize upon the opportunities of
brexit free from the shackles of
brussels bureaucracy through the brexit
freedoms bill stoke on trent is a city
which has been neglected and held back
for decades but we have so much
potential just waiting to be unleashed
finally we are now having we now have a
government and local politicians who are
focused on securing the investment and
delivering the improvements our city
needs
we must particularly improve our local
public transport which is a barrier to
jobs and skills opportunities in parts
of mir in my constituency 40 of
households do not have a car for the
rest of the city on average it's around
30 of households the need for rail and
bus improvements is desperate so the big
win pledges we've secured for investment
from the transforming cities fund bus
service improvement plan restoring your
railways and others are greatly received
removing removing some of those barriers
to better jobs and skills opportunities
i was delighted to champion the
improvement works proposed for longton
station through the transforming cities
fund it is time for those funded works
to now be delivered a network rail
particularly must start playing its full
part properly coordinated as part of the
delivery which it hasn't been doing up
until recently i hope that through the
great british railways and the transport
drill this will help to look to resolve
how we can better deliver the transport
improvements needed in cities like
stockholm trent and particularly address
organizations like network rail which do
hinder some of that process and have
very much hindered the progress on the
works that we've been doing across
stoke-on-trent i would also call on the
government to announce that our plans to
reopen meer station which i've been
chairing the delivery board for will
proceed and continue to support us as we
develop our plans for the reopening of
the stoke league line
and in building a better city we're not
only making it easier to get around but
reviving historic sites that give our
city and our towns its unique character
and appeal i particularly welcome the
leveling up and regeneration bill which
will help us to breathe new life into
our towns and high streets the historic
action zones which we have won for
longton and stoke town in my right in my
honourable friends constituency and the
leveling up fund pledges for major
regeneration sites and the daryl
including the derelict tams crown works
in longton are all key to levelling up
our communities and breathing new life
into our town centres
our city is becoming the place to invest
in for digital and creative sectors like
the gaming industry right at the heart
of the uk spurred on by the massive
investment in fiber gigabit connectivity
and i was pleased to visit
on site with
open reach over the over the last week
on friday i've visited a site where
they're installing fibre gigabit
connectivity in fenton this is alongside
improving education to ensure everyone
locally has the ability to access better
skills and better paid employment the
major announcements that stoke-on-trent
will benefit from both the family hubs
program and as a prioritized education
investment area will ensure every young
person gets the best possible start in
life particularly in those early ages
we also need to focus on the gaps in
things like engineering and creative
skills for those high pay high value
jobs that we want to attract locally and
to fill those gaps that we see that
employers are regularly speaking to me
about i particularly welcome the
government schemes like the lifetime
skills guarantee which offers free
training for adults to upskill and this
will be significant in places like
stoke-on-trent to upskill adults given
the number of adults that we have
without those higher skilled edu those
higher level qualifications and the
school skills bill and the higher
education bill can get us on the right
track for young people to achieve their
full potential and ensure everybody in
our city achieves their full potential
finally i hope to see some more support
for the ceramics industry and there are
real concerns about the current cost of
energy for high use high energy use
manufacturers particularly local world
leading ceramics industry i know the
prime minister is listening and he
carefully did again on his visit to
churchill trial last week in
my honourable friend for stoke on trent
north constituency i know hope we won't
allow other countries to steal a march
on the fantastic british ceramics
industry increased energy costs remain a
significant concern for much of the
sector and we must see more support
especially for those smes who did not
qualify for much of the sport announced
thus far thank you very much
thank you mr deputy speaker
children and young people have paid a
very high price through the pandemic in
terms of their liberty in terms of
learning loss and in terms of their
mental well-being we have the hokie koki
of school reopenings and exams
inflicted on parents pupils and teachers
yet our young people have shown a
remarkable resilience and school staff
rose to the challenge
now is the time
to recognize those challenges and
sacrifices now is the time to address
the widening attainment gap between the
wealthiest and the poorest children
now is the time to embrace new ways of
teaching and learning as well as to
capitalize on new levels of parental
engagement
i'm afraid her majesty's humble address
failed our children spectacularly only
one sentence one sentence dedicated to
children or education yet here we are
with the most severe disruption to our
schools in two years crises in
children's mental health and special
education needs and disability the
education secretary has managed to
secure parliamentary time for a schools
bill
and he's using that precious precious
time to tinker with structures school
structures what a waste
this technocratic schools bill tinkers
around the edges of management and
governance of schools and is not what
parents pupils or employers are crying
out for they want a broader offer that
equips our young people with broader
life skills and experiences that nurture
creativity build resilience and teamwork
and boost their well-being
all of us on all sides of this house
want to see children in school and are
alarmed by the large numbers of children
missing from school however i am
concerned that the government's zero
tolerance approach overlooks the needs
of those children who might be
struggling with their mental health or
with special needs we need to identify
and tackle the root causes of school
absence rather than go in for the all
stick and no carrot approach
i hope the government will use the
clauses in the bill that relate to the
funding formula to reverse the
devaluation of the pupil premium i'm
proud this liberal democrat policy to
support the poorest pupils was
introduced when we were in coalition
government but it has been cut in real
terms by 160 pounds per primary child
and 127 per secondary people over the
past seven years since we left
government with the attainment gap
growing the pupil premium must be
restored to its original value if the
government really is serious about
leveling up
now mr deputy speaker i have time and
again in this place highlighted the
growing mental health crisis among
children and young people we know that
unhappy children are less able to learn
thrive and perform well our teachers are
overburdened and unable to cope with the
immense challenges around pupil
well-being yet there was no reference to
the urgent action that we need
i would suggest we need an urgent
children in young people's mental health
plan recovery plan and the secretary of
state for health is here in the same way
that he's focused on the elective care
backlog i implore him to come up with a
similar plan on children's mental health
because it's desperately needed we
wouldn't ignore a child with a broken
leg yet too many children who are
mentally unwell cannot cope without the
access to help and support that they
need and liberal liberal democrats are
calling for a dedicated qualified mental
health professional in every school
finally mr deputy speaker on catch-up
funding there was no reference to this
either the sutton trust has found that
more than two-thirds of primary heads
are struggling to help children due to a
lack of catch-up funding schools in my
constituency are drawing on parental
donations
to support children with catch-up this
is a political choice
people no longer may want to talk about
the pandemic but its impact on our young
people and our economy will be felt for
decades if the right investment is not
forthcoming
i call again on government to step up
and provide the full 15 billion pounds
of catch-up funding recommended by their
own advisor sir kevin collins the
education policy institute has said that
the cost to the economy of lost learning
could run into the trillions i repeat
trillions over the next 80 years and
that's based on oecd data
that's many times the return on
investment of key infrastructure
projects if the full 15 billion catch up
is committed so let's start treating our
children
the future generation on whom we will
all be reliant on one day
as an investment and not as a cost
sadly the queen's speech has largely
ignored them
luke evans
may i take this opportunity to um say a
great deal of thanks from my
constituency to the queen for her
service over the almost 70 years as i
may not get that chance going forward
this queen's speech is labelled the
session today is making britain the best
place to grow up and to grow old two and
a half years into my service as the mp
for my constituency i thought it's worth
touching on a few things to try and move
that plan forward
we've had millions of pounds into
hinkley academy to make sure we have an
education that's supporting our local
children we've had 19.9 million pounds
go to twycross zoo to create a
conservation education center there to
breed the next conservationists of the
future
we've had 28 million pounds going to
leicestershire for internet which means
330 houses in sketchly brook in burbage
have now got better faster internet
access and we've had 1.8 million pounds
into hinckley high street to improve it
to make sure that people go to that
place and want to enjoy it whether
you're a child or an oap
we're working on getting the a5 improved
the infrastructure that's vital for our
constituency so people can get to their
jobs with 20 million pounds invested in
it and we've moved through decision
point one earlier in march and i'm keen
to see that goes forward
and of course most importantly we've had
seven million pounds put towards the
hinckley hospital with another cdc
coming forward with a plan that's coming
together ready to go and i am dead keen
to make sure there is no red tape in the
way when that cdc comes forward because
that puts hinckley on the map and
provides the service we need for our
community children adults and oaps and
that's what it's all about
but there are two parts that i'd like to
focus on in the three minutes i have
left
the first is planning
and the second is the online safety bill
now when it comes to planning i've heard
the secretary of state use an acronym
biden to discuss the five crucial points
i put it to him he's mr tricked here
because actually in bed with gov would
be a far better selling point
but the principles
are right
we need the right homes
in the right place
with the right infrastructure that's
right for our environment
that is actually actually fundamental to
our planning system and the current
planning system doesn't deliver that and
my constituency typifies it because
under the lib dem local borough
under the borough council we don't have
an up-to-date local plan which
fundamentally means every single day we
are open to speculative development
without that infrastructure without
those amenities and without that support
so i'm pleased the queen's speech is
bringing forward planning change and i
think it should really
concentrate on strengthening
neighborhood plans
localism in action especially if you
don't have an up-to-date local plan
but of course the infrastructure levy is
so important getting funding up front
for the amenities that we need the roads
the gp surgeries the schools all these
things need to be rectified and i'm glad
they're being brought forward
and of course
building out it's one thing developers
getting the land it's another thing them
using it because we need houses for
young people and their families to
aspire to
but we also need houses for our
pensioners to be able to retire down to
downsize to that providing support for
them
now the second in my last minute
is the online harms bill and i come at
this through my work on body image and
there are two fundamental things that
i'd like to see go forward in the online
harms bill
the first
is a legally named person for the
algorithm
we have safeguarding leads in school we
have cool decock guardians in health we
have gdpr controllers and the
fundamental point on our social media on
internet is the algorithm
naming someone who's accountable means
that anyone in this house or anyone in
this country would be able to hold the
big companies to account and i think
that's imperative to lifting the bonnet
to see what is underneath and what is
driving the content that all of us be it
children or adults are served
and the second is the authenticity of
images
allow people to choose if they want to
be served verified authentic images that
technology exists we're allowing people
to choose anonymity
why don't we do it with authenticated
images
these two little changes will really
make sure that we grow up and grow old
in the best of britain
it's the matters thank you mr deputy
speaker we've already had quite a lot of
discussion tonight about uh waiting
lists and i just want to talk about
another aspect of that which is actually
waiting times for mental health services
yes because they continue to be
chronically oversubscribed if people are
actually deemed enough to be referred to
them in the first place and if i may i
just want to give one example of what
this means to the person who was waiting
of a constituent who was advised in 2020
that they were displaying signs of ptsd
and an emotionally unstable personality
disorder they were accepted onto a
dialectical behavior therapy treatment
course which had a two-year waiting list
which of course uh has been exacerbated
by kerbin however in the second year of
waiting there's been no update
whatsoever from the mental health trust
so my constituent is just left waiting
and wondering how much longer it will be
before she receives any treatment at all
we of course have been chasing the trust
as well as the mp's office but we
haven't heard anything either i just
think this is a really appalling way to
treat some of the most vulnerable people
in our communities
i also want to join in with what my
honourable friend the member from
bradford south said about dentistry
in my area uh waiting lists are in their
thousands with one practice quoting a
waiting list of more than 3 000 people
one constituent contacted me because of
the pain she was experiencing described
her attempts to register a practice
as a fight which i think sums up the
situation perfectly and in the last six
months of 2021 our 2021 i was contacted
by dozens of different constituents all
of them were actually contacting
on behalf of their families as well as
themselves i think it's well documented
just how challenging it is that the
issues dentists face in relation to the
uda
which doesn't encourage dentists to take
on new patients and only accommodates 50
percent of the population that in effect
means we start from a position where the
government knows that many people will
be denied access to dental care that
have consciously and deliberately
accepted their policy will leave many
people either forced to carry on in pain
or seek treatment from the private
sector the whole system is in desperate
need of reform and of course we cannot
have a debate on the nhs at the moment
without having regard to the impact kobe
decides but mustn't just limit it to
covert itself but also
how people
have been suffering from long covered it
remains a huge issue recent reports have
suggested number of people seeking
helpful on covert is to be in the region
of 1.8 million people
that is a huge number mr deputy speaker
and it's reported some sufferers are
waiting so long for help that they are
taking advice on bang their own oxygen
to help with their breathlessness whilst
others are also seeking advice on
accessing private health care because
they can't get anything from the nhs and
that is a nub of this
the pattern we are seeing in just about
every aspect of healthcare for surgical
procedures for mental health support the
dental treatment people are finding the
system that they have paid into all
their lives is no longer there for them
and the founding principle of universal
healthcare free at the point of use that
is supposed to be the bedrock of the nhs
is under threat this will lead to
privatization by default and we will be
all the poorer for that i just want to
say a little bit mr deputy speaker about
the cost of living because every
indicator i see shows that things are
going to get much worse before they get
better interest rates inflation energy
bills food bills we're on the cusp of a
tsunami that will send many people under
and i won't even start to talk about the
complete failure to support british
agriculture
and get those crops being planted in the
ground which will cause us problems next
year but for many the point of
destitution has already arrived and i'm
sorry to say numbers of people see me in
that situation because they've already
gone through all the emergency
assistance agencies and they've had
their quota for the year is showing me
that there is a real problem and the
state isn't offering any solutions and
telling people to get a better paid job
or work more hours is just patronizing
nonsense that just shows how touch this
government is
so it's shocking in those circumstances
in terms of the most pressing issue that
requires urgent action there is nothing
about the cost of living in the queen
speech there's nothing to give families
security they need and i really don't
see
what the objection is to a windfall tax
on north sea or profits and gas profits
the clue is in the name mr deputy
speaker winfor these companies were not
expecting this money therefore it cannot
be a restraint on investment that some
would claim it to be but it would make a
huge difference to my constituents
twelve and a half thousand families in
my constituency alone would see 400
pounds off their bills as a result of a
windfall tax and i think that is
something that we should really continue
to push for
but in the end we we have
a whole system
where
we are seeing a rowing back of public
services many constituents see the
transport network uh decay public
service is decaying local councils staff
the resources town centre's closing down
i think there is so much more that we
need to be addressing and i'm afraid for
me the humble address fails to do that
yeah
jacob young
uh mr deputy speaker it's pleasure to
follow the honourable member for
ellesmere port and to congratulate him
as well for offgem's recent announcement
that elsmere port as well as red car
will progress to stage two the hydrogen
village trials
today's debate is on making britain the
best place to grow up and grow old and
we're doing just that
but this queen's speech must be viewed
in the context of a war in europe and a
growing energy crisis that's why for me
the energy security bill is one of the
most important bills in this speech
because defense and energy security go
hand in hand
putin has been emboldened because of
europe's collective
reliance on russian gas and he uses this
as a weapon as can be seen in his rash
reaction to finland's desire to join
nato
our energy bill will enable us not only
to achieve energy sovereignty in a
dangerous world but also furthers us
along the path to net zero and creates
thousands of jobs in the process in
places like t-side
in t-side we are quickly becoming the
center of excellence for green
technology through offshore wind the
world's first industrial ski industrial
scale carbon capture utilization and
storage project
hydrogen production with five gigawatts
of hydrogen planned and hydrogen village
trials that i mentioned a few moments
ago and of course our nuclear power
station at hartley pool
but hartlepool power station was
commissioned in 1983
a whole ten years before i was born mr
deputy speaker and only three power
stations have been commissioned in the
uk since then
in the 13 years of the blair brown
government not one new power station
constructed and six decommissioned
new labour turned its back on new
nuclear and were righting their wrongs
with a new power station every year for
the next decade
this queen speech will help us address
this great national challenge ensuring
that our critical infrastructure remains
future-proofed to the evolving needs of
the 21st century
an investment in infrastructure is a key
signature of this government's
commitment to leveling up
but i think we can go further
and i look particularly to hs2
currently hs2 has no commitment to using
uk source steel in its construction
i think that's wrong
it's nonsensical to have a situation
where every few years this steel
industry finds itself in further
hardship and we as mps for steel
constituencies go knocking at the door
of the treasury
surely a better use of taxpayers money
is for procurement rules to benefit
foundation industries in the uk over
international counterparts and i hope
that that's what the procurement bill
allows
it's not an excuse for uk industry to
not be competitive in its pricing but we
should acknowledge that in any
procurement decision the economic and
social value that investment in uk
industry brings and the leveling up
effect that such investment can have
the purpose of our leveling up program
is the next generation
that is why this government is also
investing in a world-class school system
to deliver the high quality education
that our young people deserve and the
school's bill will set it will
absolutely set us on a path to achieving
this
in red career cleveland we've made great
strides under this government to invest
in our local schools particularly at a
primary school level with over 20
million invested to revitalize the over
40 of the 48 primary schools over the
past decade newcomer primary remains one
of the best in the country
but despite this more still needs to be
done to ensure that every child has the
education in nature they deserve and in
my part of the world this particularly
relates to our secretary school and i
hope this school's bill helps achieve
this
and i want to finally thank the
government
for bringing forward the conversion
therapy bill again and i speak as a gay
christian who can't wait for this
government to finally outlaw conversion
therapy
everyone lgbt or otherwise deserves to
grow up and grow old being who they are
without the threat of disgusting
outdated and hopefully soon to be
criminal practices labeled as conversion
therapy
to conclude we are three years into this
prime minister's leadership we face the
biggest political challenge in the
post-war era with brexit and the single
biggest health challenge in 100 years
with corvid
and we now face the dual challenge of
our energy security and war in europe
once again
this queen speech demonstrates our
willingness to tackle the big issues of
the deer becoming energy secure while
leveling up across the whole of the
united kingdom we have been tasked with
delivering on the people's priorities
and we're doing just that
thank you mr deputy speaker i do welcome
the legislation to protect access to
cash it's a lifeline for many of the
most vulnerable and one of the best
budgeting tools that there is but it
does need to be enacted speedily
closures are happening daily and the
more they are the more difficult and
costly it is to reverse them
there does need to be statutory
regulation for shops to offer cashback
it is a service offered by many but it
could be withdrawn at any time at the
moment and also shops need to be
forced to accept cash people who choose
to budget that way should be able to
spend where they wish
i also welcome the regulation to force
banks to reimburse the losses through
the push payment scans
enforcement and top penalties will be
key but i would also like to see
transparency so customers can see how
quickly and how many people they
reimburse in this aspect and then they
can choose their banks accordingly
and more needs to be done to protect
consumer rights not just by giving the
cma new powers to fine firms who break
the rules but we also need to ensure
that consumer groups are consulted in
all changes to consumer protection
particularly when any eu laws are
scrapped we don't want a reduction in
standards
there also needs to be a new duty and a
clear remit for the fca to have regard
to financial inclusion and ensure
consumers aren't excluded from products
and services by the poverty premium
now there have been many comments made
about people using food banks because
they can't budget or cook a meal from
scratch
now both from my own experience and from
23 years dealing with people in debt and
on low incomes i haven't found this to
be the case in fact it's quite the
opposite and i will give you a little of
my own experience to demonstrate this
when i was left alone with a very young
child i did find a job very quickly it
wasn't greatly well paid but i managed
if i was careful and if there were no
unexpected bills which is often the
tipping point why people get into debt i
got up at 00 am i got my daughter who
was 18 months old ready for the child
minder breakfast drove 30 miles to work
because there was no public transport
suitable did a day's work drove home
gave my daughter tea bastard for bed 8
p.m thought about my tea prepared for
the next day that was every weekday
weekends tidying washing and trying to
spend some time with my daughter and
play with her
doing this week in week out it's no
wonder that people have little time or
energy to prepare meals from scratch
every day or batch cook every weekend
i certainly didn't and it's no wonder
people resort to frozen convenience food
or heaven forbid a takeaway instead of a
rush sandwich
there is a saying about not judging
people until you've walked a mile in
their shoes
and cab brought that home to me and i
think we'd all do well to remember that
now we have 2.1 million people a year
using food banks to survive it's been
said that throwing money at the problem
won't help but actually it's probably
the only thing that will help as too
many people have too little income to
pay bills and eat and heat
a windfall tax is one measure that could
happen
reinstating the 20 pound uplift to
universal credit and a moratorium on
deductions from benefits which lead
people well below the poverty line would
also help
but undoubtedly there will be an
increase in demand for debt advice and
an increase in the numbers of people who
have no disposable income to pay their
creditors
i'd like to know what discussions the
government is having with both
businesses and their own departments
regarding treatment of people who have
no chance of paying off their debts due
to lack of income
according to the joseph rowntree
foundation nearly 4 million low-income
households are behind
on essential bills
rent
or debt payments to creditors that's
gone up threefold since the pandemic
what measures are being considered to
help these people
we perhaps need to look at the jubilee
debt campaign and write off some of
these debts because there's no point in
leaving people in constant debt all it's
doing is building up mental health
problems ill health
and
causing more and more pressure
on the the support networks for these
people
the prime minister promised to bring his
full fiscal firepower to tackle the cost
of living crisis
well on past performance so far these
measures have proved a pretty damp squib
for most of my constituents
dana davison
thank you mr deputy speaker now today's
theme is all around making this britain
the best place to grow up and grow old
and since i'm still clinging onto my 20s
desperately i'm going to focus on the
growing up side of things for now and as
a northeast mp i'll be focusing on my
region and on my own fabulous
constituency of bishop auckland
and we know that there are talented kids
right across our country in every single
community but for generations and
unfortunately because of the actions of
successive governments too many
ambitious talented young people feel
they have to move away from their
hometowns to chase their jobs and chase
their fortunes
now the government is already making
progress on this particularly in our
region we see the suedes of high quality
jobs coming to darlington thanks to the
new treasury and dit campuses opening up
but also the success of ben houch and
tease value mayor empowered by
government policy on devolution and on
freeport bringing high quality high
skilled high paid jobs to our region
that are well within commuting distance
of bishop auckland
but as we know it is not just about jobs
we need town centres with diverse shops
enjoyable leisure activities and vibrant
nightlife for the whole of the town to
enjoy and on this the government is
helping and helping pretty well i'd say
in bishop auckland as well as the
leveling up fund which is delivering
much-needed infrastructure improvements
to the a68 at toftel and to walton
bridge we're also the proud recipients
of both the town's fund and the
levelling up fund
now since i became the mp for bishop
auckland is over 70 million pounds of
direct funding into bishop auckland to
deliver tangible improvements to our
town centres attracting private
investment and creating job
opportunities for our young people and
i'm really delighted that the queen's
speech is going to continue this
ambitious plan through the leveling up
and regeneration bill but also the
non-domestic rating bill too helping
empower businesses improve our local
communities and breathe new life into
our high streets because we all know
they need that new life
we know that town centres are the
cultural hearts of our communities
in my own constituency we're very
pleased to have the bose museum and the
rhythm in barnard castle in bishop
auckland we benefit from kinron and the
bishop auckland food festival in
spanimore the norman cornish gallery but
it's not just town centres where we have
these cultural gems they also exist
further afield grass home observatory
and teas their locomotion railway museum
outside children and great shows great
country shows like eggleston and bows
which i enjoy every summer and if this
sounds like a tourism pitch people it
absolutely is because the best way
the best way to turbo charge making
bishop auckland one of the best places
to grow up and to thrive is by ensuring
that county durham wins uk city of
culture 2025 but let me just rephrase
that because we don't want to be the
city of culture we want to be the uk's
first ever county of culture and i hope
that ministers on the front then today
will send this message to the culture
secretary because we know that what that
city of culture status can do unlocking
the opportunities of tourism and
advertise that county durham is open for
business
but being the best place to grow up also
means not living in fear of crime in
communities riddled with anti-social
behavior and we will all know about that
from our own communities now i'm really
pleased that county durham is already
seeing its share of 20 000 new police
officers there's some absolutely
cracking people i thank them
wholeheartedly for their service and for
their engagement with our local
communities but for those who are
unfortunate enough to be victims of
victims of crime they need to feel like
they get both support and justice
and both as an mp for my community but
also the chair of the all party
parliamentary group on one punch assault
i greatly welcome the victims bill and
all that it will achieve
and the short time that i've got left it
would be remiss of me not to touch on
the conversion therapy ban
something that's been talked about for a
very long time and i'm very pleased to
see it in this queen's speech this year
because young people straight or gay or
bi
or trans
should be free to live and love as they
wish to supported in that by the
government and that means banning
conversion therapy this abort practice
finally banning it
not just for under 18s not just for
people who are part of the lgb community
but for everyone for the entire lgbt
community and certainly i plan to
continue my engagement with government
to make sure we get the right
legislation on this foreign practice
among hussein
thank you mr deputy speaker
mr deputy speaker over the last few days
of
this debate we have heard
some harrowing stories from
constituencies around the country of
poverty of deprivation of destitution
of people living
hunter mouth in some of the worst
possible
scenarios however the secretary of state
who opened this debate today seems
probably missed a lot of that because
the picture according to the secretary
of state is
this is
a place where actually people can't get
enough opportunities
actually
young people have never had it as good
actually
every school is
funded exactly as it should be actually
we've never had a health service that's
operated as it should what parallel
universe the secretary of state is
living in
i have absolutely
no idea mr deputy speaker and you know
mr speaker it's fine talking mr deputy
speaker it's fine talking about
opportunities
but actually what about the obstacles
that people face
before they get to those opportunities
and the biggest obstacle is poverty
yeah and
let's be clear about this
poverty did not arise a few months ago
with the cost of living crisis
poverty
has been
worsened over the last 12 years
because
of an ideological
austerity by those opposite
that has devastated our communities
and this is
an absolute reality
of where we are
and when i hear mr deputy speaker
of honorable members
opposite
even a minister
a time when people
are facing some of the worst challenges
ever
going on national television
and saying people should budget better
people need to
find
more hours
in work as though that is the reason
people are poor
when's the last time
we met anybody that chose to be poor
when's the last time we met a child
who was born in poverty and said you
know what actually that's the right
thing i'm glad i was born in that
household
and i urge the secretary of state
to come to a place like bradford
where our young people
are full of aspiration
are full of ambition
are full of doing tragically
the media do not give bradford an easy
ride all the time
and i'm frankly fed up of the media's
unfair image of bradford and our young
people sometimes but we are a vibrant
city we have the youngest population
but what we lack is the opportunity the
same opportunity the secretary of state
stood on that dispatch box earlier today
and apparently told me and my
constituents and people in my district
that somehow we have
now the reality is
he could have used
he could have used his time today and
they could have used
their time in this queen's speech and
honorable members opposite know this
those who represent constituencies with
poverty with deprivation will know
inside themselves that this queen speech
is a missed opportunity because actually
it does nothing to provide opportunity
to young people in bradford it does
nothing
actually to
address the issues that we have health
inequalities if you live in bradford you
are likely to live in the inner cities
of bradford you are likely to live 10
years less than if you live in an
affluent city suburb these are the
realities educational attainment you are
likely to achieve a lot less than if you
lived in a rich leafy suburb
now that's the unfairness those are the
barriers that we are talking about
and if the exactly of state who came
earlier today and uh the secretary of
state health was going to close this
if they want to address these
inequalities
then
they've missed that opportunity they
should follow the suggestion that we've
made we need an emergency budget to
address the destitution that is life in
our country because poverty mr deputy
speaker is a political choice and the
people of this country will remember the
choice they made
danny kruger
how to follow that okay well thank you
very much indeed mr deputy speaker for
calling me i'll try and just use the
microphones for her amplification um
uh i i'm actually grateful to the
opposition for choosing this subject i
think it's a very good way of framing
the mission that we have as a country
because uh a nation that is good to grow
up and grow old in uh is one that is
also ready for the threats of our times
and i'm with edmund burke who said and i
quote that the sources of the
commonwealth are in the household
the strength of our country
is found in our families and in our
communities
and these threats are very real
we we've
seen in our in this
century already how precarious our
financial system is we've seen very
recently what a pandemic can do to
global
uh health and economy systems uh we are
witnessing now the appalling reality of
war in europe and the real threat of
nuclear war and i
think also of the threats of
technological collapse
triggered by
accident or sabotage
and the prospect even if we don't fully
believe the profits of the apocalypse uh
but of what climate change could do to
the developing world and inducing
extraordinary uh upheaval and prospects
of hundreds of millions of people on the
move
heading for our safe and temperate
continent so we face a series of very
real threats to our country and to our
civilization
there's a lot to be confident about in
the uk the strength of our institutions
including our democracy and for all our
disputes
the strength of this place our
parliament
and i think also the dedication of those
who serve the state on the front line
not least in the british army uh and i
mentioned those who formed the largest
garrison in the uk in my constituency in
wiltshire
but some of the greatest assets of our
country mr deputy speaker are not mostly
found in the agencies of the british
state
and i think of two recent crises that
led us proud as a country
the situation of millions of isolating
people during the covert lockdowns
and the plight of hundreds of thousands
of refugees fleeing the war in ukraine
and for all the efforts of ministers and
officials in both those situations i
think it is fair to say that the
apparatus of the state struggled to
manage fast enough to help but society
did millions of people step forward
during kobe to organize spontaneously
mutual aid groups to support their
neighbours and we have had hundreds of
thousands of people
offering homes and support for refugees
in both these cases the state enabled
and helped fund the work of communities
but it was communities that took the
initiative
and did the work
and this brings me to the nub of my
argument if we are to rise to the
threats
of our time the crucial thing the
watchword of our whole strategy should
be resilience
now of course this means national
security and yes we need to modernize
the british state we need to invest even
more than we are in our national defense
and we need real security in our energy
supplies our food supplies uh and in
technology
but the system we really need to be
strong isn't the state or the economy
it's society itself this is the real
foundation of national resilience and
national security the security of our
communities and our families
so how do we strengthen our communities
and our families well our communities
need
the plans outlined in the leveling up
bill
in the queen's speech more devolution
more community power
and i also want to see more reform of
our public services to put them in the
hands of local people not outposts of
the central state
and our families
need more power and resources too we
need more family sized homes including
affordable and social housing has been
announced and i also welcome the plans
for the expansion of the community hubs
program and when it comes to child care
and social care
the answer does not lie in my view an
ever greater larger provision
large-scale warehousing of children and
the elderly trying to arrange for the
home and the family to do as little as
possible we must help people to live as
they would prefer to work closer to home
to have time for meaningful family life
we need people to be able to spend the
money that is available for child care
and residential social care in the way
that is best for them to look after
their children or their parents at home
if they wish or to pay for informed
support among friends and family
to put it bluntly it shouldn't only be
possible to get government money if you
put your dependence in an
institution and while i'm at it mr
deputy speaker we need tax and benefits
that reward couples not penalize them
the family is the best and the most
important welfare agency that we have or
possibly could have we should invest in
it and trust in it thank you
marion fellows
adam deputy speaker when i read the
theme of today's debate i truly didn't
know whether to laugh or cry
on whose deluded planet could anyone
believe that britain is the best place
to grow up and grow old and really has
this government had a good look at other
countries
an oecd summit a survey covering 2017 to
2019 showed that 15 and a half percent
of what over 66 in britain were living
in relative poverty rates in iceland
denmark and norway were under four
percent
small independent countries can do it
under this tory government nay chance
madam deputy speaker i'd like to speak
for a moment on behalf of waspi women
in the 1995 pensions act the government
increased state pensions aid for women
from 60 to 65 with a further increase to
66 in the 2011 pensions act these
changes were poorly communicated to
affected women with many not finding out
about the change till 2012
the parliamentary and health art service
ombudsman found that the department of
work and pensions was guilty of mal
administration
warspie campaigning for affected women
are calling for an immediate one-off
compensation
compensation payment of between 11 666
and 20 000 pounds
and by the end of this calendar year
220
190 women across the uk will have died
waiting for justice in the seven years
since the waspy campaign began
the sector has saved itself 39.8 billion
in missing compensation through these
deaths based on likely compensation
figures called for
by mosby i could go on madam deputy
speaker these women need justice they
paid in the government should pay out
many madam deputy speaker over elderly
are supported by unpaid carers a much
a neglected group who make the
difference to many
carers uk have asked this tory
government to take immediate action as
they feel it's not too late for the
government to step in and recognize
their vital role
of course that's in england
in scotland in scotland the scotland had
made a uk terror allowance uh two unpaid
carers and it was the first payment made
by social security scotland it increases
terrorist allowance by around 13
with eligible carers receiving a 231
pounds 40 payment
every six months the scottish
government's carers allowance supplement
means that since 2018 carers have
received over 460
pounds a year more in scotland than
carers in the rest of the uk
carers uk was also looking for as many
of us where we're looking for an
employment bill giving immediate rights
to flexible working
this is a huge omission from this
government's programme for business
we've heard already madam deputy speaker
about the baby box and how
what a fantastic thing it is in scotland
and how it supports families who cannot
afford much absolutely
mad madam deputy speaker
in scotland
people care and the government cares
about those less fortunate than
themselves could we have some of that
down here in england i know this debate
was called britain it was about britain
but really most of what the minister
spoke about today was england possibly
wales and possibly northern ireland
there wasn't a great deal for scotland
that's why
increasingly this tory uk government
actually lets scotland down
the best way for scotland to get out of
poverty madam deputy speaker is for us
to become an independent country giving
us the powers to make scotland the best
place to grow up and to grow old in and
i strongly look forward to that day
junior crosby
thank you madam deputy speaker it's a
privilege to speak in today's debate uh
our ample honor spawn on behalf of the
people of honest mourn and to follow
many excellent speeches
the subject of today's debate making
britain the best place to grow up and
grow old is truly a subject that
particularly resonates with my
constituents
in this debate a year ago i spoke about
how the uk government's plans were
hardwired for opportunity
i spoke of initiatives already ongoing
on honest mourn like the holy head
hydrogen hub monesta and morlice and i
spoke of my hopes and aspirations for
honest mourn
one year on i can see genuine progress
for my constituency an island which
includes some of the most deprived
communities in the uk
last may my island community was reeling
from the withdrawal of hitachi from the
proposed will vanilla with nuclear power
station on honest mourn they cited
financing as a major issue
and the potential high quality
employment opportunities for local
people from the proposed plant were
hugely significant in an area of high
unemployment
the potential loss madam deputy speaker
hit the community
hard
since then this government has taken
significant action it has fast-tracked
the nuclear financing bill to support
the funding of new nuclear it produced a
british energy security strategy in
which wilbur was specifically mentioned
where this government committed to the
acceleration of nuclear and eight new
nuclear plants this very decade
and is setting up the great british
nuclear delivery vehicle which will be
headed up by simon bowen a welshman
in january the prime minister a fervent
supporter of willva visited wilbur with
me to see its potential for himself and
just last week in a first for honest
mourn wilvo was visited by the energy
minister the secretary of state for base
and the secretary of state for wales the
minister and two secretary of states
came to announce the 120 million pound
future nuclear enabling fund announced
the plans for at least one freeport in
wales i'm so proud that anglesey is now
front and center of government policy an
island in north wales where our most
senior ministers come to make
significant national announcements
so how does this fit into today's debate
i regularly highlight to this house how
honestmon hemorrhages its young people
every single year in search of skilled
employment the data shows we have an
average number of births and an average
number of school children we have a
fantastic secondary and tertiary
education on the island group
plantaricular menai headed up by daffod
evans is one of the largest fe colleges
in the uk has excellent facilities and
gives practical vocational training
across a range of disciplines including
the energy sector alert jones griffith
is the principal of colleague mennai and
this college worked with horizon to
produce young apprentices who had to
leave honest morn to find work at the
hinckley nuclear power station
honest one wants its young people to
come back arness moore needs the next
generation of young people to stay on
the island and to have a future
without local jobs our bright keen young
people take their skills and enthusiasm
elsewhere in search of better better
careers better opportunities and better
pay and with them they take our welsh
language culture and culture
i made a commitment to honor swan that i
would work hard and fight to bring jobs
and investments to its shores i'll be
supporting the uk government's
priorities for the year ahead including
the energy security bill the leveling up
and regeneration bill welsh free ports
and the shared prosperity fund
are we doing that so the communities of
honest moon will reap the rewards that
will make it a great place to grow up to
under this government's plans honest
morn is shifting from a place that feels
forgotten to one in which our young
people can look forward to the same
exciting opportunities that others
across the uk enjoy
a place where local people can earn good
salaries where local people can enjoy
fulfilling careers and where local
people can buy their own homes and where
school children have local role models
to inspire them
this is what the people of honest moon
want this is what the people of
honestmon deserve and working with the
uk government this is what i aim to
deliver jochenval
carolyn harris
speaker
today's theme of making britain the best
place to grow up and grow old and made
me think back to my childhood i grew up
a stone throw away from where i still
live in swan's east a proud
working-class area and it still is today
we didn't have a lot but we had enough
and that's the difference
now i'm honored to represent my local
community and i'm delighted to be able
to help those in need with the summer
lunch club a fast approach and my team
are working on how many children we can
realistically feed through the summer
scheme and we're already looking forward
to christmas and to trying to establish
whether we need to help more than the
2000 families we helped last year
and whilst i'm privileged to be able to
use my platform to do this it breaks my
heart that i have to
if we are serious about making britain
the best place to grow up in then the
government needs to do more
much much more to tackle the food
poverty and social injustice that we all
see in our constituencies every day
despite many promises in the royal
address words alone do nothing action on
promises is what's needed
warm words are not delivering on the
insurances by this government that men
of portal women in england would only
have to pay one annual fee for the hrt
prescription the announcement was made
in october 21
but it now looks as if it won't happen
until april 2023
that's not what was said
that's not what was anticipated and it's
not with the women who attended this
place on that day to welcome the
the government's commitment believed
as a result of this i other colleagues
across the house and very many menopause
campaigners groups and individuals have
recently launched the menopause mandate
which aims to ensure that we will add
our voice to make sure that it is fair
and equal access to menopause support
and services right across the country
and i'm not even going to start on the
hrt shortage which i've written to the
health secretary about on so many
occasions i was beginning to think we'd
started a pen pal relationship although
the la his lack of response is obviously
a one-sided arrangement
now there were glimmers of hope in the
queen's pitch but they were just
glimmers
primarily the commitment to publish
draft legislation to reform the mental
health act
as a woman who spent 12 years on
antidepressants
after wrongly self diagnosing with a
nervous breakdown and depression instead
of what it was the menopause
i know how vital it is that links are
made between the two
i'm pleased that depression is listed as
a clinical indicator on the quality and
outcomes framework
but i'm disappointed that menopause
isn't
i'm not being critical of depression
being on that nor the fact that doctors
are incentivized to diagnose and treat
it but what concerns me is what is being
missed
because all too often anxiety and
depression are diagnosed when menopause
is the problem
it's really important the similarities
and the links between menopause and
mental health are better understood by
medical practitioners the governments
have an opportunity here through the
proposed mental health act to include
the menopause and the impact it has on
mental health in this piece of
legislation
i'm truly passionate about making
britain the best place to grow up and
grow old in and i've been called a lot
of things in my time the sandwich lady
the men opposed lady a prohibitionist
and a methodist if you listen to the
gambian lobby and quite a few other
things that i can actually say in this
chamber but in last week's debate on the
address the member for bracken and
breton and radner give me perhaps my
favorite title when truly referred to me
as a pain in the government's neck
i'm very proud of that
and for the record i fully intend to
continue that trait
[Applause]
madam deputy speaker it's a great
pleasure to follow the honourable ladies
speech
madam deputy speaker this queen's speech
promises to deliver an agenda that
reflects the ambition and the
aspirations of the british people our
debate today focuses on some of the most
significant periods of our lives growing
up and growing old and the bills in this
queen's speech will make britain an even
better place to do both
education is the ultimate expression of
levelling up good not just for our
employment prospects but for our
well-being our personal development good
not just for the individual but for the
economy and for society
einstein said education is not the
learning of facts but the training of
minds to think
an educated thinking population creates
a productive dynamic innovative and
entrepreneurial population capable of
meeting the challenges of this country
so i'm pleased to see in this queen's
speech the government's determination to
deliver an education for all ages
whether you're starting out a primary
school a student at the local technical
college or in your 40s or 50s wanting to
retrain and learn new skills
my constituency of ellsbury has superb
grammar schools which can consistently
feature as some of the top state schools
in the country
but as well as pure academic
qualifications we also need young people
with the technical and vocational skills
that are fit for the modern economy
bucks utc with its offer of health and
digital courses is an excellent place to
learn those skills for children in my
constituency one that i am proud to
champion
and bucks college is an enthusiastic
advocate and adopter of t levels a
qualification that like my right
honourable friend the secretary of state
for education i want to see as famous
and as respected as a levels
the school's bill promises to help every
child fulfill their potential by raising
standards as a former school governor
i've seen firsthand how joining a strong
multi-academy trust can enable schools
to flourish as they benefit from high
standards and expectations this is
exactly what far more schools will do
with this legislation
i'm also very pleased that the
department for education has now
published the send green paper
my constituency has excellent volunteer
organizations like grasps which help
parents to navigate the minefield that
education and healthcare plans
many parents have come to my office in
sheer desperation trying to resolve
difficulties with the hcps and i'm glad
that the government particularly the
minister on the front bench is working
really hard to improve this i would
respectfully urge ministers in the
department of health to ensure that the
nhs plays its part in ensuring that
children with special educational needs
and disabilities are treated as they
should be because sadly all too often
the delays and difficulties i see stem
from health rather than from education
madam deputy speaker growing up is not
just about getting good exam results a
great apprenticeship or a job
it's also been about becoming a rounded
adult confident and secure in oneself
that's why i'm delighted to see the
inclusion in the queen speech of the
conversion therapy bill which will ban
frankly evil and abhorrent practices
which are intended to change sexual
orientation
we all need to be free to love who we
want to love
for too many of us it took too long to
be able to do that too long to accept
ourselves for who we are and too long
for others to accept us
let us hope that this bill will be
another step to enable today's young
people today's generation to feel safe
and secure in acknowledging and
expressing their sexuality
madam deputy speaker we're often keen to
talk about the delights and the
opportunities of childhood but less
enthusiastic about confronting some of
the challenges of growing old
too often elderly people are almost
hidden from view
so i'm extremely pleased that this
government is putting older people at
the heart of its plans for social care
with a comprehensive vision and
substantial investment coupled with a
massive commitment to the nhs through
funding recruitment and the construction
of new hospitals
madam deputy speaker no one can deny
that we face difficult times in the
months ahead
but with the measures announced in the
queen's speech our country is equipped
to encounter any challenge and any
adversary with skill experience and
expertise with resilience enthusiasm and
true british grit lillian greenwood
thank you madam deputy speaker
this queen's speech shows that the
government either doesn't understand or
doesn't care about the lives of my
constituents in nottingham south
top of their agenda but sadly not the
governments is practical action to
address the soaring cost of living
crisis
take my constituent a single mum of two
living in privately rented accommodation
despite working full-time
when her wage goes in and her rent and
bills are paid she has just 75 pounds a
month left over to feed and clothe her
family including two teenagers
she told me my daughter came home from
school worried because she had a cookery
exam and didn't want to tell me because
she was worried about me having to spend
more on the shopping list for her
ingredients can you imagine as a mother
how that made me feel
i'm sure you'll agree with me madam
deputy speaker that the situation my
constituent faces is not her fault and
that young people should not face those
worries
rents and prices are rising fast energy
bills are skyrocketing and wages aren't
keeping pace
yet the government chose to scrap the
uplift to universal credit the
government chose to raise national
insurance contributions i don't hold the
government responsible
for
global price rises but i do hold them
responsible for 12 years of failure for
making a difficult situation worse and
for failing to act now to protect those
who are least able to withstand economic
shocks instead of listening and acting
ministers and mps lecture people telling
them they'd be fine if only they bought
value brands cooked better or improved
their budgeting they patronized people
saying work longer hours or get a pet
paid job
if they really cared about pay and job
security the speech would have included
legislation to protect workers from
unscrupulous employment practices
action to deliver affordable child care
and measures to enable parents to better
combine work and care
it doesn't
and some members of the government seem
determined to add insult to injury
demanding people stop working from home
and spend even more time and money
commuting
for children growing up in tory britain
life is getting harder the resolution
foundation predicts that by 2024 25 more
than one in three children will be
living in poverty well in nottingham
south they already are that's almost 6
000 children in my constituency being
let down
by this government
and there's nothing graceful about
growing old in tory britain either
we're now at the point where many older
people who've worked and paid taxes
their whole lives are having to choose
between heating and eating as pensions
fail to keep pace with rising prices
research by age uk shows that
three-quarters of older people in the uk
are worried about the rising cost of
living and if energy bills increase
substantially as we inevitably expect
them to a quarter of all people have
said they'll choose between heating
their home and buying food
some of the poorest pensioners are
already cold and hungry
madam deputy speaker the government
should have used the queen's speech to
introduce an emergency budget including
a windfall tax on oil and gas companies
near record profits to get money off
people's bills
but they didn't
they should have announced investment in
energy efficiency measures measuring
labour's plans matching labour's plans
to insulate 19 million homes in a decade
that would reduce gas imports make homes
warmer and cut bills whilst helping to
tackle the climate crisis and create new
jobs
they chose not to
on the cost of living and support for
workers on energy efficiency security
and sustainability on nhs waiting lists
at a record level on social care on
vital public services including youth
clubs libraries road maintenance parks
and so much more this government has
failed
my constituents deserve better i'm
afraid they won't get it under the
conservatives
[Music]
james davis thank you madam deputy
speaker and it's a pleasure to speak in
this queen speech debate on making
britain the best place to grow up and
grow old and to follow my honourable the
honourable member for nottingham south
now with 38 bills in the queen's speech
covering a wide range of topics from
crime and disorder to education and the
economy and cost of living there will be
much legislating to do in the next
several months
today however i'll focus on the
transport bill the data reform bill and
the financial services and market spill
madam deputy speaker improved public
transport infrastructure and services
are vital to ensure this country is in a
good place to grow up with opportunities
for all
the proposed transport bill will of
course create great british railways and
i hope this can help overcome some of
the fragmentation we currently see
including between the wales and borders
franchise and the rest of great
britain's network
our nearest major cities of manchester
and liverpool and their airports can be
reached on average in just over an hour
by road from real in my constituency in
comparison existing rail services take
around two hours at a similar distance
by rail in the south east of britain can
take as little as 40 minutes
poor regional rail services stifle
economic growth including our vital
tourism sector
suppress efforts to reduce higher than
average unemployment
and result in just two percent of
commutes to the north west of england
being by rail
some 80 less than the national average
so i urge the government to ensure that
rail infrastructure improvements north
wales requires are placed in the soon to
be updated rnet at the decision to
develop stage
the transport bill is expected to
contain provisions to enable the
installation of more electric vehicle
charge points a move that is very much
needed locally
i hope the bill will also contain
provisions to bring into being uk net
strategic transport network for the
whole of the uk as recommended in the
union connectivity review
moving on to the data reform bill i
believe that this has the potential to
empower citizens and improve their lives
by a more effective delivery of public
health care security and government
services
requiring uk wide comparable and
interoperable data within our public
services but particularly the nhs
could help identify unacceptable
performance allow learning from best
practice and drive improvement and
change
it would also allow the electorate to be
better able to identify success or
failure and hold politicians to account
accordingly
madam deputy speaker we must remember
that cash remains an important part of
life for millions of people across the
uk as they grow up and grow old
particularly those in vulnerable groups
atms remain the most popular way of
withdrawing cash but their numbers have
been in decline recently
i have experience of this in my own
constituency where in verstatin high
street the number of atms dropped from
six to zero due to the rapid closure of
several banks
cash is still important for many
residents and companies in my
constituency especially the independent
businesses in the high street
following a campaign and thanks to
cardtronics three new cash machines have
now been installed in the town centre
so i welcome the fact that the financial
services and markets bill will protect
cash by ensuring continued access to
withdrawal and deposit facilities across
the uk
it's important that the bill is
delivered as soon as possible so as
existing cash infrastructure can be
protected
it's also my hope that the legislation
will set out that link be formally
regulated by the financial conduct
authority to ensure access to cash
whether that be through mandating the
installation of atms recommending new
banking hubs or requiring enhanced post
office services
legislation should ensure that
communities which have lost banking
services before this year of 2022 such
as prestatin potentially qualify for a
hub rather than only those which lose
branches after the legislation is on the
statute book
consideration should also be given to
the ongoing availability of welsh
language banking service provision in a
community
this is a concern that mentor yaith
sirathimbik has emphasized in
correspondence with me particularly in
relation to the town of denbigh
but i'm deputy speaker the queen's
speech has delivered a promising set of
bills which will help to ensure that
britain remains one of the best places
to grow up and grow old and i look
forward to helping shape the legislation
as it progresses through parliament
ronnie kell thank you very much madam
deputy speaker
we cannot provide equal opportunities
and a stimulating environment throughout
life which will enable people to live
truly fulfilling lives while we continue
to have such high levels of poverty and
insecurity and we will continue to
support a society where greed is good
and poverty is rife
research provided by independent age in
partnership with city university of
london tried to financial health of
people past state pension age between
2010 and 2019.
that was shocking finding was that forty
percent of pensioners spent at least one
year in poverty during the nine year
period
the queen's speech was a missed
opportunity to introduce immediate
measures that could help to alleviate
the devastating effects of the cost of
living crisis including a commitment to
ensure pension credit reaches those who
are entitled to it increases in social
benefit income from things like pension
credit are a crucial factor in helping
older people escape poverty particularly
to among people is 75 plus
as take-up remains stagnant research
from lufthansa university commissioned
by independent age estimates that this
lack of take-up costs the treasury 4
billion pounds per year in increased nhs
and social care spending
and the other end of life's journey
before the pandemic 4.3 million children
were living in poverty in the uk
that was up 200 000 from the previous
year and up 500 000 over the past five
years according to action for children
that's 31
of children
if you're listening that's 31
of children
almost 60 of all children in poverty in
scotland live in a family where a child
is under six the scottish government has
reacted positively since august 2021 all
councils have been offered 1 140 hours
of funded early learning and child care
to all eligible children making high
quality early learning and chelsea
available to families and saving parents
up to 4
900 pounds per year for each eligible
child the smp are proud to be delivering
on manifesto promises the provision of
free school breakfast and lunches
all year round for all children and
primary one to seven digital services
for every poor child abolition of fees
for instrumental music music tuition and
removal of course curriculum charges
feeding their bellies and their minds
barbara crowther coordinator for
children food campaign said universal
free meals for primary schools could be
a valuable and cost effective lifeline
for families at a difficult economic
time
and what all those farmers are
struggling now and were struggling
before covered or the energy price
increases who do they turn to a few days
ago the chancellor tried to explain why
he couldn't adjust welfare he blamed the
computer system at its core and yet over
the last seven years whenever i have
questioned the suitability and the
flexibility of existing welfare system
i've always been told it's doing its job
it's just fine move along nothing to see
here but it clearly isn't and yet
possible solutions once again are
ignored dismissed as fanciful but never
fully investigated i know it's a concept
the uk government scorn but councils in
all four nations want to try all
universal basic income and only by
trials will be able to value its pros
and cons the uk government should not
fear the outcomes of these trials they
should be instructing dwp and hmrc to
work with the council authorities so we
can learn and improve based on solid
data and academic research not the
prejudice and misconceptions that beset
the current welfare system whatever must
be designed to provide security and
confidence not designed to punish and
stigmatize and the uk big idea to
resolve the disparity of rich and poor
is levelling up where the uk government
will point the leveling up as example
stimulus it begs the question if our
society is so equal why do we need
leveling up why are we not already level
unless you address those issues with
poverty and deprivation and the lack of
aspiration of life's wasted and
unfulfilled then everything else is
smoking mirrors
if all the stated goes out of any
kidneys they must be rooted in a fair
society with an equal access to
education health energy food and
transport when beverly wrote his report
to design a post-world war ii welfare
system for the united kingdom he said a
revolutionary moment in the world's
history is a time for revolutions not
for patching this is such a time as we
emerge from a worldwide pandemic and the
gig economy increases we need a
revolution in welfare in an increasingly
unequal society the uk government would
do well to listen now is the time for
big ideas and the queen's speech was
sadly lacking in any of those
david simmons
thank you madam deputy speaker
the queen's speech contains a wealth of
proposals which broadly fall between
those which are about how we best
support the vast majority of our people
for whom things like our state-funded
education state-funded healthcare are
important in their lives
but also those bills which are very much
about how we
support those and focus on those
who need the intervention of the state
in order to
thrive
and i'd like to
echo
the congratulations of my honourable
friend the member for harry east
in congratulating our colleagues the
re-elected leader of hillingdon
councillor ian edwards and the newly
elected leader of harrow council paul
osborne
because it is through local government
that we often see
the
vehicle through which the state supports
both the most vulnerable and also our
communities and that is going to be a
theme which i'm hoping to develop in my
brief contribution tonight
the first of those is in respect of the
school's bill and i would like to
commend ministers for the work that's
been done in particular
in the field of special educational
needs and disabilities i know the
minister has spent a lot of time
engaging with people across the sector
and it is clear to all of us that if we
are to make sure that every child has
the chance to thrive that a change is
urgently required and despite welcome
reforms that have been introduced into
the system it remains enormously
challenged another aspect of that
school's bill which begin to create a
more level playing field across
different types of schools will again
offer an opportunity to ensure that
state-funded education across the whole
of england does give every child the
best start in life there will be a
debate about that i would certainly
welcome in particular the fact that the
government has brought forward proposals
to enable local authorities to set up
multi-academy trusts as the research by
the local government
association shows based on research
previously done by organizations such as
watchted there remains a significant
maintained school advantage that local
authorities remain more effective than
academy trusts that improving the
attainment of schools that have been
struggling and we need to make sure that
we can harness that to the best
advantage of all of our communities
the
honourable member for romney and
chiselhurst made a comment about the
importance of the review of human rights
and i know as a member of the giant
committee on human rights i've had the
opportunity to hear a lot of
representations about that over the last
few months
it seems to me it's very important that
we get this right that we reflect the
need to update our human rights
legislation to take account for example
of the growing impact of the online
world on the way people live their lives
but similarly i would echo the concerns
about ensuring that we do not displace a
problem by sending cases to strasbourg
that we can more effectively deal
deal with at the uk level
and in respect of the development of our
economy in so many different aspects in
education in local government
in healthcare i think we need to
recognize that the trend for working
from home which has been very much
embraced by the most productive the most
efficient and profitable parts of our
economy that we recognize that in
respect to professional services in
particular we can help the money that we
spend
on taxpayer-funded services to go even
further by making sure that people who
can work from home most efficiently do
we're getting those who need to be in
the office providing frontline
face-to-face public services are there
where it is required
in respect of
social care it is important in this
house that we recognize that the local
authority that has the greatest
proportion of its residents accessing
some form of social care through the
whole journey of their lives
cut touches less than one in five of its
local residents
but those residents are often the people
who are most vulnerable and i know
ministers in the department of education
in particular have been looking at the
way in which we can review and improve
our children's social care system and
bring safeguarding updates to reflect
the challenges of the modern world but i
would urge ministers to look at both the
crocker review of private equity which
looks at the costs of providing children
social care and also i hope ministers
will find time to answer the call from
the children's commissioner that england
should follow wales and scotland in
abolishing the reasonable chastisement
defense uh in respect of uh the
discipline of children and finally
madame deputy speak in respect to
growing old i'd like to encourage the
government to look in all its endeavors
at a public health approach to aging
that we look at how local authorities
encourage activity such as walking
football bowls and swimming to keep our
older citizens active there is so much
potential to show our pride in our
communities and our ambition for them
and the public will find much of that on
these benches
thank you madam deputy speaker now on
these side of the benches we're hearing
about the cost of living crisis we're
hearing about it in the media from our
constituents on the news we're hearing
about it constantly
but somehow it feels like this is
falling on deaf ears because in the
government's queen speech this is
they've failed to address this and it is
with shock and horror that due to the
cost of living crisis 1.3 million people
in the uk are set to fall below the
poverty line next year
this includes 500 000 children who will
experience severe poverty now if we look
at this in more detail that will affect
children what children eat the quality
of their food and the size of their
portions maybe the frequency of it it
will affect their ability to be warm in
their home it could affect their
clothing and how much clothing is being
able to be purchased from as we've heard
from other members and it could affect
their health and we've already heard
from other members about obesity being
linked to poverty so there are lots of
areas where children are going to
experience deprivation and disadvantage
but it seems like the government is set
to be okay on this
now before the cost of living crisis um
was it even hit in lewisham 35
children were already in absolute
poverty this figure is rising and is
only set to increase further the
government must get a grip on the cost
of living so that our young children
will not suffer now there's something
about this where if children are
experiencing deprivation and
disadvantage and they're going to be in
severe poverty then actually some costs
only get passed on to another area so if
the government invested now they'll be
doing what's right now rather than
certain costs being passed on into the
health service to do with health issues
into the criminal justice system because
of the rise of poverty and poverty often
leads to an increase of crime into uh
children's social care because the
chances are there needs to be more
intervention from uh public services and
as we know the local authority is
already suffering so these costs are
being passed on so why isn't the
government making the choices
of investing now in people's lives
rather than being in the situation of
controlling people's lives it is vital
that we protect children and new parents
early years learning is essential to
ensure that children start have the best
possible start in life and the
government needs to get it right for all
children
now the government should aim for the
state education to be as good as grammar
schools and private schools each child
including 10 children should have an
equal chance to success just like any
other child the government clearly has a
long way to go to achieve this
now in addition to education older
children are perceived often
and managed by the police and the
criminal justice system
in a negative way and this can affect
their well-being and health and
currently many older children's
interaction with the justice system can
leave them traumatized and with a
negative experience of the police we
only need to look at child queue for
evidence of this and there are many
situations of stock and searching young
black men and women in london in
particular where we know that these
situations are detrimental to their
health and we only need to look at
bianca williams the commonwealth gold
medalist when she had that awful
experience of a roadside stop
now there are stories of children across
the uk being held up to 18 hours in a
police cell in custody this is
shockingly long and this should be a
shock for everybody who's hearing this
for the first time
current legislation requires that they
should only be detained as a last resort
for the shortest appropriate period and
this is clearly not happening
young people have described this
experience of being horrible and
devastating for them and i am standing
with vicky kemp a principal research
fellow specializing in the area at the
university of nottingham to press the
government to cut the statutory stay
limit for children from 24 hours to 12
hours so i really do hope the government
is listening to this according to a
report by the children's commissioner
the average waiting time also for an
appropriate adult is 9 hours
and my 15 year old constituent was
detained for nine hours before her
mother was even called to be informed
that he was in a police cell and again
i'm campaigning with the national
appropriate adult network to speed up
the attendance of appropriate adults to
come to young people's aid in the police
cell the government must make sure that
children are treated as children within
the care of public bodies and indeed in
the care of the police thank you
thank you madam deputy speaker and it's
a great privilege to be called to speak
in this debate and to follow the member
from lewisham east
making the uk the best place to grow up
and grow holt is an ambitious target but
we are definitely closer to it following
this year's queen's speech in my opinion
and in the opinion of a lot of people
who live in cornwall it already is but
there is still a huge amount to do
there's a lot of work going on in
cornwall uh we get we're we've secured a
new secondary school uh near perrin
porth on the north coast and we're
expecting a new women and children's
hospital to arrive at the trellis site
today i'd like to focus on the brilliant
work of the of the some of my
constituents in the turin farmer
constituency
last month i was delighted to welcome
the member for south northamptonshire to
falmouth to show to the farmer family
hub to show some of the best practice
of our excellent early years teams led
by meredith teasdale and councillor
barbara ellenbrook
cornwall is one of the 75 local
authorities to receive treasury funding
as part of a vital best start for life
program we began by visiting team
members from the wild the largest young
parents charity in the uk this
organization works with cornwall council
to ensure that young parents and their
babies have the best possible start to
family life we were lucky enough to see
messy play sensory play with bubbles
paint water foam that would make any
mother twitch and thank goodness they
have facilities to do that that's not in
my house
i know i speak for all parents in this
debate when i say that becoming a new
parent is incredibly challenging and
daunting and while for many people
becoming a parent means their hopes and
dreams have come true it's never easy
and a bit of extra support can go an
awful long way but for younger parents
and for those with no support network
this extra help is absolutely vital and
this is why the work of wild which has
supported more than
thousands mums dads and children over
the years is so important
for example their healthy start program
helps young parents transition into
becoming a new parent their infant
mental health project helps improve
mental health and the well-being of
babies and toddlers and their first
steps project focuses on those children
with the highest needs in line with the
early years foundation stage framework
these teams incredible work
along with cornwall council puts
cornwall on the map for for early years
work and i would urge the government to
consider cornwall to become a
trailblazer local authority where we
could ex where we could potentially
secure extra funds
to excel and share our best practices
with other localities
madam deputy speaker moving on to the
later stages of life i'd like to draw
the secretary of state and the
minister's attention to the hair project
the healthy aging through innovation in
rural europe project
this project does a brilliant job in
supporting rural communities with an
ever increasing aging population facing
significance to health and care
challenges and determining what services
really make a difference in ruralities
together myself working with fiat parish
council
one of only two in the united kingdom
their team has done brilliant work
locally to develop an environment in the
community that supports and encourages
older people to feel engaged and as part
of their locality and as we have heard
from the member of the thorac
we if you can live healthily in your own
home it is much better you get much
better health outcomes and speak from
speaking to the hair team it is clear
that more needs to be done to promote
healthy aging in rural communities and i
would like to briefly focus on the need
for the government to actually develop
varied and effective accommodation
potentially for elderly residents
it'll come as no surprise to everyone in
this chamber that housing is the number
one issue for my constituents in
cornwall
only 2.5 percent of the uk's 29 million
dwellings are defined as retirement
housing and the stock is heavily skewed
towards housing with three or four
bedrooms as the member for bosworth has
already touched on this the government
must increase the proportion of housing
stock for people of retirement age and
encourage those over 65 in properties
with surplus bedrooms to downsize those
who wish to that is um and so that
that'll allow younger families to upsize
to reduce the pressure on build to build
more houses
and therefore
using the solution easing the housing
crisis and improving health and
well-being for older residents and by
the way not all retired people want to
live in retirement villages with other
retired people only some people want to
live with families and children and see
play and see everyday life and what i'm
driving at here is we need the bills in
this queen's speech to promote what we
conservatives do best and that is look
after our communities cornwall
absolutely
shone the light during kobe to show what
communities can really really do and we
really need to learn from the good
practice here making the uk the best
place to grow up
and grow well is a challenging task and
i know this government will rise to it
and we can supporting the fastastics
local initiatives ensuring our housing
stock works for everyone will play
essential parts in achieving this goal
for all our families and for all of our
communities
cat smith
speaker and when i was thinking about
what to say in a debate on making
britain the best place to grow up and
grow old the first two constituents that
came to mind were lee and phillip lee
and philip were both born with fetal
valparai syndrome they will have a
lifelong need
for care and support and for their
parents it is a worry to think about
them growing up now they've already had
their childhood they're adults but
they're living with lifelong
disabilities and with the opportunity of
anger health minister on the treasury
bench i'm going to make the opportunity
to to make the case that for victims of
sodium valproate we do need a redress
scheme similar to that of those from
thalidomide to ensure that that lifelong
care is there and that the worry that
the parents of these children and young
adults now
are living with can be eased somewhat
um last week i visited beaumont college
in lancaster as well as lancaster and
morecambe college and the new youth club
in fleetwood and it was really great to
hear from those young people but it
strikes me that there is something
missing
from the queen's speech which is any
mention of youth work and the way in
which it can support our children in
education but also support our young
people growing up
at a recent q a session with pupils at
cardinal allen high school in fleetwood
the message was clear they wanted better
access to mental health support and
their teachers agreed
and they told me what we already know
which is that currently at cams the
waiting list is unacceptably long and
the threshold to meet their care is
unacceptably high
um the queen's speech confirmed that the
government planned to introduce a
school's bill these reforms come at a
crucial time for our education system
but having met with many local head
teachers they tell me that it fails to
deliver on the key challenges that our
schools are facing it's indifferent to
the issues of mental health and
well-being the school's bill doubles
down on the failures of the past setting
a new target for sacs performance that
will not raise the quality of education
the bill singles out student attendance
for attention whilst overlooking the
problems of mental health and the exam
factory culture that contributes to this
poorer attendance
but lancaster and fleetwood is a great
place to grow up because it's a great
place to learn and i'm fortunate enough
to have two brilliant universities in my
constituency
lancaster university and the university
of cumbria and i had the pleasure to
meet with students and researchers at
lancaster university who are pioneering
research across diverse areas from flood
defenses to a better understanding of
alzheimer's and given that 18 000 people
currently living with dementia in
lancashire it's certainly something that
helps to bridge what can sometimes be a
gap between the town and the gal in our
community
but with the higher education bill we
would see restrictions on who has access
to this brilliant education on the basis
of gcses
and to those who say that too many young
people are going to university nowadays
i ask how can it be a bad thing that
people are getting more education
education enriches the lives of the
individuals we see but also the
communities that they live in and that
changes lives for the better
lancaster in floyd is a great place to
grow up because it is a great place to
work my constituency is full of
brilliant local businesses from small
independent retailers to international
businesses like fisherman's friends but
the reality for many in rural
communities is that they feel
disconnected from these work
opportunities the queen's speech
promises a transport bill that will take
control of the railway system and my
question on railways is simple
and we've been campaigning hard to get
our railway reopened in fleetwood it's
been promised to us around two years ago
and what's happening where is it will
this bill reconnect fleetwood to the
rail network or is this something else
which has become derailed by this
government
but we shouldn't lose sight of the
importance of local bus networks too for
many of my constituents it might be a
question of traveling from dolphin home
into lancaster from classroom dock into
goalgate and those rural bus networks
have suffered huge cuts and my
constituents
feel disconnected from access to jobs
but also access to social and family
events too
lancaster and fleetwood is a great place
to grow old because
people of every age and every stage in
their life are embraced as part of our
community from the parent and toddler
group at lancaster methodist church to
the wire wheels project on every friday
in the memorial park in fleetwood
supporting anyone even me of any ability
to get on a bike and cycle it's a
resourceful community and it's certainly
a compassionate one and but in the last
few weeks i've received so many emails
from constituents concerned about the
rising costs their bills and the fact
that pensions are not keeping up with
these costs my rural constituents
especially those on oil-powered heating
have been left out of any government
support when it comes to heating so can
i implore to the treasury bench the
importance to remember everyone and in
every community right across britain and
ensure that britain really is the best
place to grow up and grow old
moore thank you madam deputy speaker
since the last queen's speech southport
has begun the process of seismic change
with our 37.5 million pound town deal
being met with hundreds of millions in
pledge private funding the town deal
will ultimately help create over 1300
jobs and bring over a million extra
visitors a year from the individual
small businesses springing up along our
high street to the largest south port
cove and marine lake event center
developments our wonderful town which
i'm proud to call my home is rightly
seeing the benefits of the government's
leveling up agenda it is important that
local communities have a say over change
in their area and so i welcome the
leveling up and regeneration bill which
offers a real opportunity to address the
housing shortage
while this bill will also further
devolution of powers over local services
to local elected leaders i urge you to
go further and bring in a mechanism to
allow a community to more easily change
its local authority catchment area in
southport we've been repeatedly held
back by the vindictive actions of labour
led sefton council who take away
resources from southport and ignore
local concerns for example over unwanted
unnecessary and unwelcome cycle lanes
furthermore as the minister for children
knows we found in the days conveniently
after the election sefton council's
children's services have been rated
inadequate by ofsted in all areas yet
the responsible councillors shamelessly
remain in office and southport's
vulnerable children continue to suffer
these children deserve excellent quality
services from their local council just
as they deserve excellent quality
healthcare from their local nhs
such healthcare is crucial throughout
life and while i welcome the
government's commitment to clear the
backlog from covid we must aim for more
than simply returning to a place where
we were before the pandemic hit and
restrictions came into force and as my
other honourable friend the minister for
health knows southport hospital has been
lacking children's e a a since 2003 with
services rolled into armed care hospital
yet over covered ornskirk's children a
he has ceased being 24 hours
with the result a child that falls sick
out of those hours must now travel to
liverpool first we will see the
resumption of the 24 7 service in
ormskirk and then most importantly we
must see the return of this service to
southport madam deputy speaker we must
ensure that everyone across this country
from the first day they are born is
given the support they deserve we must
ensure the children are given the best
possible start we must ensure that the
uk remains the best place to grow up
education is crucial to allowing people
to prosper and succeed especially as we
build back better from covid so i
welcome that the school's bill will
strengthen our education system while
labour-led section council are content
with failing help to children this
conservative government will bring
through this schools bill level up
opportunity support children across this
country but we are not stopping there as
the higher education bill will raise
education standards and increase
fairness within the system allowing
students to fulfill their potential
wherever they live southport greatly
benefits by well-qualified graduates
when they return to our town as their
innovative drive and passion for local
progress is crucial to our success
for example southport's hospitality
developments look no need no look no
further than southport college where
under the fantastic leadership of
michelle brabner students are well
supported in finding skilled well-paid
work locally
finally madam deputy speaker all of this
relies on strong transport links we need
the bursco curves railing to reopen
which would enable stronger connectivity
not only locally within the region but
as far afield as scotland and the south
of england we need to maintain the
direct link from southport to manchester
piccadilly which is crucial for jobs
businesses and leisure so i'm optimistic
that the transport bill will succeed in
stated aim of making our transport
system more reliable and efficient for
passengers but i'm deputy speaker this
queen's speech brings welcome
legislation to particularly my
constituency of southport and i look
forward to supporting this government as
we continue to level up our local areas
support our children and connect our
communities
hi williams
thank you madam deputy speaker it's a
pleasure to follow the honourable
gentleman who's clearly a passionate uh
supporter of southwest and uh
congratulations to him i'm sure he will
do well in today's conservative policy
um
this queen speech fails to address the
immediate cost of living crisis and
there's little
uh to end longer-term issues of growing
poverty and inequality in wales as in
the uk
that is the context of this debate
and the cause of the hollow laughter at
its title making britain the best way to
grow up and grow old
in wales we have high levels of poverty
and have had them for decades
particularly since the destruction of
our heavy industries by the conservative
governments of the 1980s
that is why in fact we qualified for eu
supports
on a par with the former soviet bloc
countries of the east
that is until we were blessed with
brexit opportunities when that supports
diminished
our levels of child poverty in wales are
the highest in the uk
affecting a third of our children as
measured in 2019
and as the children's commissioner for
wales
said over the weekend that's rate is now
more likely to be around 40 percent
this persistence poverty as consequences
for children's development including
damaging their mental health
and these carry on
on to adulthood and at that point if the
website listening i would like to
congratulate the governments for
uh intending to bring in a mental health
bill and as a former social worker
approved into the mental health act i
would be very glad of the opportunity to
contribute to the scrutiny of that bill
now poverty does indeed carry on down
the generations
but not as some would have it as
something inherently bad or morally
reprehensible about working people
it is policy that damages lives and it
is poverty that kills
the cost of living crisis is having a
devastating impact on children all over
wales and elsewhere in the uk
and families indeed are being forced
to choose between eating and heating
wales has the highest rates of food bank
use in the uk with over four thousand
food parcels distributed per hundred
thousand people per annum
people are turning to food banks as they
have no other choice
now the cuts to universal credits of 20
pounds per week which took away
286 million pounds from the welsh
economy
wasn't a disaster for children in
low-income families
and as to adults in wales
one in three people of working age and
almost one in five pensioners
die
in poverty
it is the highest rates in the uk this
disgraceful victorian value must be
banished for good
smoking is the largest single cause of
avoidable early death in wales and pride
companies supports the introduction of a
polluter page levy onto my tobacco
manufacturers today's
funds for tobacco control to ensure our
smoke-free ambition for wales is indeed
met
but the real game changer for wales
would be the evolution of social
security
so that we can build a system of
supports which meets our particular
needs
control over the administration of
benefits would create some more flexible
approach at the time found families need
it most
for example
paying universal credits weekly
reflecting the way that poor people
actually have to budget
and changing the current degrading
sanctions regime
welfare support could be delivered to
meet the actual needs of people in wales
with winter fuel payments linked to home
energy efficiency
cold weather payments could be improved
to take into account morality which has
particular effects
on people in the uplands of my own
constituency of arvon
and the evolution would enable us to
create new ways of helping to top up
existing benefits we implied kimberly
believe
our senate should create the welsh child
payments similar to that in scotland and
much much more
very briefly
thank you for giving way and of course
one of the difficulties with the
benefits that have been
developed to scottish government is that
we only have a very small amount we've
only got about 15 percent of benefits
involved with what he's talking about
obviously you need all benefits to
evolve so it could be properly ministry
well i share the ambition of the older
lady and the friends to have a proper
social security system which is tailored
to the needs of our particular
communities and the scottish government
is certainly leading the way as far as
i'm concerned and we will be emulating
some of the measures that they have be
bought in when we have that power
uh madam deputy speaker wales comes way
down the priority list
of this conservative governments their
eyes are glued both on their vulnerable
red wall seats
and their increasingly unhappy homelands
in the south and east of england
but like they advocates the bold
policies for everyone
which will actually make wales a good
place to grow old and to grow up thank
you
thank you
speaker
the pandemic has been particularly
difficult for young people research by
the education policy institute has shown
that despite the best efforts of
teachers over the last two years pupils
have lost the equivalent of over four
months of learning with those in the
north and midlands most affected there
is a real danger that covert will end up
exacerbating long-standing inequalities
and according to the latest austere
inspection reports only 55
of derbyshire secondary schools are
rated good or better compared with the
national benchmark of 80
this inequality opportunity simply isn't
good enough we must do better in high
peak we are making progress with some
philip catholic voluntary academy and
glossop being upgraded to good in its
latest offset inspection compared to its
2018 rating of requires improvement
we've also seen capital funding that
we've secured to invest in hope valley
college funding to expand harper hill
primary in buxton and the four million
four million pound expansion of
gloucesterdale school is under
construction due to create an extra 240
places for the town during september
but more can and must be done so i
welcome that the government has
designated derbyshire as one of the new
education investment areas which means
derbyshire schools will receive much
needed extra support with additional
money for recruitment and retention for
the best teachers and the queen's speech
aims to build on this progress with the
new school schools bill to help drive up
standards
madam deputy speaker our schools aren't
the only public service challenged by
the pandemic the nhs is still grappling
with a huge covert backlog a good
example is a withdrawal of the mobile
breast cancer screening unit in high
peak back in 2020 i fought hard to get
this vital service reinstated and i'm
pleased to report to the house that the
mobile unit is back up and running
locally operating at 160
of pre-pandemic levels but we must do
more than simply restore existing
services if we're to build a more
resilient preventative health service
and that's why i'm pushing so hard for
new urgent care centres for both
stepping hill hospital and homeside
hospital
it's also why i'm supporting derbyshire
community health services bid for
capital funding for a major new health
center for buxton of course
not all illnesses are visible as we
rebuild from the pandemic we must
deliver parity between mental and
physical health services and the
proposed mental health act reform bill
will play a key role in this mission
giving patients greater control over
their treatment ensuring that they
receive a more personalized level of
care i recently visited the construction
site of the 4.8 million pound highly
specialist mental health unit that is
being built at tameside hospital this
will replace the existing psychiatric
intensive care unit stepping hill
providing short-term care for men over
age 18 experiencing mental health
distress and once that new unit is built
at tameside
the current psychiatric intensive care
unit at stepping hill will be
refurbished to create a new unit
specifically for women and this is
particularly good news given this
service is not currently available
anywhere locally so it'll allow women to
receive specialist mental health care
closer to their homes and loved ones our
turning to social care and pleased that
this government have finally grasped the
nettle and introduce reforms to try and
ensure that nobody will have to sell
their home to pay for care in future and
while these reforms are welcome we
really do need to get on with delivery
and fleshing out the details of the
improvement plans of course tackling any
of these challenges is only possible if
we have strong public finances to pay
for world-class public services we need
and that requires a strong and growing
economy and as we all know we're facing
global rising energy prices a war in
europe and we're still dealing with the
enormous supply chain disruption caused
by covid all of which are driving high
inflation and the rising cost of living
the government's long-term reform plans
are the right ones investing in
infrastructure skills and public service
reform to create sustainable growth and
well-paid high-skilled jobs but we do
need to think very carefully about what
more can be done in the short term to
help people cope with soaring costs now
there are no magic solutions and those
members who pretend otherwise are
deluding themselves and the people they
represent that doesn't mean that we
can't do more
we need honesty creativity pragmatism
and compassion to deal with the
challenges ahead and if we work together
i'm confident we'll succeed i'm glad
that the queen's speech put forward a
whole series of practical measures to
make britain the best place to grow up
and grow up
helen hayes thank you brother deputy
speaker this gracious gracious speech
should have been the opportunity for the
government to rise to the unprecedented
set of challenges facing our country and
in doing so to make britain the best
place both to grow up and to grow old
the lack of ambition and the stony
silence of the speech on some of the
biggest challenges facing the uk speaks
volumes about a government which is out
of touch and out of ideas
worse than that many of the challenges
we need to address are a direct
consequence of 12 years of tory
government
12 years in which instead of stepping up
with ambition for our country this
government has run down our public
services undermined our economy
negotiated a disastrous exit from the
european union admired itself further
and further in defending the
indefensible current occupant of number
10 downing street
our country was left lacking resilience
both when the kobit 19 pandemic struck
and as global factors have brought
pressure to bear on the cost of living
the government can't always prevent
international shocks to our economy but
it has a primary duty to make sure that
we are as resilient as possible when
they come and in that duty this
government has failed the uk cannot be
the best place in which to grow up or
grow old while households across the
country are struggling to make ends meet
while parents wake up in the morning and
go to bed at night worrying about how
they will feed their children and keep a
roof over their head and when pensioners
worry about whether they will be able to
eat and keep warm
as i knock on doors in my constituency
i've been really shocked in recent
months to see the increasing numbers of
older people who come to the door
wearing a coat on cold days
it is shameful that this is happening in
britain in the 21st century
the queen's speech includes new bills to
reform the regulation of social housing
and private renting this legislation is
long overdue
next month we'll see the fifth
anniversary of the horrific rainfall
tower fire and tenants still cannot have
confidence that changes have been made
which will protect them
on the private rented sector i have been
calling for an end to section 21
evictions for the past six years and it
is very hard to understand what has
taken the government so long
but alongside some overdue reforms it is
also clear that this government has
given up on the large-scale delivery of
social housing which is urgently needed
to address the housing crisis
the uk cannot be the best place to grow
up while children are condemned to live
in poor quality private rented
accommodation which their parents can
barely afford to rent or to heat
i hope the government will consider
accepting an amendment to the social
housing regulation bill along the lines
proposed in my recent 10-minute rule
bill which i called georgia's law
georgia's law recognizes the devastating
impact that a threat of gang violence
can have on family life when a young
person is threatened and their family
has to move they can lose all of their
stability
being placed in temporary accommodation
and ending up on a waiting list for
years for a new social housing tenancy
that is what happened to my constituent
georgia with catastrophic consequences
for her family
georgia's law would place new duties on
social housing providers to protect the
tenancy of a tenant whose family is
threatened with violence
helping to limit the harm of gang
violence in our communities it has
cross-party support and it would make a
huge difference
madame deputy speaker as a co-chair of
the appg on adult social care i want to
say how utterly unacceptable it is that
this gracious speech contains no mention
of adult social care the government has
introduced an unfair and unaffordable
tax hike which it justified in terms of
the urgent need to provide additional
funding for social care
funding for the nhs is of course welcome
though there are far fairer ways to
raise it but the social care sector
which was ignored and neglected and even
blamed by the government during the
kovit-19 pandemic and faces a workforce
crisis and a funding crisis will not
receive any funding for at least three
years
the uk cannot possibly be the best place
to grow old while across the country
people fear losing their homes to pay
for their care and the workforce tasked
with caring for our loved ones is burnt
out with staff leaving in their droves
to work in retail and distribution
because the pay is better so i asked the
government where is the ambition where
is the empathy and insight into the real
and intolerable pressures our
communities face and where are the
solutions we so desperately need to the
problems they have created
james wilde thank you very much madame
deputy speaker it's a pleasure to be
called in this debate to support the
measures in the queen's speech focus on
that core conservative value of
opportunity and of course education is
key to giving people the best chance to
make the most of their talents and for
britain to be the best place to grow up
that's why one of my priorities since
being elected has been visiting schools
across my constituency to hear directly
from teachers from teaching assistants
and peoples about the challenges
involved in improving literacy and adult
and numeracy standards which are
fundamental to young people going on to
succeed so i welcome the school's bill
which sets the ambition to have 90
of children achieving expected standards
in reading writing and maths up from 65
percent in the most recent year that
sats took place and it's all very well
setting targets there needs to be a plan
to achieve them and much will rest on
the new parent pledge which means that
any child that falls behind in english
or mass should receive additional
tailored support
and the best schools already do this and
by sharing evidence on what works more
children can now get the support they
need and their parents will be more
closely involved in their child's
progress
and one of the issues most frequently
raised during visits to schools is
access to speech and language therapy as
others have referred to spoken language
underpins literacy development is key to
learning across the curriculum including
for maths
and the royal college of speech and
language therapists highlights evidence
from the education endowment foundation
that teaching with emphasis on spoken
language enables an average of six
months additional economic progress over
the course of the year
so i welcome the reassurance that my
annual friend the secretary of state for
education gave me when the send paper
was published that the parent pledge
should ensure that children who need
help with language and communication are
supported
and one of the calls that the royal
college and other language organizations
make which i support is to ensure that
the national professional qualifications
in literacy special educational needs
and early years include a focus on
developing and supporting spoken
language skills
but as we learn to live with kobed the
specific art from a recent visit to
churchill park academy in kingsley which
serves young people with special needs
is for tests to be made available to
such schools they have particularly
vulnerable peoples who are not currently
attending school due to concerns about
covid prevalence i'd be grateful if
education and health ministers could
carefully consider that request
now madam deputy speaker the focus of
this debate
of making britain the best place to grow
up and grow old also includes access to
health care it all comes as no surprise
to ministers that i return to an issue i
raised in my maiden speech in the first
queen speech debate in his house and
indeed in last year's queen's speech and
on many other occasions namely the
pressing need for a new hospital for the
queen elizabeth in king's lynn
qh is now more than a decade beyond its
planned 30-year lifestyle
and due to the rack concrete planks it
now has 1500 timber and steel supports
holding up the cracking roof
it is the most propped hospital in the
country and that number is likely to
increase as further fail-safe work is
completed
due to this concrete cancer the trust
risk register has a red rating for
direct risk to life to the safety of
patients visitors and staff due to the
potentially catastrophic risk of failure
of the roof structure
last month some of my constituents once
again came to westminster to talk about
the need for qh to be one of the
additional eight new hostel schemes the
government's committed to building
and a major issue they asked me to
highlight is just how bad an experience
being an award surrounded by props
holding up the roof it's for patients
the staff at the hospital stressed how
it makes it harder for them to do the
job to provide the care the patients
need
and i warmly welcome the funding from
the dh
for a new endoscopy unit in new west
norfolk eye centre which opened last
week at qbh but now is the time to make
a decision to build a new hospital for
the 300 000 people across norfolk
lincolnshire and cambridgeshire the qeh
serves and this isn't about having shiny
new buildings for their own sake it's
about better health outcomes in some of
the most deprived areas in the country
that the government has recognized as
priority for leveling up
by committing to this vitally needed
hospital the inevitable requirement for
replacement will become part of a funded
program
rather than unplanned demand on the
treasury requiring emergency funding
that is better value for money for
taxpayers and will deliver the
improvements people in northwest norfolk
and beyond deserve so i hope my rival
friend the health secretary has good
news for my constituents soon as they
are rightly frustrated for the delay in
this decision
very much
speaker it's honored to speak in this
very important debate
under this government living standards
have plummeted to 1950s levels and life
expectancy is falling oneness figures
show that inequality gap in the least
deprived area is growing even wider
almost one in three children in britain
live in poverty
britain is in decline under this tory
government
despite all of this the government
have the termity to talk about
leveling up they can put the phrase at
the front of
the at the front and center of their
rhetoric but i saw nothing in the
queen's speech that will actually
deliver it
nothing the prime minister has announced
in his legislative agenda will address
living standards or the cost of living
crisis help people pay for child care or
meet the unmet care needs of over a
million older people
his announcement won't bridge the gap
between what people earn against
spoiling in
inflation tax rises and fuel surges
to achieve a stronger economy
make this country fairer make our
streets safer fund the nhs properly and
improve schooling and higher education
we would need to reverse the
failed policies of the successive tory
governments of last 12 years
as i listened to the chancellor
spring statement in march
i thought of my constituent and his
disabled partner who is unable to work
he currently attends college to improve
his skills but earns well below the
average wage
leaving for them
has meant relying on candles
for hitting and lighting and they are
not allowed it is cruel snapshot of
today's britain for many people workers
pensioners and families and children
under the tories our i want britain to
be the best place to grow up in
and grow old in but a baby growing it up
in
today's britain today
under the story government will have
it harder than their grandparents
the queen's speech does not go far
enough to address long-term problems
facing children and young people
throughout the uk
such as the frightening numbers of
children and young people waiting for
mental health support
the leveling up white paper does
not include clear measures to tackle
child poverty or children's health
inequalities
and where is the legislation to improve
support for our most vulnerable children
those in care care leavers and unpaid
carers disabled young people can't reach
their full potential while they cannot
access the health care and other
services they have a right to like
respite care therapies and specialist
education
the life-changing opportunities
available a generation ago to go to
university is being steadily eroded by
this government the marketization of
higher education is a tragedy and is
hollowing out the sector that was once
envy of the world
students who go to university are
settled with crippling debt
it's off-putting for so many coming from
homes where household budgets are tight
every child should have equal access to
the education training and
training they desire not to have
obstacles and the specter of debt put in
their way to be persuaded university is
not for the likes of them and talking of
token
of children's future the queen's speech
totally failed to deliver the urgent
action required in response to the
climate and nature emergencies we
desperately needed the government to
tackle the root cause of our energy and
climate security problems and bring in
the legislation to speed up the
transition from fossil fuels to
renewables
generations are being let down by a
government too short-sighted to plan for
a more
hopeful future but instead focus focuses
their attention on themselves and how to
keep the prime minister in office for
another day the government have no new
ideas no real plans to fix their broken
britain and to build a better future for
all cradle to grave
thank you
gary sandberg thank you very much madam
deputy speaker as we know the
title for today's debate is making
britain the best place to grow up and
grow old and with that in view i'd like
to be the first member of this house to
congratulate jake daniels for coming out
today as the first active footballer in
uk professional football um it really
does make the uk an even better place to
live and to grow older and for many
people like me that grew up in a world
where we looked for role models jay can
be very proud of the role that he will
be playing as a role model um for future
generations
and it is in that vein too i welcome the
um the government's commitment to
conversion therapy in the queen's speech
uh banning conversion therapy in the
queen's speech and i would gently push
um the treasury front bench to remember
that we in our original promise did
include trans people and we should
include all lgbt people in that
conversion therapy ban
moving on to education madam deputy
speaker
across my constituency i'm pleased that
now 82 percent of young people are in
schools which are good and outstanding
or outstanding and i'm always amazed
when i visit so many of my local schools
especially um balunwood and king edward
vi
norfield school for girls which used to
be called turf screen girl school and
turf screen boys school and also
colema's fun primary and hawksy academy
at the dedication and commitment of so
many of their teachers and the young
people who have so much commitment to
learning and also man deputy speaker i'm
really pleased that the edge academy has
been shortlisted for an award for the
support that they give their young
peoples uh in that school right at the
heart of northfield
we are all very much concerned
by
education because of the benefits that
it gives our young people and giving
them the skills that they need for the
future and when we move to higher
education i'm glad that there's measures
within
this queen's speech doing uh to improve
higher education and when i meet with
julia stevens from the cadbury college
pleased with the new investment they've
got in the north block and also their
new uh labs um and the commitment that
she has to lifelong learning and also
principal mike hopkins from south and
city college and the work that they're
doing there and i was pleased to open
the electric car center only a couple of
months ago the commitment that college
is making ensuring that young people
have the skills of the future and and
then fall growing older and people in
the constituency of northfield where we
have two extra care retirement villages
one in bourneville and one in longbridge
which are an amazing example of what we
can do when we are creative about
housing
and the many many activities and things
that people can do in those retirement
villages living together in a community
which i like to refer to as like static
cruise ships which are amazing places to
visit
i if only when as soon as i hit the age
of 55 would love to put my name on the
waiting list for one of these extra care
retirement villages and i always think
as members of parliament we should lead
from the front which is why i was keen
to join so many in the conga line at the
umpa band nightly of the week at the
bourneville village uh
retirement village uh which was joined
by so many local people and these really
are places for the future where we can
encourage so many people to move into as
they grow older
moving briefly to social housing
i was born on a cancer state in
birmingham which was one of the largest
cancer estates in europe
when it was built and often uh through
my casework of which now over twenty
thousand uh items of casework have been
done by my brilliant team assisting me
in the constituency many of those are
often in reference to housing and
housing repairs and i'm glad that the
social housing regulation bill will be
in here making sure that we increase the
standards of houses that people are
living in in social housing and also
expanding even further tenant rights to
people in the private rented sector and
we do need to build more houses in the
right places and in consultation with
local people and it's unfortunate and
when we have big projects in birmingham
like what was supposed to be the
athletes village which won't be housing
any athletes unfortunately after the
commonwealth games or during it now but
when we have a local authority that
demands certain levels of social housing
on private companies falls really short
of what the expectation they hope for
other people to have with the last count
only being four percent of the thousands
of houses being built on that scheme so
we need to do more to make sure that the
22 000 people who are currently on the
waiting list have the opportunity um to
get onto the housing
ladder and into social housing man
deputy speaker and we're only ten
seconds left i like to think from my
near five hours of bobbing i've paid
some part in my ambition towards the
government's obesity strategy
ms cadbury thank you madam
speaker and it's a pleasure and an inter
interesting to follow the
member for birmingham north fields
because i would like to point out that
that birmingham bourneville village
retirement village would not be possible
had it not been for the endowment of the
bourneville village trust something set
up before the welfare state by my
forbearers that enabled the uh costs of
the land etc to not have to be covered
if we most areas in this country do not
have that asset which is why those that
provision needs to be supported by
governments
madam deputy speaker if the government
really wants to make britain the best
place to grow up in and provide those
opportunities referred to by the
secretary of state for education it's
got to do far more than the thing rule
dished up by the queen's speech last
week and i'm not sure that many of my
constituents at school college or
university can see much to celebrate in
the queen's speech schools in labour-led
hounslow are all good or extend
outstanding but that's a challenge after
a lost decade of underfunding 17 million
in our borough schools alone or 500
pounds per pupil parents and teachers
are trying to fill this gap from their
own pockets money that fewer can afford
to do as the cost of living bites ever
deeper and now we read that there's a
risk to life because of the disrepair to
too many school buildings something that
can't be fixed from the school fates
income
school buildings need a properly funded
commitment from government as the as the
labour government did in this building
schools for the future program a madam
deputy speaker on covet catch-up funding
the government ignored the
recommendations of sir kevin collins who
they appointed he said that 15 billion
need to be spent
but he but the government agreed a
fraction of what was needed labour's
children's recovery plan
would fund significant and targeted
extra investment to our young people who
missed out most during the lockdowns
and madam deputy speaker teachers morale
has to be addressed teaching is already
challenging over the last decade a lot
over the last decade they've had to take
on more responsibilities as staffing
levels are cut to respond to the annual
budget round and yet more
central government edicts then during
the pandemic teachers and school heads
who were at the front line told me they
felt let down and ignored by this
government announcements made on the
spur of the moment with the government
lurching from one fiasco to another
welfare
and at the same time welfare and mental
health and special needs support is
still being cut despite warm words from
this government
teachers and school staff were were on
the front line but left behind by this
government and it's not no surprise that
seven out of ten teachers have
considered resigning
from the profession in the last year the
government need to wake up to the huge
amount of anger and distrust they've
created among school staff a madam
deputy speaker investing in school staff
and school buildings means you invest in
children's learning and development in
their future
labour have a funded plan
to invest in school staff to enable all
teachers and leadership teams to
continue to access continued
professional development
now on students who've all be have been
all but ignored uh by this government
practically the only time we see
ministers talking about universities or
students is when they want to create a
distraction or a row so maybe if the
government talked to students in higher
education staff and actually listened
they'd know that students already
struggling with the cost of living rises
in rents in energy bills and food many
students in my constituency tell me they
have to work full-time in order to fund
themselves through university supposedly
full-time courses and i've heard from 16
and 17 year olds who are terrified they
won't be able to go to university
because of the costs so much for social
mobility
in conclusion madam deputy speaker this
queen's speech is the proof that after
12 years in power this government have
no ambition or determination to fix the
problems in the education system that
they've created
on school funding we see our computer
says no from the chancellor there's no
plan to support school staff and
leadership teams with adequate pay or
proper mental health support and
certainly
little sign of a coherent and evident
schools policy no plan to support
students just a carefully hidden rise in
student loan interest payments in the
last budget and i've said earlier
nothing for muslim students who can't
who aren't able to take out the student
loans labor would take a different path
a better path families in my
constituency would have a government
that was on their side with a plan to
tackle the cost of living priceless
crisis with a windfall tax on oil and
gas producers a government with an
ambitious camp catch-up plan for
education as described by my honorable
friend for houghton and uh sunderland
that's how we will make britain the best
best place to grow up in here
thank you madam deputy speaker and it's
a pleasure to follow my co-chair of the
cycling and walking appg where we so
often agree whereas tonight we probably
will not so whilst we're looking to make
britain the best place to grow up and
grow old i am delighted to represent the
beautiful constituency of north devon
which is certainly one of the most
popular places to grow up and grow old
having had a surge of people move there
during the pandemic for their primary
residence and their second home we're
also an incredibly popular holiday
destination which has led to a surge in
airbnb short-term holiday lets which
whilst great for our tourism economy
does mean that we have something of a
housing crisis ourselves in north devon
so whilst warmly welcoming the leveling
up and regeneration bill i very much
hope as it makes its passage through
this house that we will see more done to
tackle second homes and short-term
holiday lets to rebalance our housing
economy back in north devon and whilst i
have the opportunity to put it on the
record i also hope that the long-awaited
consultation into short-term holiday
lets promised last june as part of the
tourism recovery strategy will be
forthcoming as a first step on that
journey to sort our housing market
i was a former maths teacher and so i
have spent time here before talking
about averages and variation and when it
comes to education and the school spill
i very much hope that we will look
deeper than the average that says that
devon is okay because when you look at
the variance in a county the size of
devon there are some issues in my north
devon constituency say we were to look
at the social mobility index south hands
49 out of 324 exeter 81
my north devon constituency 238
my neighbouring torrid northern devon as
we call it up there 283
we need to look deeper than just a large
local authority to enable those children
to have their education leveled up
because today we've missed out on cold
spot funding and whilst delighted to
welcome multiply i don't know quite how
that will be delivered in my
constituency where we only have one fe
college we're 65 miles from a university
my fe college petrol are utterly
brilliant but please don't tell me that
this is going to be coming in online as
a course because what we don't have in
north devon is broadband and whilst
we're talking um in these bills about
the elimination of the barrier of
digital exclusion when i talk about
digital exclusion it's not so much what
gadgets the children have is that we
can't even connect to the outside world
the inequalities i talk about when i
think about leveling up are around rural
and coastal communities and i my theme
throughout my few minutes speaking
tonight is how do we ensure that as we
level up the country we actually reach
into those pockets of deprivation in
rural and coastal britain
health inequalities on the coast are
perhaps better documented than
educational ones
but i would like to sing the praises of
my tiny north devon district hospital
the smallest on the mainland and it has
done a fantastic job for the people of
north devon through the pandemic we've
also seen it merge with the royal exeter
trust which means that we're actually
managing the flow of patients and the
flow of medical professionals between
that tiny hospital and the bigger one
further south
in devon we retained our nightingale
hospital and i'm terribly proud that we
will be the first to deliver our covered
catch-up fund ward so on may the 23rd of
this month the 1.9 million given to my
hospital in december will deliver
operations and orthopedic knees and hip
replacement in just two weeks time it's
a remarkable achievement and that team
is also ready to build our new hospital
we're one of the 40 their plans are
modular and i would ask while i have the
minister's attention tonight is there
any chance of bringing us forward we're
at the end but we can build it now and
without those new theaters and the new
housing element of that hospital we are
struggling to bring people to north
devon because of the housing crisis
described earlier
and i wouldn't want to say that
everything health-wise was rosy it won't
come as a surprise to the minister for
me to mention we're a little short of
dentists and if any of them are
listening tonight the surf's fantastic
the countryside's beautiful and you will
get the warmest of welcomes i hear the
indians have a lot of dentists looking
for work we will welcome them open arms
and this is a department that has
managed to deliver things in buses
please can we have a mobile dental unit
to at least visit our children in the
coming weeks and months and so as we
look at how we level up rural and
coastal britain i hope we can morality
check our policies because many of those
that work so well in westminster have
lost a certain je ne sais quoi by the
time they reach us in rural and coastal
north devon thank you yes
daniel's psyche
speaker um
it's right that when the government
brings forward its program that the
opposition criticizes slightly
surprising the government makes it so
easy for us quite frankly because when
the world is quite obviously struggling
the country's struggling with rising
prices with a climate emergency there
are obvious measures that any government
should be taking whether it is the
windfall tax whether it's insulating our
homes and the question i find myself
asking is why on earth does the
government not do any of these things so
it's a rag bag of bills we have before
us here i'll comment on a few of them
one has been mentioned once or twice the
data bill i was on the bill committee
that introduced gdpr a couple of years
ago and that time from this side of the
house we made it very clear the
government needed to be much more
ambitious and forward-looking i would
just caution though that if we go a
different way from many of our
neighbours think hard about what that
means for our businesses and our
research institutions uh it's a coded
message but just be aware
what that might bring if we don't do
that in the right kind of way on
education the one thing it does seem to
me to link most of these bills is the
fact they rather miss the point and
looking at schools what i hear from my
schools is there is a real problem with
the very young children coming in that
who have been through the pandemic and
they need the extra help and the
catch-up that other colleagues have
talked about i couldn't help noticing
also the reference to a family of
schools we used to have a family of
schools they were within the local
authority now of course we have
predatory multi-academy trusts looking
to circle on our schools and take them
over and that's no way to get the kind
of cooperation that we need similarly
with the higher education bill as we
look at that um frankly um the lifelong
learning entitlement i think is loan
entitlement is largely welcomed but it's
very little detail at the moment i think
many worry about quite how this will be
introduced and what they will be asked
to do
and i have to say that the issues for
universities
are much more pressing than some of the
things that the government's been coming
forward on particularly the future of
our collaborative funding with other
parts of the world in the horizon europe
program
we need certainty on that um a huge
amount hangs on this uh secretary of
state
i'm sure knows this it's linked to other
things but those are the issues that
really were in universities the young
people in my city in cambridge it's
absolutely about housing and the fact
that the secretary of state effectively
gave up on the housing targets last week
does not exactly engender confidence in
where this government is going on that
um as some of my colleagues have said
that um my honourable friend member for
dulles and west nord spoke passionately
about the issues facing renters a huge
set of issues in my city and yes section
21 will be welcomed but it's been long
promised and we need much more than that
but to switch to the nhs for a moment
for people are getting old frankly what
a state we are in in this country now um
i listened again to one of my colleagues
um
my own little friend member for bradford
south and my friend from ellesmere port
erneston talking about dentistry the
minister's here i never imagined would
have a situation where we'd
reach the state where people can no
longer get help when they're in acute
pain and that is what's happening all
over the country and in my city too
and in terms of ambulance weights again
we've reached a situation where people
are paying for the national health
service they can no longer rely on it i
was speaking to a paramedic over the
weekend who works the east of england
ambulance trust these people are working
flat out
but she was haunted by the fact
that someone she went
to serve and to help an elderly person
who'd been waiting 18 hours and as a
consequence that weight she died that's
what's happening in this country now
that's what's happening
lives are being lost where's the urgency
the secretary of state led on the virus
we should have the same urgency to
tackle this this is a crisis that's
affecting all of our people yeah yeah so
finally conclusion manufacturer speaker
there's some other things actually that
works in the queen speech that certainly
for an area like mine need to be we need
to get the infrastructure right housing
but a city like cambridge to prosper in
the future drive the uk economy we've
got to get the housing right we've got
to get the transport right that means
stop prevaricating about east west rail
finish it off directly to cambridge and
finally stop playing into universities
universities are one of our great
success stories just look at the the
research excellent framework results on
the last few days proving that point
it's something we're really good at we
do not need to be picking fights with
one another having pointless arguments
stoking up culture wars concentrate on
what we're good at start
celebrating universities and i would
just say um to the party opposite look
at some of the press reports over the
weekend they're quite right that
graduates graduates are voting a certain
way frankly we are the future yeah
andrew bridges thank you madam deputy
speaker and uh the title of this
evening's debate is making britain the
best place to grow up and grow old but
it needs to be seen against the backdrop
of our recent uh covid pandemic and the
recovery from it throughout the pandemic
we've been with rightly been drawn
parallels with surviving a war indeed
often it was called the the battle
against covid whether it was
the coming together of our nation at the
beginning of the pandemic the shows of
national unity demonstration of national
unity as we appreciate the key workers
that delivered all those services that
we needed
or whether it was the unprecedented roll
out
with volunteers of health programs to
protect the vulnerable
or whether it was the eye-watering cost
of the expenditure
and every year in november we have a day
to remember those who gave their lives
in war and we rightly know that's a debt
that we can never repay but i'm
conscious madam deputy speaker that
there are also millions of people in our
society today who we owe a debt to as a
result of the lockdowns and the
privations of covid that must also be
repaid
and they are our children our young
people
we knew all along that those millions of
children and young people were at the
very least risk of the virus yet we
still as a house consciously chose to
lock them away for the safety of others
and they have suffered i've heard from
young adults who've never got the chance
to do those things that seem as a right
of passage for young people and define
points of their lives many have never
experienced the pressure of having to
take exams and they're not sure if
they've got the resilience to be able to
cope with it
others worry that their teacher assessed
grades may be seen as devalued
qualifications
they didn't get to go to the proms they
didn't get to go to their end of year
assembly didn't get say goodbye to their
friends
all these things both small and large
help prepare them
for the challenges of adulthood despite
the fact that as a whole they were
incredibly low risk from the virus
i do fear for their mental health and i
fear for their resilience moving forward
and madam deputy speaker we owe them
i've heard from secondary schools in my
constituency you told me that children
moving up to them are far behind what
the professionals would expect them to
be at both academically and socially
giving children laptops to work from
home during lockdowns was all well and
good but not always was the work
appropriate and without the correct
parental support
for some parents just didn't have the
skills to support their children as we
all the time as
as we would like them to have done once
again these children were at little risk
and they've had precious years of their
education taken away from them to
protect others and we owe we owe them
madame destiny speaker
there are infants starting out their
educational journey far behind normal
development targets local nurseries
telling me the children can't toilet
themselves they're lacking social skills
and confidence
they've got the longest time to catch up
but catch up they must or they will bear
the scars of the covid pandemic longer
than any of us
primary schools they're also noting
deficits and social skills in all years
but significantly in year two
those children who've lost their
foundation years due to covid so crucial
for their development
and for those who didn't receive
sufficient parental support the damage
is even harder
government must legislate to ensure
every opportunity is made available for
our children and young people to catch
up over the term the price they'll be
paying will be higher than any of us
with minimal risk to them they've lost
huge opportunities in a civilized
society
madame deputy speaker i expect adults to
make sacrifices for our children and
young people i do not expect our
children young people to make sacrifices
to us
we have a debt to them and it must be
repaid and all government legislation
must take into account
the damage we've done through pandemic
recovery to our children and and young
people because our children and young
people
they are the future of our country and
they need to be protected thank you
murray rimmer thank you
thank you madam deputy speaker for too
long social care has been neglected the
pressures and strains on the nhs and
social care are ever growing with half a
million people waiting for care
assessments
people are living longer and with more
complex needs yet the funding to social
care has not kept pace the queen's
speech offers nothing to fix social care
most aging people who require code do
not want to go move into a car home or
be taken into hospital very often
because they've not had care at home and
most of the time they don't need to go
into hospital most of the care can be
given at home including some health
services
elderly people would much rather be in
their homes close to their families and
friends for this to happen there needs
to be adequate social care and health
funding
people should be able to age with
dignity in the place they want to be
this is about the quality of the people
of life that people deserve as they grow
older
and this can happen if the government
invests resources in the social care to
meet the needs in the social care sector
would prevent most people being
hospitalized and saved many beds within
the national health service
there are currently six million people
waiting for nhs treatment
one of the best ways to free up more
resources in the in the hospitals and
gps is by providing adequate social care
for the elderly prevent not necessarily
doctors to go out on hospitals at beds
cintellin's adult social care and
clinical care commission have integrated
and developed systems uh systems that
include police housing probation
services and this all goes to helping to
keep people where they want to be and to
give them care and to prevent them
leading
care
and it also frees up beds in hospitals
for other services
this can be done where health
achievements can be given at home they
should be able to stay in their own
homes elderly people
the national insurance level will not
resolve this issue
if social care was respected and funded
correctly i say again it would free up
hospital beds and nhs capacity funding
the nhs without adequately funding
social care will not fix the problem
we cannot have a fully functioning
health service without a fully
functioning social care system
local authorities have had their budgets
consistently cut for over a decade and
even with the allowed additional social
care levy and most of them have levied
this this doesn't scratch the surface of
the needs of the problem of social care
according to the local government
association over 57 of council tax
funding already goes on social care
which is already the top priority for
local authorities
yet there is only so much they can do
without a government given the support
that is needed
social care is a statute of duty for
councils it is a moral duty for society
and most importantly it is the
responsibility of government to look
after the public
a social care system that is adequately
funded frees up gps and other nhs
resources
social care has been the elephant in the
room for decades it needs sorting out
and needs sorting out properly and not
from a heavy hand down it needs
developing upwards
the country cannot afford the government
he's continued kicking the can down the
road and i urge government to face up to
its responsibilities and fund and
respect social care and our elderly and
disabled people
dr lisa cannon
many thanks madam deputy speaker and
then thinking about how to make the uk
the best place to grow up and grow
as chair of the disability all party
parliamentary group i've been thinking
particularly about
inclusive growth and levelling up for
people with disabilities
i saw a fantastic example of this at the
weekend in my constituency in east coal
bride where sports scotland had
partnered with south atlantic shower
leisure and culture to train local
organizations who work in sports
to make sure that they're engaging with
people with disabilities and encouraging
them to
to engage and to reach their full
potential through the group activities
and the sports activities that are
available
because only when uh when growth and
when the work that we do is inclusive to
all can we make sure that we leave no
one behind and ensure that we're doing
our job here and i want to ask mps can
we do more
what are we doing in parliament because
when the all-party parliamentary group
looked at
including people with disabilities on
work experience in our offices we
started off at 11
of mps who were registered as accredited
disability confident employers now
through a workshop the all parts
parliamentary group has increased this
to 24 and i want to thank everybody who
has been involved
in that achievement it's been so
fantastic to hear the accounts of people
uh who have engaged in work experience
and employment opportunities in mp's
offices and how that has really
fundamentally changed their lives and
the opportunities available to them but
we want to do more we want to reach at
least up to 50
this year and there will be further
workshops so please do look out for that
because this isn't just about the queen
speech and what government can do it's
what as individually as mps that we can
do and contribute more to make uh to
make the uk a much more inclusive place
and make sure that we are always giving
opportunities to everybody that we can
i also wanted to focus a bit on
well-being and equality and a well-being
economy because countries are now
starting to look at happiness and what
makes us happy
well-being happiness and quality of life
are becoming high priorities for many
governments and i believe that this
should be a high priority for this
government
there is a happiness institute in
copenhagen who are doing research onto
that um and i mean i've been looking at
their research and thinking why aren't
we happier we're lagging behind the
netherlands germany denmark
a number of countries who have people
who are feeling much happier in
themselves have greater levels of
well-being and
we have to think what makes people happy
what creates well-being it would be
lovely to see a happy minister
or perhaps a minister for happiness and
well-being and perhaps we could invite
perhaps we could invite uh the
researchers from the happiness institute
to come to speak to us about well-being
and how we can promote this right across
the united kingdom we know from their
research that economic hardship
financial hardship predicts unhappiness
so part of this is about equality but
it's also about physical inactivity
because this lowers quality of life for
people and also life expectancy access
to green spaces to play parks being able
to engage in the outdoors and we all
felt the the impact of that during
covered and how important it is but the
research is actually suggesting we
should pay even more attention to these
issues
mental health and depression is the
antithesis it poses a real threat to
well-being and doesn't just impact the
well-being of an individual but also
their whole family and their family life
so much more focused on mental health
services and low well-being in later
life has costs in health and social care
so we do need that holistic approach
the other interesting thing i noticed
was that homes are a big factor in
overall happiness or security in our
homes being able to live in a safe home
free from threat free from risk and
anti-social behavior so i think local
authorities have a huge role to play in
this and i'm sorry i'd only have a
minute and in making um social supports
and communities more available to people
is extremely important so i want the
government to also have a look at
well-being and happiness because with a
holistic approach
good lives make for happiness well-being
and it's also good economics
shadow secretary of state
thank you madam deputy speaker this has
been an
excellent and wide-ranging debate it's a
pleasure to follow the uh honorable lady
and and
say to my honorable friend the member
for saint helens it was a well worth the
wait um waiting for her speech on um on
the importance of rebalancing
the health and social care in order to
help us tackle the pressures on the nhs
we've had some fantastic speeches
disproportionate on this side of the
house i might say
my honourable friend the member for
washington and sunderland west
highlighted the increasingly poor
outcomes for people with special
educational needs and disabilities and
in particular the terrible injustice of
the inner growing inequality we see
between those who can pay for a
diagnosis and those who can't the
honourable members for
birmingham selly oak and brentford and
eiselworth both made wide-ranging
powerful speeches on this government's
failure on education catch-up on school
buildings on shawstark on so many
of the pillars of educational success
built by the last labour government
sadly eroded
under the last 12 years of conservative
government and my honourable friend the
member for lancaster and fleetwood
highlighted in particular the link
between mental health and educational
outcome and why it's so important to
prioritize mental health for children
and young people
the members for bradford south ellesmere
paul and cambridge all got their teeth
into the crisis in dentistry and not for
the first time my honourable friend the
member for bradford south has sounded
the alarm but maybe maybe uh the
secretary of state will listen uh to the
alarm she sounds if not my bad puns
the member for chester gave a tub
thumping speech rightly asking where the
employment bill is the the promised
employment rights that failed to
materialize he also made a powerful
argument for a full ban on con
conversion therapy if this is to be the
best place in the world for children to
grow up it's absolutely right that we
ban this abort practice it is not
therapy in the slightest and i pay
particular tribute to the members for
bishop auckland and birmingham
northfield who highlighted the
importance of this being an lgbt
conversion therapy ban and i applaud
them for making that case on the
government benches and as the memphis
birmingham northfield rightly said in
what i thought was a very entertaining
speech
today this country has already become
that little bit better place to grow up
in thanks to the courage of jake daniels
becoming the first male footballer to
come out since 1990 it really shouldn't
take courage in this day and age for a
footballer to say that they're gay in
fact it should really shouldn't be
relevant at all but sadly we know it is
and he has made himself a powerful role
model and i hope an example that others
will follow my honourable friend the
member for cambridge highlighted um the
crisis in the nhs and the life and death
consequences of the ambulance weights
asking where is the urgency a very fair
question i hope the secretary of state
will answer the member for louisiana
spoke powerfully about the experience of
young people in the criminal justice
system and then there were the speeches
about leveling up my honourable friend
the member for bedford highlighted the
gap between rhetoric and reality uh my
right normal friend the memphis kingston
upon whole i think um well summarized
this government's approach to leveling
up um
in terms of its planning reforms the
victim elder approach as she called it
leveling down for next doors
conservatory hardly the level of
ambition this country needs my
honourable friend for the from bradford
west highlighted that leveling up is a
slogan without substance although there
was a um a pretty well it depends on
your perspective the interesting effort
from the member for bosworth who offered
a new slogan in relation to the
government's planning policies in bed
with gove a mental image none of us
wanted
and on the left nonetheless left with at
this late hour
and then turning to some of the other
speeches from this side of the house and
the member for bradford west gave a
searing account of sorry gave a searing
account of poverty in his community and
he is right this is a matter of
political choices and we see the
consequences of those political choices
and the speeches of my other honourable
friends my noble friend the memphis and
west norwood highlighted the
disaster of children growing up in
overcrowded temporary accommodation with
huge consequences for their learning and
for their life chances my honorable
friend the member for swansea east
having to run summer holiday lunch cubs
and and christmas hamper schemes because
of the grotesque level of poverty in her
constituency my honourable friend the
member for nottingham south describing
the embarrassment the humiliation
of parents who are unable to provide for
their children whose children share
their parents anxiety about how to make
ends meet and so don't even tell their
to don't even tell their parents that
they're required to bring in some extra
kit for school whether in cooking
cooking classes or an extra ask for
school trips it is a thoroughly
damning indictment of this government
and if i may say as the son of a single
mom
i was i was really moved by my honorable
friend the member for makerfield
describing her experience and if only it
was as simple as ministers claimed on
the morning round this morning that you
can just put in a few extra hours or
maybe take on a better pay job if only
it were that simple but it is it is not
as simple as just going out and finding
more hours in fact in the case of many
of our constituents they are already
working three jobs how many more jobs
how many more hours do you want them to
take on of course the i hope people
forgive me the very best speech was
given by my honorable friend the member
for erdington who gave her maiden speech
today we dearly dearly miss her her
predecessor our dear friend jack dromey
but i know he would have been proud to
see her make that speech today as we all
were madame deputy speaker this is a
great country with a world of
opportunity i'm glad that i was born in
britain but this is also a country that
is being held back by intolerable levels
of inequality and by a government that
is simply unable to face up to the scale
of the challenge half a million more
children are set to be plunged into
poverty following the chancellor's
spring statement two million adults are
going full days without meals many more
are relying on food banks to feed
themselves and their families as i found
when i went around the country in the
local election campaign including in
colchester where the food bank told me
that they were seeing nhs nurses coming
in to access the food bank pension of
poverty is once again on the rise with
out-of-control bills a real terms cut to
the state pension and national insurance
rises meaning that working pensioners
will be over 1200 pounds worth of worse
off over the next two years and of
course the cost of living crisis isn't
just a treasury issue it's a health
issue too if millions of people in this
country face a choice of whether to heat
their homes or eat regular meals they
either get sick or fail to recover if
they've been sick
and before we entered this pandemic
average life expectancy had stalled for
the first time in decades
stalled life expectancy surely the most
basic measure
of the progress of a country of the
progress of a society and it's a mark of
shame that in 2022 in the sixth richest
nation on earth five thousand people
were admitted to hospital for
malnutrition
in the last six months
cases of scurvy have doubled since 2010
scurvy 12 years of conservative
governments
ushering in the return of dickensian
diseases to britain
what kind of country have we become when
millions of people who work full time
still can't afford the basics
the british people deserve a government
on their side instead we have the only
government in the g7 which thinks that
now is a good time to raise taxes on
working people a government which is
happy to add to working people's tax
burden but as we know from members of
the cabinet spend plenty of time
avoiding paying their own
the government promised 38 new pieces of
legislation yet not a single one is
going to put more money into people's
pockets all they have to offer families
struggling today are sneering lectures
telling them to work harder find a
second or third job or put themselves in
for a cookery class and we've seen their
approach when challenged on the cost of
living blame the people play blame the
bank of england blame anyone but
themselves and even when challenged
about his own spring statement that
plunges half a million more people into
poverty what was the chances excuse the
computer said no well that didn't stop
him taking 20 quid a week off the
poorest people in our country did it it
worked then surely it works now
britain deserves better we need a
government that understands what life is
like for most people in this country if
we had such a government we wouldn't
have the education secretary talking
about the imbalance the tipping of the
balance in favor of private schools i
mean who's he trying to kid
defending seven percent of people who go
to private schools who are going to have
a brilliant world of opportunities
available to them but failing to stand
up for the 93
who don't
and let me tell him about tipping the
balance as someone who received free
school meals went through the state
education system and made it to
cambridge university i was one of just
one percent on kids of kids on free
school meals to make it to cambridge
university and i'm proud that i got
there but don't tell kids from state
schools who are making it now who are
being finally judged on their merits
don't tell them that that somehow the
system's been tilted in their favor when
they know full well from their life
experience their childhood their growing
up under a conservative government that
his party and his colleagues opposite
have done everything they can to tilt
the balance in favor of people like him
from backgrounds like theirs at the
expense of people from backgrounds like
mine that's the truth madam deputy
speaker and what the education secretary
doesn't understand it is that it's not
talent or potential that's unevenly
distributed in this country it's
opportunity participation and
extracurricular activities is falling in
state schools fewer children are doing
sports drama and music and the least
well-off children are three times more
likely to do no extracurricular
activities at all they may accept this
poverty of ambition for our children the
labour party will not just as we rebuilt
the education system under the last
labour government so we'll have the same
level of ambition for the next labour
government and i say to my honorable
friend for swansea i'm very sorry to
disappoint her but we're going to be
putting her and her lunch clubs out of
business because the next labor
government will work to end child
poverty not increase it
turning to health madam deputy speaker
there was just one mention of health in
the queen's speech the long-awaited
overhaul of the mental health act the
changes proposed are welcome but this
legislation alone will not solve the
challenges facing people living with
severe mental illness
reverse this government's persistent
neglect of mental health services nor
narrow the gaping mental health
inequalities that see black people over
four times more likely to be detained
under the existing act our mental health
services simply do not meet the scale of
the challenge a quarter of beds for
patients struggling with poor mental
health have been cut over the last 12
years one in every three children who
seek support from mental health services
are turned away at the door 1.6 million
people in total are waiting for
treatment waiting too long and those who
are offered treatment are often sent to
the other end of the country because
there aren't local beds and services
available
people struggling with poor mental
health won't get the support we need if
we don't have enough frontline staff
that's why labour's plan would guarantee
mental health treatment within a month
to all who need it
done by investing in an additional eight
and a half thousand staff and offering
specialist mental health support in
every school and because politics is
about choices madame deputy speaker let
me be clear about the choices we would
make we would pay for that mental health
support for every child in the country
by removing the vat exemption from
private schools and closing tax
loopholes for private equity fund
managers now i know the education sector
is pitching himself as a defender of
private school privilege ahead of the
next conservative leadership election
and the health secretary
and the health secretary and the health
secretary may well have benefited from
these tax loopholes himself
and let me tell them opposite they'll be
a con let me tell them madame deputy
speaker let me tell them
let me tell them let me tell them
there'll be a conservative leadership
election a lot sooner there'll be a
labor leadership election let me tell
you let me tell you
but i hope we can agree that mental
health is one of the most urgent needs
of our time particularly after the
pandemic which was difficult for so many
and i'm glad the health secretary is
here to respond madam deputy speaker
because i'd like him to account for his
government's record patience being made
to wait longer than ever before as we
sleep walk towards a two-tier system
that betrays the founding principles of
our nhs the self pay health care market
in the uk has doubled since 2010 people
forced to go private because they won't
get the treatment they need billions
more spent on private insurance and
operations private health care providers
rubbing their hands together because
they know that people are increasingly
choosing to jump the queue while the
rest are left to wait for up to two
years for care and of course the health
secretary let me save him some time it
will tell us that our nhs is suffering
from a covert backlog and the problems
facing the health service are all the
result of the pandemic there is a
backlog in the nhs madam deputy speaker
but it is a conservative backlog
the nhs was experiencing record waiting
lists going into the pandemic it was a
hundred thousand staff short with a hund
another 112 000 vacancies in social care
suspected cancer patients have been
waiting long to be seen every single
year since labor left office and not
only was there just one piece of
legislation across health and social
care but as i mentioned the government's
dropped its long promised uh employment
bill so what does the secretary of state
say to the millions of family carers in
this country promised a week's carers
leave just one week a year to have a
break but let down and left waiting
again and again and again by this
government the fact is madame deputy
speaker the longer we give the
conservatives in office the longer
patients will wait
longer for a gp appointment
longer for an ambulance to arrive now
two hours for thousands of heart attack
and stroke victims longer for an
operation with some patients waiting
since before the pandemic began and
longer for pensioners and the disabled
to wait for suitable social care we're
paying more we're waiting longer that's
the conservative record and the longer
we give the conservatives in office the
longer britain waits well madame deputy
speaker their time is up
[Applause]
before i call the secretary of state can
i just emphasize how important it is
that people get back in good time for
the wind-ups it's extremely discourteous
to the front bench and others who've
participated in the debate if people are
late and in some cases are not here at
all it has been noted secretary of state
thank you madam deputy speaker it's an
honor to close this debate on the loyal
address and in this platinum jubilee
year let me extend my thanks to her
majesty the queen for her years of
dedicated service
may i i also thank all honourable and
right honourable members from across
this house who have taken part in this
debate today but i do have to say madam
deputy speaker i'm disappointed by the
shadow secretary of state for help
how he has taken this once again as an
opportunity to talk down britain as he
as as he so often does and also choosing
instead to use this debate as a naked
leadership pitch for his own party he
even used the words madame deputies he
talked about leadership bids in his uh
debate just now it because he is he has
no ideas no ideas at all how to improve
the the society for for british people
no ideas at all and he knows that we're
both both of us we had to fight to get
our foot in through the door he knows
that our chances to succeed come from
this country's world-class public
services yet he stands there madam
deputy speaker and he has the audacity
to attack my right honourable friend the
secretary of state for education who
came to this country as an 11 year old
immigrant in this country and rose to
the position that he has today and by
the way madam deputy speaker he could
only rise to that position in the
conservative party
[Applause]
i speak with feeling about this country
madam deputy speaker because for my
family coming to britain was a choice
too they came here for freedom for
security for opportunity and for
prosperity they came here because they
believe britain is the best place in the
world to grow up and to grow old they
were right then and they are right today
public i i will give way in a moment
public services have been a lifeline for
me and my family the teachers who made
my career possible the police officers
who kept me and my family safe and the
nhs who cared for my father in his dying
days this queen's speech backs our
public services it invests in them and
it reforms them to secure the future of
britain and unlike the honourable
gentleman opposite i've always been an
optimist about britain's future
i'll give way to the only lady here 50
hour ambulance waiting time is that
world beating yeah
no of course it's not madame deputy
speaker and i'll come on to that in a
moment she knows full well why the nhs
is facing its most challenging time in
history now madam deputy speaker
being being
being the best place to grow up and to
grow old on relies on keeping people
safe keeping them safe from disease we
rose to the challenges of the pandemic
brexit gave us the mindset to license
and deploy a vaccine against covert 19
quicker than any other country the
phenomenal nhs got jabs into every part
of the uk
and it was the wisdom of the british
people that has meant that we have one
of the highest vaccination rates
anywhere in the world and not only that
random deputy speaker we created a
juggernaut of a testing and surveillance
system we bought
more antivirals per head than any other
country in europe and we got it right on
omicron with the most successful booster
program in europe and as a result of all
this we were the first country in europe
to remove all restrictions
and had we listened had we listened to
the party opposite
had we listened to them we would have
been shackled to the eu on vaccines
and
and
and our schools
our schools would have been shuttered
for even longer contrary to what the
honorable lady had to say in her
comments in this debate but instead
because this government got the big
calls right we're leading the world when
it comes to living with coving
now madam deputy speaker from clinics to
classrooms the pandemic showed the
wealth of our skills the skills mission
is a job for the whole of government in
his opening my right honourable friend
he outlined our ambitions for the new
schools bill to deliver a stronger
school system that works for every child
as as talked about in this debate today
by my honourable friend from russ slip
when he talked about academy trusts and
my honourable friend for truro and
falmouth when she talked about the
importance of early years we've also are
delivering with a higher education
freedom of speech bill which will
reverse the chilling effect of no
platforming in our world-class
institutions
while our higher education reform bill
promises to promises that bring about a
fairer and more sustainable future
and i think my honorable friend i
listened carefully my old friend from
northwest leicestershire when he talked
passionately about putting our children
and our young people first
madam deputy speaker a skills-rich
economy is about more than just the
elite institutions i'm a product of
filton technical college it ignited my
desire to go to university and help
bring me where i am today this is a
government that treats further education
colleges with the seriousness that they
deserve and when i was chancellor i was
proud to put an additional 400 million
pounds into further education in this
country because madam deputy speaker
this is a great country to grow up and
to grow old and a great country to stay
skilled in as my right on my honourable
friend for bexley heath said himself in
the debate earlier today as well now
allow me madden deputy to turn also to
health care
this government passionately believes in
the nhs and its founding principles in a
world-class health care system that is
free at the point of access for everyone
funding from the levy which the party
opposite voted against on top of uh
on top of the historic long-term nh
settlement that was announced in 2018
means that the nhs resource budget in
england will increase to
162.6 billion pounds by
2024-25 that is the highest ever budget
the nhs has had that includes it
includes an additional eight billion
pounds over the next three years to
tackle those covert backlogs
and in a fast-changing world with an
aging population we need to embrace of
course new ways of thinking and and a
number of my honorable friends they
refer to that today about the investment
we're making the my honorable friend
from bosworth and i also listened
carefully when we were talking uh
talking about nhs vestment for my
honourable friend from northwest norfolk
who i think made a very powerful case
and that's why madam deputy speaker when
it comes to the nhs where we are
we set out our plans to tackle the
covert 19 backlogs we've legislated for
a new health and care act and we've
published an integration white paper it
is also why we have an upcoming digital
and data strategy where we're setting
out a new 10-year cancer plan and i
listed i can't see him in his place but
the honourable member the honourable
gentleman for westmoreland and lonsdale
when he talked about the importance of
the importance of cancer and we've got a
we're setting out a new 10-year plan to
improve mental health a number of uh
honourable members talked about rightly
the importance of mental health
including my honorable friend from
aylesbury who who speaks with passion on
this subject especially when it comes to
the mental health of children we are
also publishing uh very soon a health
disparities white paper which i hope
will be welcomed by the honorable right
honourable lady the members of for
kingston upon hull when she rightly
talked about the importance of of
leveling up and we will soon be
publishing the review the outcome of the
review into health and social care
leadership we're also bringing the
mental health act into the 21st century
that was uh but we're going to as we
said in the queen speech there will be a
draft mental health act ensuring that
those in mental health crisis are
treated as people not patients a number
of honorable members talk passionately
about mental health and and especially i
listened to the honourable lady for
birmingham erdington uh and uh
i want to welcome to her to her place uh
in the house and i do agree uh with
something that the honourable gentleman
said earlier when he said that we all
cross this house we we miss jack jeromey
her priesthood predecessor we miss him
uh very much but i i know that had he
listened to that speech he'd be very
very proud of of of of what she said i
think she spoke with passion and pride
about her community and i and i know
that she served for many years for over
two decades in the nhs and when she
talks about mental health she talks uh
with experience and i know that she will
have much of value to say in this house
over the years ahead of very much
welcome her to her place and and and
madam deputy speaker when it comes to
the nhs again a number of um colleagues
made very important contributions my
honorable friend uh for sleeping talked
about the investment in community
diagnostic centers and a number of uh
colleagues across the house the
honourable lady from bradford south and
you're my honourable friend from north
devon talked about the importance of uh
dentistry and the need to keep up uh
investment at the heart of our strategy
for the nhs is prevention
personalization performance and people
for prevention for example it means
focusing much more on on the biggest
killers of you know of tobacco of
obesity of alcohol my honorable friend
on stoke on trent central she talked
about the importance of continuing to
tackle obesity and when it comes to
personalization that means making more
use where you care of community services
something i know that my honourable
friend for devices would welcome and
when it comes to people there are now
more doctors and nurses working in the
nhs today than ever before we're on
track to deliver 50 000 more nurses by
the end of this parliament and we have a
record number of medical students in
england the fact is madam deputy speaker
the opposition has no plans for the nhs
they have no plans for the nhs they
voted against our plan to secure
resources for the nhs and they have no
idea about how to meet the challenges of
the future and now madam deputy speaker
when it comes to adult social care we
are also transforming its provision
we're investing an additional 5.4
billion pounds over the next three years
we're introducing a more generous means
testing system by more than quadrupling
the upper savings threshold to 100 000
pounds we're protecting more people from
the lottery of catastrophic care costs
and we're putting half a billion pounds
behind our social care workforce and i
hope the uh the honourable lady for
saint helen south will welcome this
record investment she talked about adult
social care and i hope her and others
will recognize that this is record
investment see these changes matter
because whether you whether you are
growing old or you're working age adult
social care is there for all of us
something that my honorable friend for
high peak also talked about i will give
way to the honourable lady i thank the
health sector for giving way and um can
i ask him what he plans uh to do for the
victims of sodium valkyrie who live with
lifelong
care needs
the health minister today she met with
uh some of the victims uh of of that and
uh there are plans that we are looking
closely at and when we are ready we will
come uh to this house
now
madame deputy before i close let me just
there were a number of other issues that
were raised by honourable members my
honorable friend uh friends from red car
and uh enos mon they raised they both
praised the energy security bill and
obviously right to do so a very
important piece of legislation that this
country has long needed and my
honourable friend for bishop auckland uh
she rightly welcomed the investment and
increase in police numbers and lastly i
i did uh listen carefully to the
honourable lady from east
bride about the importance of happiness
i agree with her unhappiness but i do
want to assure the the government
benches are full of happy ministers
there's plenty of them i i i don't think
we need any more and and to
and to to to close uh madden deputy
speaker uh her majesty's most noble
speech sets out a positive vision of
freedom of security of opportunity and
of prosperity it matches the ideals that
brought my family to this country that
this is and will continue to be the best
country in the world to grow up and to
grow old unlike the party opposite we
are optimists about britain's future
the choice is clear madam deputy speaker
the choice for the country is clear
between a government with an ambitious
vision for the country and an opposition
without a plan we will provide the
leadership that this country needs and i
commend this queen's speech to the house
i beg to move that the debate would be
now adjourned
the question is that the debate be now
adjourned as many as our of that opinion
say aye
of the country no
i think the eyes have it the eyes have
it debate to be resumed what day
tomorrow tomorrow
thank you
i beg to move this house to our journey
the question is that this house do now
adjourn
sarah atherton
thank you
thank you madam deputy speaker and it's
an honor to have been granted this
german debate on wrexham's bid for the
city of culture 2025
firstly we are thrilled to be in the
final four
with the title within touching distance
bradford southampton and county durham
are good bids and colleagues from across
the house have put forward very
convincing arguments
however there is one key difference that
sets wrexham apart from the other three
and that difference is wales
if wrexham were to become the city of
culture 2025 it would be the first welsh
winner of the title since the inception
of the competition
and as a proud unionist as i know
a few of us are on this side
a welsh winner would highlight the
commitment of this government to the
union and talking of firsts wrexham has
had a few
i am the first conservative female mp to
be elected for wales and in 2019
uh 2019 was the first ever time wrexham
turned blue
and we're going for a hat-trick modern
deputy speaker by hoping wrexham is
named city of culture the first in wales
of course one huge element of this bid
is that we have the welsh language as
our trump card
and since many responsibilities are
devolved in wales to the welsh labour
government in cardiff the city of
culture bid represents a unique
opportunity for the whole of the uk to
celebrate the individualism of wales and
its proud language and culture whilst
also celebrating its importance as part
of our union
now wrexham has a diverse population
with over 70 languages spoken
the largest being our polish community
who recently mobilized
to send aid to you to ukraine working
with local businesses to facilitate
nearly two million pounds worth of
donations
working with each other for the
betterment of wrexham is what we do
wrexham's culture bid has involved over
200 stakeholders with 50 grants being
awarded to community organizations to
participate and we have held over 90
city of culture events already
now wrexham is a town built on brewing
football and mining
to take football which is very topical
right at this moment wrexham athletic
football club is on a high and on sunday
i will be cheering on the reds at the fa
trophy final against bromley at wembley
and of course we'll win but of course
you would have to have your eye off the
ball to have missed the fact that
wrexham athletic football club is now
owned by hollywood actors ryan reynolds
and rob mcelhenny
wrexham has certainly been put on the
map rob and ryan we're not mbfs just yet
but i'm working on it rob and ryan know
the importance
i beg to move this house do now journey
the question is this house to now agent
sarah atherton
robin ryan my nbfs nearly
they know the importance of football to
wrexham i want to nurture and champion
that
and as the minister knows from a visit a
while back the home of wrexham athletic
football club
is the historical racecourse ground
and is in some ways the headquarters of
our town the racecourse ground is the
oldest international football ground in
the world and has um and has been used
to host international matches when wales
hosted the rugby world cup in 1999 the
wrexham race course was filled with over
16 000 funds from around the world
international gains have not been seen
on that scale since
mainly because the capacity no longer
allows this unlike everyone in wrexham
and the whole of north wales i am
passionate about returning international
sporting events to north wales the
redevelopment of the historic cop stand
which i am campaigning for as part of
wrexham's leveling up fund bid will
allow for an extra five and a half
thousand spectators which will then
permit the hosting of international
sporting events
and madam deputy speaker if you'd like
to sign our petition please click onto
change.org
for the redevelopment of the racecourse
stand to create a stadium for the north
all signatures welcome
our aim is to make wrexham the home of
welsh football hollywood investment the
arrival of the national football museum
for wales commitment by the welsh fa and
the redevelopment of the cop stand
fingers crossed could all make this a
reality
another founding pillar of rexum is
brewing
rexella was founded in 1881 and is the
staple of the town it is steeped in
fascinating history and as a former
brewer myself rexella is not only close
to my heart but my taste buds
the brewing the brewery and
exemplifies wrexham's business and
trading prowess
it was one of the first internal
international exports from wrexham
imported to the americas in the 1800s
served as the only beer on the titanic
it went down well
and is a firm favorite of the royal navy
and that brings me nicely onto the
significance of wrexham's military
history
a military town with a proud veteran
community of which i am one high town
barracks was the home of the royal welsh
fusiliers dating back to 1689.
and hightown barracks was only to billet
a residual military presence until last
year when the mod recognized wrexham's
military significance and returned a
reserve unit of the royal welsh back to
hightown barracks
under the future pro
soldier program i'm grateful to the
secretary of state for defence my rat
honourable friend for weir and preston
north for affirming his commitment to
wrexham and north wales
on the final pillar of wrexham as i see
it i must mention the importance of
mining to wrexham wrexham was a proud
mining town which was rocked in 1934
by the grassroot man disaster where 266
men lost their lives and we are fiercely
proud of our mining heritage and look
forward to commemorate
commemorating this further in the future
and finally i would like to touch on
rex's potential
wrexham is brimming with talent
especially stem expertise wockhart uk
won the uk government's contract to
bottle the astrazeneca vaccine at the
start of the pandemic
wrexham is hugely proud to have played a
part in the whole of the uk vaccine
program
the vaccine was produced in england
bottled in wales trialled in northern
ireland and rolled out in scotland
and with a growing industrial estate due
to ever increasing inward investment and
soon to be the largest in the united
kingdom wrexham will be the envy of the
world and be known for its stem
innovation manufacturing and skills
and we are growing our own talent with
wrexham's glendora university and
colleague cambria both in the town
and we have ever increasing number of
job vacancies on offer
furthering our home-grown talent we have
expanded our health care training in
wrexham for example our new nursing
campus at the university and nursing
cadet training at the college
all of whom train at our local hospital
the wrexham mailer where i trained as a
nurse some decades ago and returned
during the pandemic
in terms of art music and tourism
wrexham has a mass on offer
only last week it was announced that
t-pow had been shortlisted for art fund
museum of the year and two weeks ago
fifteen thousand people descended on
wrexham to enjoy the focus wales music
festival which showcased emerging welsh
talent
and crowds have always been attracted to
our unesco heritage site the
pontessachty viaduct
which recently received 13 million
pounds of uk government levelling up
fund investment to ensure its future
and many more enjoy the grand house of
ervig and chirp castle
in fact
of the seven wonders of wales three are
in wrexham saint jose's church dates
back to the 15th century the yew trees
of overton and the bells of grassford
church where i got married
and i would like to put on record my
thanks to the uk government for already
committing in the leveling up fund white
paper to moving civil servant service
jobs to rexem with the cps and hmp
berwin nearby i am pleased that the
ministry of justice
is setting up a hub and that is starting
to develop
and to sum up madam deputy speaker the
benefits of rex to wrexham are being
named city of culture 2025 are endless
it would bring recognition to our
beautiful town
unmatched investments something wrexham
has not seen for 20 years and strengthen
our union
and when i got elected in 2019 my goal
was to put rexum on the map
decades of labour neglect left wrexham
deflated there will never be a better
moment for rexum to be recognized
recognised as a hidden gem brimming with
history
pride potential and passion
to me the bid of city of culture is not
only about historical accolades or how
many famous singers architects or
artists came from a place it's about
what wrexham is achieving now
and can achieve
it's about its people
and its potential
and wrexham has that in bucket loads
it just needs someone to unlock it
and this government has the key to do
that rexem
we rise together the other vow
here
it is
well thank you madam deputy speaker and
i thank my honourable friend the member
for wrexham for securing this debate and
she is rightly championing wrexham as
she always does and is justly proud that
the county borough was the only place in
wales as she said that was shortlisted
in this fierce competition for the
highly coveted uk city of culture title
the title previously held by derry
londonderry whole and currently coventry
is a growing prize
and a record 20 places applied this year
this is the final debate secured for the
four shortlisted places bidding for the
2025 title and i'd like to briefly
reflect on the passion with which all
honourable members spoke about their
constituencies they highlighted the
incredible heritage and cultural assets
of which people are proud across the
whole of the united kingdom they spoke
of the dedication of their bidding teams
the ambition for positive change and
their sheer number of partners that have
come together to support their place and
while this is a competition it is worth
acknowledging the transformative power
of culture in all places not just the
winners
and this is why the uk city of culture
program is a key part of dto messi's
efforts to level up opportunity right
across the uk
it's a proven model for harnessing
culture and creativity to attract
investment and tourism to bring people
together drive economic growth positive
social change and regeneration
and the title is unique in its holistic
nature it galvanizes partners across
sectors to ensure systematic change
promotes social cohesion and well-being
and creates a shared vision with
multiple outcomes the competition was
inspired by the success of liverpool
when it had the european capital of
culture into 2008 and it was designed
and is delivered by dcms in
collaboration with the devolved
administrations this government has
recently announced that it will be a
permanent quadrennial competition
continuing in 2029 and beyond and i'm
delighted that some of the unsuccessful
bidders in the current competition have
already declared their intention to bid
again for the 2029 title
now my right honourable friend the lord
parkinson of whitley bay a minister for
arts has recently visited all of the
shortlisted places including of course
wrexham and has been hugely impressed
with the effort and ambition of bidding
teams and partners and as my honorable
friend mentioned i had the honour of
visiting rex and myself not so long ago
and had the opportunity to visit so many
of the local cultural establishments and
sites that she mentioned
now the impact of the title is evident
in the benefits felt by previous winners
more than 150 million pounds of public
and private sector investment was
invested into the 2013 winner derry
londonderry and the 2017 winner hull saw
5.3 million people visiting more than 2
800 events and coventry despite the huge
challenges posed by the pandemic has
developed an extraordinary program of
events that have put culture
at its heart and a part of the social
and economic recovery
co-created projects have taken place in
all 18 wards in the city with thousands
of community dancers musicians poets and
makers participating
and the city has seen more than 172
million pounds invested in the likes of
music concerts public art displays the
new telegraph hotel a new children's
player in the city centre and
improvements to public transport
and coventry's year will culminate in
radio 1's big weekend at the end of may
it's no wonder therefore that there were
more initial applications for the 2025
title than ever before
wrexham county borough along with the
three other locations bradford county
durham and southampton
was approved by the secretary of state
to make the shortlist for 2025.
all the bids have been scrutinized by
the expert advisory panel which is
chaired by sir phil redmond and will be
continuing to assess the finalists
against criteria such as place making
leveling up uk and international
cooperation opening up access to culture
and creating a lasting legacy
and the panel has now visited the
shortlist and will make their final
recommendation to dcms ministers
following a presentation from each place
this very week
and the winner will then be announced in
coventry later this month
[Applause]
now as my honorable friend
has said so eloquently wrexham county is
a proud and passionate region with
substantial cultural assets for one it
boasts a unesco world heritage site the
pontius [ __ ]
aqueduct uh hope i pronounced that right
or close it's the tallest aqueduct in
the world
and the colour splash on the bib team
logo represents coal dust as a tribute
to rexum's industrial past as my
boyfriend mentioned and while the colors
used are to represent the vibrancy and
diversity of everyone who lives works
and plays in wrexham
wrexham is indeed world renowned for its
textiles bricks beer mining and much
else and of course is also home to the
world's third oldest professional
football team afc wrexham and the club's
recent takeover has attracted immense
international interest and support
now unfortunately madam deputy speaker i
uh last visited wrexham just before the
acquisition of wrexham football club by
hollywood stars ryan reynold uh ryan
reynolds and rob
mcelhenny and therefore also missed out
on the opportunity to visit the emerging
major tourist attraction that is the
urinal in the gents toilets which was a
gift um
to uh to to rob uh on his birthday from
ryan reynolds and i'm sure and confident
that this major cultural attraction will
form the centerpiece of the 2025 city of
culture bid um or maybe not but uh they
gave me the opportunity to talk about
urinals in the chamber the house of
commons madame deputy speaker so i took
that opportunity um now of course
wrexham is a place of uh of myth and
legend
it's a place filled with music and
homegrown talent and i know that focus
wales one of the uk's leading music
showcase festivals welcomes over 15
thousand international artists industry
leaders and music fans from across the
world to to the county every single year
and wrexham's uk city of culture bid is
led by the county council alongside
partners from local businesses to
national trust wales and transport for
wales
wrexham's vision for 2025 includes
celebrating the region's cultural
diversity and becoming the uk capital of
play and i'm told that on the panel's
visit to wrexham the chair sir philip
redmond was persuaded by young people to
even take a turn on a zip wire
now the bid also aims to establish
wrexham as the home of football in wales
the north wales center um for trade and
events leaders in innovation and from
tomorrow to promote the welsh language
and heritage
wrexham's bid celebrates local and
national heritage as part of the bid
process the borough council awarded over
50 grants of up to a thousand pounds to
individuals and organizations to host a
multitude of events and projects to to
promote the county and planned
activities include the recreation of the
historic wrexham tableless quilt a
powerchair football event to highlight
wrexham's inclusive environment for
disability sports and a special fusion
event with african and welsh food
fashion and music
now as outlined in their website the
team also aims to establish a permanent
long-lasting legacy of socio-economic
benefits beyond their 2025 year
improving health and well-being and
educational outcomes
and as the only welsh region in the
competition the team anticipates that
should the bid be successful it would
have a positive impact on neighbouring
regions such as
dembyshire flintshire and powis are more
broadly across wales and in wrexham
itself regeneration of infrastructure
and the discussed public spaces is a
priority
now as the competition goes from
strength to strength for the first time
the eight long-listed places from across
the uk received a forty thousand pounds
grant each to support their application
ahead of the shortlisting stage and this
was intended to level the playing field
reduce the burden on the bidders and
help them to develop scalable plans and
i would like to take this opportunity to
thank all bidding places for
participating in this competition
as i alluded to earlier there are clear
benefits to all places that bid
this was evident from the visits that
have recently taken place to all the
shortlisted places the bidding process
engages and galvanizes a wide range of
local communities and organizations
resulting in enduring partnerships and
pride in place and the process
encourages places to develop a vision
and come together around ambitions for
change and it also attracts media
attention putting places on the map
for example hull was unsuccessful in
winning the 2013 title but came back to
win the 2017 title sunderland who bid
for the 2021 title created the momentum
to form a new arts trust sunderland
culture and this achieved enhanced arts
culture england funding and mobilized a
lasting team of
community volunteers paisley bid in the
2021 title and has since raised funds
for its museum and hosted a range of
major events including unboxed about us
and norwich bid in the 2013 title went
on to be unesco city of literature
now dcms wants all bidders to benefit
from the bidding process and we are
committed to working with those who do
not win to continue develop to develop
partnerships advance culture-led change
and strengthen cultural strategies as
well as to signpost upcoming
opportunities and funding
so i absolutely commend wrexham's
commitment to winning the uk city of
culture competition 2025 and i applaud
my honourable friends continuing
championing of wrexham and i wish all
the shortlisted bidders good luck in the
final stage of the competition
the question is that this house do now
adjourn as many as our of that opinion
say i the eyes have it order order
thank you
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons sound
house of commons